now the founder of the website wikileaks
the group that posted more than 91 000
classified military records relating to
the war in afghanistan
julian assange talks to reporters about
the release of the documents spanning
six years
he also discusses unreported incidents
of afghan civilian killings and covert
operations against the taliban contained
in the reports the guardian from this
morning
14
14 pages
about this topic
also concurrently in
the spiegel 17 pages
the new york times are not sure how many
international herald tribune and i
believe the telegraph also has it uh on
front page and i haven't uh checked into
the others
what do you say when people like the
white house accuse you of compromising
the security of troops in afghanistan by
virtue of this massive league
we're familiar with
groups whose abuse we expose
attempting to criticize the messenger to
distract
from the power of the message
and we don't see
any difference
in the white house's response to this
case
to the other groups that we have exposed
we have tried hard
to make sure that this material does not
put innocence at harm
all the material is
over seven months old so is of no
current operational consequence
even though it may be of very
significant investigative
uh consequence
thank you
um
i'm curious as to
whether you feel
i
at
here in the uk
as a result of this
from time to time we have
threat warnings from
our sources and
people in a position to know in
government and
some national security reporters we take
those seriously
in the west
we haven't felt a threat to our personal
safety
in kenya and
other parts of the developing world
unfortunately that has not always been
true
we do have surveillance events from time
to time and there have been more in the
past
few months
we understand
from the work of a national security
reporter
in australia that the australian
government
was asked
by the united states
to engage in certain forms of
surveillance
of my person and
other wikileaks people in australia
that source says most of
those requests were rejected by the
australian government
what do you think this does to the state
today with the uk
i think it's too early to say yet
it's clear that
it will shape
an understanding of what the past six
years of war has been like
uh and that the
course of the war needs to change the
manner in which it needs to change is
not yet clear
there's a number of issues obviously
but what do you think has been the most
standing revelation
i'm often asked this question what is
the most
single damning revelation what is the
thing that is easily
capturable the single event the single
personality the single mass killing
but that is not the real story of this
material the real story of this material
is that it's war it's one damn thing
after another
it is the continuous
small events the continuous
deaths of
children
insurgents
allied forces
the maimed people search for the word
amputation in this material or amputee
and there are dozens and dozens of
references
so this is the story of
the war since 2004
and like
most of the accidents that occur on the
road are as a result of cars
not of buses
most of the deaths in this war
are
as a result of the everyday squalor of
war
not the big incidences that said of
course
there are
reports with high kill counts
in this material for example a single
report
uh
taking place in
on august the 9th
2006
has a kill count of 181
one
wounded one
one wounded zero detained
what is the circumstance behind that
report well it's part of operation
medusa
but the full circumstance is not yet
known
according to the report an ac-130
gunship is a cargo plane which has been
fitted out with cannons all along one
side circled around for three hours and
killed 62 of those people
we add up all those deaths in that
report we get about 80.
the deaths of the other 100 are still
unexplained
there are many reports like that that
looks look very suspicious but the full
details are not yet explained
we can see
the behavior of task force
373
a special forces
assassination
squad a kill or capture squad
involved
in
pursuing the jpel the joint priority
effects list a euphemism for the
u.s
assassination list
killer capture list
in afghanistan
there are many events associated with
that
some that
resulted in the deaths of
one that results in the deaths of seven
children and others that result in the
deaths of
a number of other innocents
for that for that list we can also see
how people get on the list
they seem to be recommended by
regional governors in afghanistan or by
intelligence authorities often with it
appears little evidence and of course no
judicial review
um
how you came to cooperate with the new
york times guardian and the shield yeah
so i mean that's quite an interesting
journalistic story that we managed to
pull together these four groups sunshine
press wikileaks
the spiegel new york times and the
guardian
to share investigative resources we
shared
research stemming out of this material
not final stories but research and
computational techniques uh to deal with
this material
as equal partners
with the exception that
we controlled the embargo date and could
move that
back and forth
we
i spoke to
nick davies of the guardian uh he was
instrumental in
starting to broker
that arrangement and then we did it at
an editor-editor basis
um
between the uh alan rostrigger and the
editor of the spiegel and the editor of
new york times
that's a very good question um
the mod
this morning
are saying that
even they aren't able to verify
much of these documents
i'm sure the us would probably say the
same about other documents too at this
stage
how can you be sure that what's placed
up on the internet is accurate and if
some of it is not
doesn't that eat into
your legitimacy uh wikileaks because
it's wrong information and therefore
it's up there
if some of that information was
inaccurate uh that wouldn't eat into a
legitimacy quite correct
however we have never
released misdescribed material and i
don't expect this case to be any
exception
some people are suggesting that
lots of the intelligence or some of the
intelligence it's difficult to quantify
it came from low level came from people
who are are biased against different
absolutely and so how can you rely on
that how can you allow people to read
information
and placed up there as if it were truths
as far as you're concerned
when we publish material
what we say is
the document as we describe it is true
we publish cia reports all the time
that are legitimate cia reports that
doesn't mean
the cia is telling the truth
similarly with this material
there is reporting from
military units of various kinds in
afghanistan
reporting from u.s embassies
across the world
about
matters relevant to afghanistan
reporting from
informers in
pakistan
and afghanistan
those are legitimate reports
it doesn't mean
that the contents are true
some people should exercise caution
people should exercise caution and i'll
give you some examples of the ways in
which they should exercise caution
and we in fact do this if you go to war
wardiary.wikileaks.org you will see
how
how to read the material report
you will find that u.s military units
when self-reporting
of course often speak in ex-corporate
language
redefine civilian casualties as
insurgent casualties
downplay the number of casualties
and we know this by looking comparing
these reports to
the public record for where there has
been comprehensive investigations so as
an example kunduz
gorani for the kunduz report we see
the initial report from the field was
56
insurgents killed no civilians killed
but we know from later reportage
investigation in fact
most of the people killed were civilians
and there was some hundred and something
but when units report when military
units report on other military units
they are more likely to be frank
on other u.s military units
when they report on other allied units
that are not from the u.s military for
example on the polls or on the brits
they're even more likely
to tell the truth and of course
when they are reporting on the taliban
then all the evil comes out
similarly
when we look at reporting from
informers
we can see
sometimes completely outlandish claims
they just don't hold water
it will sometimes say that that
reporting is the result of the source
being paid it will sometimes there is a
rating system that
marines intelligence will give these
sources how reliable they think they are
so that is the
opinion of marines intelligence as to
marines g2 intelligence how reliable the
source is and how much you should take
away from it
um but just like dealing with any source
you should exercise
some common sense uh that doesn't mean
uh you should close your eyes
um what are the statements the white
house made immediately with regards to
the pakistani uh links
um the guidance was you've been sent and
says i don't think anyone who follows
this issue will find it surprising
i suppose that's what i found
about this whole thing that the detail
is stunning in the 191000 documents or
something and yet in the end there is so
much that
one doesn't find
entirely surprising i wonder if you've
concluded that at the end of all this
i'm following on from my colleague about
reliability do you find it in any way
suspicious that the documents that
you've got here are all labeled secret
but not top secret they're all fairly
low level field reports they come from
junior officers the only guy in jail is
a private first class i mean have you
again
any feeling that perhaps
you have reason to doubt the reliability
of these documents
we have no reason to doubt the
reliability of these documents
we should say what they don't include
they don't include top secret reports
they don't include
most reports from u.s special forces
they don't include reports by the cia
they don't include reports by
other coalition partners
however
they do include the majority of
regular us army activity
and where regular u.s army
overlaps in the activities
of other forces in afghanistan
it includes reports about their
activities so when
task force 373 the special forces
assassination squad
is involved in a raid it will often
partner
with regular us army forces and so there
are descriptions about its activities
similarly when the cia
is engaged in a raid
or
a u.s army bomb squad needs to be called
in or something like this you'll see oga
other government agency
a sort of cover
typically for the cia sometimes for the
dia defense intelligence agency
and you can see some information about
the behavior of the cia
through this overlap with regular us
army activity
surprised by the revelations
we have a harm minimization process our
goal is just reform our method is
transparency but we do not put
the method before the goal
we have a serious endeavor we do things
in policy we do not do things in an ad
hoc way
so so far our harm minimization
procedures have always worked to our
knowledge no one has ever been
physically harmed by the material we
have released
even though we have
uh caused the change
of governments and many other serious
reforms
just a quick follow-up
sorry
um
revelations in the future that the great
afghan civilian deaths would be greater
than those who revealed
i don't know enough about that policy to
to comment meaningfully
um i can only say
prima facie if uh restraints are reduced
there will be more civilian casualties
um you talk about the har minimization
policies and this is only relates to the
material before seven months ago but how
do you respond to the charge that you're
in no position to know particularly
given the vast amount of uh material out
there what harm is being done to sources
or potential sources in terms of that
and also on the historical point about
it all relating from last year how do
you respond to the question well how do
you respond to the point that um the
obama administration uh
would argue that actually you say things
must change that they will argue that
things have changed that this all comes
before the surge actually got into
operation
one of the interesting things that we
have noticed from this material
is that
at the time that mcchrystal took command
with
a stated policy intention of reducing
civilian casualties especially from
airstrikes
a new field appeared
in these reports
a field of credible
allegations of
coalition forces causing
civilian casualties
that appears to have been an attempt by
mcchrystal to get some
handle on the situation to get some
measure on where civilian casualties
were occurring as a result of coalition
activity
but what we see
is that
the u.s army is an enormous boat that is
extremely hard to turn around
and the
cover-up
of those sorts of crimes
begins at the bottom
and moves its way to the top
so it is quite hard to enact
a new policy and have it filtered down
to a change in practice
a new policy by obama
does not mean
a change of practice by the us military
anymore
the new policy by mcchrystal
meant
a change in practice
by u.s forces so these are war crimes
sorry you said cover-up oh no already
you already asked the question sorry
yeah but it's an important
thing
speak to you right here um have you and
have your partners published all the
information that you gave you access to
them if they held back
what did they hold back on and do you
have more of this kind of material to
come out you spoke about
wikileaks since december has been a bit
on a bit of a publishing hiatus
in order to
do significant re-engineering
to cope with the level of submissions we
were receiving and the level of
public interest in our site is actually
a very hard engineering task to supply
two to five percent of the entire world
uh internet connected population
at a single moment with
material
and so we're a small organization trying
to understand how to do that and do that
in a secure way as a result we have
built up during that period an enormous
backlog
of whistleblower disclosures
additionally after
the collateral murder tape came out
which revealed how two
reuters journalists were killed in 2007
in baghdad along with 18 to 26 other
people
we received a substantial increase in
the number of submissions so
now we have an enormous range of
material we are trying to get through
and trying to keep our promise to our
sources in achieving the maximum
political impact for that material in
relation to these in particular
this is one of those cases
this is what one of the cases of us
getting through our backlog
so
we have
released to the public some 76 000
reports
from this
set of material
the set itself comprises of
over 91 000
reports
we have held back about 15 000
reports of a particular type to undergo
a further
car minimization review
and
those
some of those reports will be redacted
and released
released
as soon as
we are able to get through them
and
others
will be withheld until the security
situation in afghanistan
means that it is safe to release them
and by safe i do not mean safe for
military forces i mean safe for the
local population of
just now and afghanistan declined to
answer the question from my colleagues
so what do you mean i don't find that
interesting well hang on you're here to
talk about the freedom of expression and
you're using to answer questions
that's a little hypocritical you have
your phrase your questions you use the
word crimes and now you're refusing to
explain why
you have to phrase you have to wait your
turn and you also have to phrase your
questions in a meaningful way
do we have another question
do you find that difficult
um just curious why you decided to
donate your home collaboration with
three liberal media outlets
specifically
well i'm
i am a print journalist
i mean
i don't we we've had one video
production so far so we don't really
know how to do a tv that well um we had
hoped to
partner with
a network to do a more significant
investigation but
limited time and resources eclipse that
we do hope to do that next time
the reason why these three
organizations
obviously we can't have a
journalistic coalition which is too
large
sharing everything equally for the
logistical reasons it just doesn't hold
so when we're talking three or four that
we can actually get together into a room
and agree on all the conditions
those
simply are
possibly the exception of some french
publications
the
three
the best three research
uh publications in print
new york times the spiegel and the
guardian one of them
the investigation of the kundus event in
2005 which killed
um over 100 people and approximately 60
to 80 civilians
by the german press
is an interesting case study
because the german press investigated
this with
incredible
thoroughness
that is not seen for any other single
event
in afghanistan or iraq
and it's really i suppose a credit to
the german press uh to see that level of
investigation
but
it also speaks to some kind of market
demand or cultural desire uh in germany
to see those sort of crimes thoroughly
uh investigated where german forces play
a part
there
are a number of reports that do concern
german forces and
the
regions where german forces are
stationed including task force 373 which
is stationed or has been stationed near
a german-controlled region
der spiegel uh
has more on that issue
i'll let them speak for me
they know more about the details
did you experience
any approaches or attempts to um should
walk publication from the u.s
as soon as it gets difficult
the media groups
including us agreed that the new york
times uh would approach the white house
for comment and the pentagon for comment
and that would comment would then come
back and be shared amongst the others uh
that approach took place in the middle
of last week
so they knew it at least since that
point
we haven't
had any
direct
attempts to censor us
like every delicate investigation we
have of course held things close to our
chest and so have the other media
organizations
what are the kind of things you hope to
change with the release head support
changing foreign policy more information
a higher public profile yourself the
site
we give a promise to whistleblowers that
come to us that is our role as the
international public service that
provided they meet some very simple
criteria like
like a lawyer we will
represent them
fairly
to the court
in our case the court of public opinion
so
this submission met that criteria and
therefore we were tasked
to
keep our promise of getting the maximum
political impact for it
and
i think we
appear to be living up to that promise
that said
of course
some material
calls out for more attention
and material which exposes significant
human rights abuses
tasks us
to spend more effort on it
some of those
15 000 documents i think you were
talking about earlier on
so presumably within those 15 000 or so
documents there are things that you
maybe have already
seen that might deserve some amount of
attention
being the case
and the fact that you get immediate
coverage whenever these things happen
can you then therefore
answer the question that's been asked
twice already by a journalist you
mentioned the word crimes
can you please just be a bit more
specific about what you meant by are
these crimes committed within these
documents because unless the questions
answered
how do you expect the media to take you
seriously down the line when there are
potentially more good stories to go what
is your specific question you mentioned
uh
a a while ago
war crimes or crimes when you were
talking about the documents you didn't
you weren't specific what i'm asking you
is to be more specific when you talk
about war crimes or crimes is i think
the word you used i think i was speaking
about the issue in general however
it is up to a court to decide
clearly whether something is in the end
a crime
that said prima facie
there does appear to be
evidence of war crimes in this material
example is the task force 373
high mars missile strike on a house
which killed
seven children
on the one hand
as we all know the united kingdom is a
surveillance state
on the other hand
we do have extensive
uh
political journalistic and community
support
in this country
and
it would only serve our interests in
fact to be
um
uh or for me to be arrested or detained
i can't imagine uh that happening in
this country um i
uh unless unless there was a
miscommunication from the bureaucracy to
the political leadership so political
leadership
in this country would not tolerate that
the um the motives of wikileaks in all
of this are well known and you've
expressed them i wondered
without revealing your source on this
what what your sources motives for for
releasing this material to you um where
was it was a motive expressed to you
yeah we when we get submissions we
typically get a statement in fact we
require
usually a statement from the source
about what they want us to do with the
material why it's important and so on
um
so yes the source wanted to call
attention to
a number
of these incidents
not all the ones that we have found but
some of the ones that we have found and
and their perception was of course there
would be many more and they appear to be
correct
yes we have
committed funds
to
mr manning's
lawyer we are
his jag team
and
they understand that those funds are
available
at the point that he wishes
to choose to engage his civilian council
presently
his
jag u.s military legal team
has
not chosen
civilian council
which is independent the fifteen
thousand documents you talk about have a
similar low level of the ones that
you're looking at further are they
similar uh low-level intelligence
reports or does this include us embassy
cable from other documents there are a
number of there are
over 50 uh us embassy cables uh in the
material
uh that has been released already
the
majority of the material that has not
been released yet
are threat reports
we
experience certain you know surveillance
events from time to time
um and uh
our sources have told us something of
the
decision-making
process that was occurring some months
ago within
the white house
i shouldn't really say more about that
but that
the private statements are made
within
the white house and state department
were
concerning
however
those private statements have now synced
up to the public statements which are
acceptable
mostly acceptable
yes
one of the papers you work with
suggested that you um
have access to several million
files around the world and that they'd
be very controversial can you give can
you confirm that and can you give us
some flavor of why they're so
controversial
we have
in this backlog that we have built up we
have
files that concern
every country in the world with a
population of over 1 million people
including the united states
we won't go into further detail until
that material is to be released
that it is not
one thing about lots of places but
rather
thousands of
databases and files about all sorts of
countries
we're working as hard as we can
have we got a big team
we have a small team of
dedicated and overworked people
uh that said we also have uh
around 800
volunteers part-time volunteers and an
extended network of
10 000 people and i suppose loosely 70
000 supporters
as anyone who will know who's
managed an organization uh
going from a small organization to a
large organization is very difficult let
alone um
in this adversarial security environment
that we have to work
easy
you know appears to be quite sort of big
it's getting a lot of coverage that more
people are going to
follow suit and come forward with
information are you already getting a
sense that people are approaching you
with stuff that is our experience that
our courage is contagious that when
there is a significant source disclosure
um
that is resulting in a media impact and
appears that it's going to result in
some kind of political reform down the
track
sources
are encouraged
by the opportunities
uh that they see before them and step
forward
so we expect that to also be true in
this case so the age of the
whistleblower
entering into it i hope so
absolutely
yes
yes we were um
mr manning is there is no allegation uh
as far as we can determine uh that this
material is connected uh to bradley
manning
uh either in these sort of chat logs and
evidence that has been uh provided or
um
as a result of the charges that the
u.s military have applied to him
but that said he is a very high profile
alleged source um
in fact he's the only alleged
uh
us military source
so there is of course a
natural
um media tendency to
for anything
related to u.s government or u.s
military to try and correlate this
to mr manning but
as far as we can see from the public
record uh there is no
evidence of a correlation
there are no reports
in here directly from german forces
there are some reports
by u.s forces saying what german forces
have told them and there are reports by
u.s forces on
their interactions or encounters with
german forces and others
but there are no
direct reports
in this material
from
any other group than
of the
united states army
and marines sometimes there are reports
that are given to
regular army and marines and that are
then incorporated into this material for
example
u.s embassy cables
um
i'm not across
that's possible but where
publicity is based on the truth
um
we do not now call that propaganda
we did in the 1930s but but not anymore
that said
this material
it does not leave
anyone
um
look smelling like roses
especially the taliban
i mean there are some
reports in here if you add up the
figures of 2 000 people
civilians killed by ieds
now of course
it is wrong to say that
all those ieds
were planted by the taliban
but they were presumably
planted by rebel forces of some
description uh in afghanistan
what do you think in the end this
disclosure of these documents really
signifies and i think you've said that
this is the
most comprehensive history of a war in
terms of the raw detail ever to have
been
presented
you know what do you think that
signifies what what does it mean in the
end what will change what might change
what should change
so
this is
the equivalent of opening the stazi
archives
no one
particular stasi file
has
a tremendous impact to change a whole
nation to change the whole nation of
germany
but
across all
the stasi files
many individuals are represented and
many people in german society could see
their connection to the behavior of the
stasi
so i it and that's something that came
out over time so i expect that to be the
case also uh in this material it is the
is a history it is a enormous compendium
of material that will affect
many different people in different ways
we as a journalistic group
the
four media groups who worked on this
have really only just scratched the
surface i think between us we've
probably read about a thousand or two
thousand of these reports properly
so
um
it's going to take the rest of the world
press
and academics to look at the statistics
that uh come out of this
and the soldiers
and return soldiers
from afghanistan from coalition forces
will take the taliban
to look at this
the refugees from afghanistan the locals
still living there
to all look at this and say
i understand that event i was there this
is just a tiny summary let me tell you
what really went on that was my father
who was killed that was my buddy
he was killed
that was my commanding officer who gave
me an order that i was extremely
uncomfortable with
we had we saw things like that coming
out
um when we released the collateral
murder video we saw two two u.s soldiers
involved in that event come forward and
give
many additional details we saw the sons
and brothers
of
the journalists who were killed in that
event come forward and give details
we saw the wife of the driver who was
killed in in the van come forward and
give additional details so
that's what i expect to happen with this
material and to some degree
it is of such scope that it eclipses
the economic ability of
the press
to go through it
it's going to require not just the press
but all interested parties to understand
this material and that is why we have
endeavoured to put it into a format that
is easy
for people to go through and comprehend
just
just to understand the question did you
say that you have only
gone through uh in detail two thousand
of these
seventy five thousand ninety one
thousand documents well how do you
square that then with your
uh argument that this is a responsible
publication and that you've done all the
uh harm minimization that you said you
have the documents are in many different
categories they are tagged with
different categories so we can see that
some categories
do not have
the type of material that would
as an example
identify innocent informers
well things are going pretty well so far
i mean um
i i suppose our greatest fear is that we
will
um
be too successful too fast and
we won't be able to do justice to the
material we're getting in
fast enough
um
that's our greatest problem at the
moment
to accept that secrecy is
an important and unnecessary part of
government
secrecy is
sometimes perfectly legitimate
for example
your
medical records with your doctor are
probably in all likelihood
perfectly entitled through
confidentiality
but not always
in some cases
but that is not true
so you make a choice
this is a matter about
whether the coercive power of the state
should be used to stop people
sharing information who have no direct
connection
to the source of the information
so you can't use the coercive power of
the state to stop people spreading
rumors to top people discussing
political life
and
sophisticated us jurisprudence
understands that
and that is why
you have things like the first amendment
which takes
the press outside
the legislative process because in the
end it is the communication of knowledge
which regulates
the legislature which creates
the constitution
yes unfortunately we do not see any
rivals of blower sites
we did have a grand application into the
knight foundation to try and give our
technology to every news organization in
the world
so
submit you know so every newspaper would
have submit this material uh to us using
wikileaks technology
but that grant application was rejected
for political reasons after the
collateral murder video
do you see yourself accountable in
exactly the same way three other major
organizations
have to be accountable and secondly even
those media organizations uh focus on
uh driving a profit
what is the commercial arrangement
between themselves as wikileaks and
these three organizations who are
advertised
et cetera there was no commercial
arrangement
ongoing in terms of
no commercial
at all
we
have been blessed uh over the past few
months of receiving extensive report
support by the public not by foundation
support by journalists and by human
rights activists we have raised a
million dollars
from the general public
as a result we
have we are um
are unable to have a sort of fierce
independence
that
larger organizations
find more difficult that said of course
we are also immediately accountable to
the public
because that is where all our money
comes from directly from the public not
from advertisers and not from
foundations
now in terms of governments and
prosecutors what do you want to see done
with the information that you've now
posted and now it's out there in the
public domain what do you expect to see
happen and what do you want to have well
we would like to see this material
the revelations that this material gives
be taken seriously
investigated
by governments
and new policies put in place as a
result if not
uh prosecutions
of those people who have committed
abuses
this it's important to understand this
material doesn't just reveal abuses
this material describes
the past six years of war
every major attack
that resulted in someone being detained
or someone being killed
that tells you how the war is going
where this happened in what different
parts of afghanistan what sort of weapon
systems
were used
which particular military units is there
a killer is there a killer unit in the
united states military because there's
been histories of that
you can find out using this data
you can create a simple computer program
we haven't done it yet
but any one of your technical staff can
create a simple computer program to add
up the kills
by unit
and get and find a top kill unit
so that that's an example of something
can be immediately extracted from this
so you can really see how the war in
afghanistan is going and then compare
that
to government statements and government
policy this is the raw material that
ends up on the big boards on the war
room there's even a field in their d
color which
describes the color
that this material ends up and it's
displayed on
big boards this is the raw ingredients
that lead to
pentagon statistics about civilian
casualties that lead to graphs about how
many insurgents are killed
we only ever normally see those figures
in aggregate but now we have all the
events that are used to create those
figures and we can understand
whether those aggregate figures
are in fact
accurate or are they distortions
in fact we can see in many cases where
we know
what's in this database
and
we have
press sourcing or afghan government
investigation we can see the disparity
between these two
so we can see in fact the aggregate
figures
are based on faulty data
we see a lot of exculpatory language in
these reports
from a unit talking about
why it killed someone and why
why um
a convoy is going on a road
car comes along
goes to overtake they shoot the driver
and so
that unit then reports all the things
that it did and you see
we engaged in escalation of force
procedure and we told him to stop and
but then
what you what you look is
if if you look across these reports you
see an amazing number of civilians
killed by ricochets
so we fired a warning shot in the
ricochet
ended up killing this person i mean it's
it's just not credible that that many
people can be killed by ricochets
so we we see that
um
you know it's like a
a policeman investigating himself
i mean filing his own report about an
alleged crime that he's meant to commit
alleged to have committed of course
that sort
of
reportage internal reportage is filled
with errors but that
it is those initial reports that then
lead to investigations so we can see
the field credible
allegations of coalition
forces causing civilian injuries
that field that was introduced about the
same time as general mcchrystal
took command
we see this
unusually sorry
applied to
in an unrepresentative way
non-us forces
so it's u.s forces talking about the
pole the u.s force is talking about the
french and that label gets applied when
a unit reports its own activities that
label never gets applied
sometimes one u.s military unit will
apply it to the activities of another
u.s military i mean this
shouldn't be any surprise if you have a
basic understanding of how human beings
behave
but it does show that it is a hardship
to manage
because the the the raw ingredients you
need to manage it the internal reporting
is
not accurate
so what are you going to do
that's right
so there's distortions going up to the
top and then the top ties to push things
down
we want you to report all the civilian
kills
because
what incentives is there for a unit to
report its own bad behavior
[Music]
when you're in afghanistan which is the
primary catastrophic problem for the
west is an utter lack of understanding
of the afghan people where they are who
they are what their motives are what
they're doing
a lot of what you've got here chloe's
there from was it
what's your question do you draw the
same central left
afghan people are many well
there's many diverse groups in
afghanistan
having different economic bases
different language different um
clan affiliations
uh and yet
u.s troops and british troops are
essentially culturally homogenous and
all go in there
with the same sort of culture but
there's many different regional cultures
in afghanistan i mean
i feel that i would be drawing myself
too much to
to agree with you although i can see
glimmers of that problem coming out of
the material but the one thing is very
clear to me i mean it is one damn thing
after another it is it is war
um but we don't normally see war
uh through this material we do see what
war is like
the every at the everyday level uh as
well as the big events the whole lot you
know um
when we released this iraq video uh
gates
secretary of defense gates said
that it was looking at war through a
straw
and we only gave a 40-minute video and
somehow that this lacked context
although we did give news reports
about what happened on the day
but this if you like is the beginning
the end and the middle uh this is
the whole context
with some exceptions uh of the
afghan war and if anything can give us
some kind of intellectual understanding
uh surely this is it whether whether it
engages people emotionally is another
matter i mean
to some degree that is the task of
good journalism is to turn
this raw material who when where
how
how many
into something that emotionally engages
people who can apply levers on decision
making
are you are you concerned though i mean
accepting the argument
is well made and i think most of us
expect that but are you concerned that
in the process of releasing this
information that actually will do more
harm than good at least in some areas
what about the relationship between
pakistan and afghanistan it's very
volatile a lot of the information about
isis involvement comes from
mds and apparently you know biased or
potentially
the internet in a way violent could in
fact
inflame at least an aspect taught by the
taliban but there was another dimension
and several of them mentioned
there now you can stand that this is all
you thought
this is going to make that situation
worse
there is no perfect information
um
but in the end the truth is all we have
right
but you have a more electrical response
to put information the way that people
can understand it and process it
responsibly i mean there is well i think
we have done that
i i think we have done that extremely
well i mean we have 14 pages in the
guardian just here that's not a bad
outcome right journalistically
i mean what more could you do
what about the security of the
troops
when you publish this material
the material is all seven months old
there doesn't seem to be any
there's no nothing about troop movements
no tactical considerations in this
material
so
why
of course i am not
i would always think about that issue
before dismissing it out of hand
we have looked at it and it doesn't seem
to be anything significant
that said i mean
the revelations of
abuses
uh by
us and coalition forces
may cause afghanis to be upset
and rightly so
they should treat them better
not conceal
abuses that have been undertaken
undertaken
why does so much of this material that
you publish come from us forces and not
from other coalition parts such as
the british actually we've published a
lot of material from the british
in fact the the ministry of defence
put in an order to british telecom which
controls the gateway
for
mod
and told them to block all connections
going out to wikileaks
in an attempt to stop
british forces leaking us material
at least a stated attempt
of course
what happened in practice is someone who
was responsible for
counterintelligence got
some command from a more senior person
saying look at that thing on wikileaks
shouldn't you do something and so they
wrote a letter to british telecom
uh
instructing british telecom to make sure
that
normal connections from in inside the
mod couldn't
look at our web pages i mean the result
is that those
senior people who complain about
material that is on wikileaks are no
longer in a position to complain because
they can't read it
it's great no investigations because
they can't see the material that's there
we discovered this and using a proactive
foi that we
routinely do for sort of these sorts of
organizations that might
be trying to investigate our sources
yes the um
the bnd the
german equivalent of the cia
uh
their chief ernst ullah
wrote to us
demanding the removal of a document
exposing
corruption in kosovo
which included information about cia
behavior in kosovo
uh under under the threat that we would
be prosecuted under german law would you
respond
yes right
tell me more and tell me more
precisely what law is it that we are
going to be prosecuted under
and eventually
b and d decided
that they didn't want to tell us the law
that we would be prosecuted under
because of course there is no such law
please speak up a little bit
one of the things
um
we won't
comment on what we have not yet released
but that said
uh we can look at what happened in six
years
because we have a window of six years
from 2004 to 2010
and we don't see sudden
dramatic shifts
when there is a change in policy as an
example by the changes in policy when
the crystal came on board
i would find it very unlikely
if there were any
sudden dramatic shifts
in the behavior of
u.s forces all the isi
over the last seven months given that
there hasn't been
any
significant change
in the prior
five
four years
that would seem to be unlikely to me
if there would be any inquiry
would you
be willing to give the original raw
material
we have made available to the world
uh
76
000
of these reports
in
csv format
xml format sql format
as a format you can load the whole lot
into google earth and plot it by space
and time
we have also released all the reports in
a browseable interface um did we if we
actually get this vga cable cable
working i'll be able to show you
that said of course we have not released
the
uh precise format that we obtained from
our source i think you have the adapter
do you have an adapter for that i reckon
you have downstairs they reckon i have
do they they're written in your
briefcase
not to my knowledge
search find and share with the c-span
video library
earlier today the website wikileaks
released nearly 400 000 classified
military documents on the iraq war they
reportedly revealed details concerning
thousands of previously unreported
civilian deaths and torture against
detainees by iraqi authorities its
founder was among a panel who spoke at a
news conference in london to talk about
his group's findings this is an hour and
15
and i'll minutes attempting to moderate
this this morning the press conference
as you know is dedicated to the release
of the uh
iraq war laws logs this morning and
these releases are based on four that
were received and published by wikileaks
you will have seen the print of course
and television coverage this morning
those speaking
this morning
are julian assange the editor of
wikileaks which he founded in 2006
wikileaks has won a number of awards
including the index on censorship's 2008
economist new media award
and an award of distinction from the
pre-arts electronica in june 2009
wikileaks and julian assange won amnesty
international's uk media award
and july this year he won the uh
the sam adams award for integrity
he's joined by um
kristen hoffnerson
who became actively involved with
wikileaks on the collateral murder video
earlier this year and traveled to
baghdad on a fact-finding mission he has
20 years experience as an investigative
journalist with channel 2
news
which is a private broadcaster an r.u.v
the icelandic public bro state
broadcaster he's been awarded twice
iceland's highest journalism award
after wikileaks on the panel is john uh
sloboda since 2003 john has been
coordinator of the iraq body count
project an ongoing human security
project maintaining and updating the
world's largest public database of
violent civilian deaths
since the 2003 invasion
he's a consultant and director of the
oxford research group's recording
casualties in armed conflict program
and chairs the international advisory
group he's emeritus professor of
psychology at the university of keele
and an honorary professor
at the school of politics and
international relations at royal
holloway university of london
the iraq body count data i should
mention has been used by an
extraordinary group of people the new
york times the washington post the
associated press al-jazeera open
democracy the independent the guardian
the world health organization the
international criminal court the new
england journal of medicine and the
european union's joint research center
and the brookings institute in
washington
and
at 10 25 we'll also be hearing from phil
shine
shiner phil shiner leads the team at
public interest lawyers he's been
practicing as a solicitor in the uk
since 1981 and has written extensively
on international and human rights law
in recent years he has acted in some of
the most important judicial review cases
to be brought in his area of expertise
and in march 2010 he led the team to
success in the european court of human
rights in a particularly important case
he was made a solicitor of the year by
the way in 2008 and was in the sunday
times top 10 solicitors in britain in
the same year
so i think we can now start with julian
assange
thank you gavin
because we don't have much time i won't
speak for long
but
this
disclosure
is about the truth
philip knightley the great investigative
reporter an australian
who for the past
30 or 40 years has made
the uk his home said
that
the first casualty of war is the truth
but the attack on the truth by war
begins long before war starts and
continues long after a war ends
in our release of these 400 000
documents
about
the iraq war
the intimate detail of that war
from the u.s perspective
we hope
to correct
some of that attack on the truth
that occurred before the war
during the war
and
which has continued on
since the
war officially
concluded
in that material
the deaths of some 109 000 people are
documented
internally declared
66 000 civilians
working with the iraq body count
we have seen that there are
approximately
15 000
never previously
documented or known
cases of civilians who have been killed
by violence in iraq
that tremendous scale
should not make us
blind
to the
small human scale
that occurs in this material
in fact
it is the deaths of one and two people
per event
that killed the overwhelming number of
people
in iraq
following our release of the afghan war
diaries
[Music]
we thought we would try and pull
together
a broader coalition
not just involving print but one that
had the emotionality and impact
of tv
journalism and extra research from
other groups
so we structured a collaboration between
the guardian spiegel
new york times our pre
our three previous print partners
and
new groups
the bureau for investigative journalism
[Music]
iraq body count whose
knowledge of deaths in iraq is
unsurpassed svt swedish television
al jazeera
channel 4
bbc radio
and i'm sure i've missed some others yes
le monde
[Music]
that collaboration seems to have worked
and we will see over the next few days
what's to be made of it
but so far uh we can see a fairly strong
response
we have seen uh as of uh 3 a.m uh this
morning 1500
news
1500 articles according to google news
and of course all around the world
we can see the result
we make a promise to our sources who go
through incredible
risks sometimes
to get us material that we will
do justice to their efforts
and get them the maximum political
impact possible
and while i'm not sure
that we have achieved the maximum
possible i think
we're getting pretty close
and with that
i'll introduce you now to
kristen
thank you
when
wikileaks announced the release of the
afghan war diary on july 26th
the organization was condemned by the
pentagon for releasing material that was
described as sensitive
and harmful both to afghanis and the
troops in the country
those overblown statements were echoed
in most of the media without any
criticism
or critical question
three months have passed now
and there have been no reports of any
harm in relation to the release of the
afghan war diary
this has been even been acknowledged by
the pentagon last week some news
organizations obtained a copy of a
letter sent by u.s secretary of defense
robert gates to the head of the senate
armed services committee on august 16th
this was about the same time
that gates and pentagon spokesperson
were sending out strongly worded
statements aimed at wikileaks
in kate's letter however it is
acknowledged
that the outcome documents had no
not revealed any quote sensitive
intelligent sources
or methods unquote
last week a top nato official
reiterated in a statement to the press
that he had not seen any harm
as a result of the release
the contrast between the letter the
quote by the nato official and the
statements by the pentagon spokesperson
should be a reminder that people should
not accept
condemning statements against wikileaks
without question
in relation to the outcome files
wikileaks withheld one in six reports 15
000 in all
for line by line reviewing and reduction
that work is now finished and the
reports will be released soon
this time wikileaks took a new approach
to the reduction reducting process it
used an electronic reduction method
combined with tests done by groups of
people
it is an
innovative approach and has been
perfected by a group of people
contributing to the process
it can best be described as a reverse
approach to reduction at the outset
everything in all reports
was deemed harmful
and reducted until proven otherwise
from there on words phrases
locations aberrations etc
were uncovered or unredacted step by
step
the work in the passing week has the
weeks have therefore been focusing on
minimizing
the reduction
along the way batches of documents were
taken out and tested by a group of
qualified
volunteers and further tests were done
on the 390 000 documents
we are confident now
that the documents
in the highly redacted form contain no
information that could be harmful to
individuals
having said that i would like to add
that every system
can contain flaws
but the likelihood of any flaw in our
approach is purely minimal
the end result which we are presenting
is still in unhighly redacted cashier
documents
despite the over reductions the warlock
is easily readable and can be data mined
for news news stories and angles for
those interested
we will also look into the possibility
of providing news media and academics
access to unredacted parts of the
document upon request
furthermore it needs to be emphasized
that we aim to continue on the track of
further minimizing the reductions
but being a small organization with
limited resources
this could take some time
thanks thanks kristen
you'll see on war
logs.wikileaks.org
the interface that kristen spoke of
that permits
full text searching of the entire
redacted collection
including sort of boolean terms you can
search for keywords like oga
other government agency a
euphemism typically for the cia
or dia
we also partnered with
only to produce a system where
uh people who have information about
these events can comment on them uh and
rate them
go to the website and have a look uh at
that
um there's a lot of um
uh
obviously there's a tremendous worldwide
interest at the moment so those those
systems may be slow
but if you persevere across the day
you will find them to be
quite usable
it's what
we use
partially internally and the iraq body
count also has a system
which they'll
describe in any human disaster finding
out who died and how they died is the
overriding public concern
seven years on the public does not have
a full account of the terrible human
cost of this ongoing iraq war to the
iraqi people what we have instead
is an incomplete patchwork of stories
pictures and data gathered by different
organizations for different purposes
often published one day and forgotten
the next
the victims of this war their families
and the publics whose taxes funded this
war deserve better than this
there is a public right to know
iraq body count has been working on a
daily basis since march 2003 to ensure
that no fact about a civilian death that
is uncovered is then lost from view
we carefully monitor compare and analyze
published reports mostly provided by
press and media organizations such as
are represented in this room
in this way we have been able to build
and keep in the public eye the most
detailed and comprehensive list of
civilian deaths to date that exists
in fact the world's press and media have
by default been the frontline data
gatherers of this war
without journalists and without the
organizations for which they work the
world would know little of substance
about the iraq death toll
but
yesterday's release reveals that there
has been another frontline data gatherer
the us army
day by day secretly soldiers all over
iraq have been writing detailed reports
of the violent deaths they cause witness
or are informed about
dates times precise locations names ages
and occupations of victims have all been
stored away in these logs
it is very good that this data has been
collected
but it is wrong and unjustifiable that
it has been kept secret for so long
iraq body count has started the huge
task of integrating the new information
into the existing patchwork just as we
would for any other source brought to
our attention
in the few weeks since we've had access
to the logs we've only scratched the
surface but by careful sampling and
matching of these logs against what is
already in our database we have a clear
emerging picture of what these logs
contain as a whole
and the reports on our website
iraqbodycount.org give the full details
but let me take you through the headline
findings
i and my colleagues hemet dardagan josh
doherty and peter bagnall will be
available to answer further detailed
questions during and after this press
conference
based on our careful sampling we
estimate that when fully analyzed these
logs will bring to public knowledge more
than fifteen thousand previously
unreported civilian deaths
to add to the hundred and seven thousand
which are already in the iraq body
account database
fifteen thousand is a huge number it's
equivalent to five nine elevens or
nearly three hundred seven sevens
however the newly revealed deaths do not
primarily come from large bombings like
this
most of the larger incidents were
already well reported by the world's
press and media
the new deaths are concentrated in small
incidents
killing one or two people at a time
scattered all over iraq and occurring
almost every day for the whole period
targeted assassinations
drive-by shootings
executions
checkpoint killings
these are the small but relentless
tragedies of this war that these logs
reveal in unprecedented detail
adding in the combatant deaths reported
in these logs and combining with other
previously reported deaths we are now
able to say that more than 150 000
people have been killed in total since
2003
of which about 80 percent were
civilians even where deaths were
previously known about as numbers these
logs often turn numbers into human
beings for instance the ibc database
records that on november the 1st 2006 35
bodies were found around baghdad that
day as reported for example by reuters
the new york times cnn among others
however media reports did not identify
any of the victims nor give details of
how each one died so our ibc database
has just this spare information in it
the iraq warlocks also report 35 bodies
found that day but spread across 27
blogs specifying a wide range of details
including the precise neighborhood and
time of day where particular bodies were
found and in many cases the demographics
and identities of those killed
so when fully processed the information
in these logs will allow our single
entry to be replaced by over 20 detailed
incidents
most surprisingly of all we have found a
huge number of names of victims
meticulously recorded in these logs
it's unclear to us why the us army
wanted to go to such lengths in its
recording but it is of huge public
importance and interest that it did
names are the gold dust of casualty
recording enterprise and the only
certain route to a full and final death
toll that will satisfy all parties
including bereaved families
we've already found over 100 previously
reported civilian victim names in the
logs we've examined and we estimate that
many thousands more will be discovered
as analysis proceeds
for instance on 29th of november 2006 28
bodies were discovered in the mass grave
south of bakuba this was comprehensively
reported by press and media at the time
but not a single one of those reports
gave the names of a single victim
the iraq war logs list all these names
one by one and so today for the first
time they have been put into the public
record nearly four years later
the unprecedented level of detail in
these logs is important for another
reason too it's the main way in which we
can properly assess what is new in them
the crude death totals that these lots
provide are lower than the comparable
count from ibc also lower than figures
from others providing totals such as the
iraq ministry for human rights this can
tempt people to mistakenly assert that
there is nothing new in these logs our
analysis shows how hugely mistaken that
assertion is
in conclusion we believe that having
received these logs wikileaks was right
to publish them in this heavily redacted
form but the real story is not about the
release itself but the grave content of
the logs themselves almost every log
tells a story and far too often this is
a previously unknown story of human
suffering and death
it will take many months even years to
extract every important fact from these
logs iraq wide account is committed to
playing its part in this fact-finding
work no matter how long it takes
because there can be no closure for
moving on from this or any war until
every last victim has been properly
recognized and the full details of the
circumstances of their death
acknowledged these logs are potentially
the largest single contribution to
achieving that goal that has ever been
published
we ask everyone including the u.s
government to support this work which is
in the public interest and brings closer
the proper recognition that all the
victims of this tragic war deserve
thank you
phil
[Music]
the question you're probably asking is
well what now
and i'm going to tell you about some of
the legal action that will follow here
in the uk
and it'd be wrong to assume
that as as these are u.s logs
this has nothing to do with the uk
public interest lawyers
is presently acting for many iraqi
civilians who've been killed or tortured
by uk forces
some have been killed by indiscriminate
attacks on civilians or the unjustified
use of lethal force
others have been killed in custody with
uk forces no one knows
how many iraqis lost their lives whilst
held
in british detention facilities the most
notable of those of course is barramusa
and we now await the inquiry's report
into his death
due in early 2011.
the iraq war logs add hugely to the
evidence in the public domain
as to the effect of the invasion and
subsequent occupation of iraq by
coalition forces including the uk
what can be said about the logs comes
under three headings
all three areas are or will soon be the
subject of legal action here in the uk
the first
is that of unlawful killings of
civilians or indiscriminate attacks upon
them or the unjustified use of lethal
false against them
it may never be known how many iraqis
died but we now know from the important
work of iraq body count that the
previously known number of deaths 107
369
is likely to have increased by around a
staggering fifteen thousand
some of these deaths will be in
circumstances where the uk had a very
clear legal responsibility
this may be because the iraqis died
whilst under the effect of control of uk
forces
under arrest in vehicles helicopters or
detention facilities
these deaths will all fall within the
jurisdiction of the european convention
on human rights
if the judgment of the grand chamber in
the al skyny case
which is due early in 2011
asserts as we expect
that once uk forces have authoritative
control over iraqis there is
jurisdiction for the purposes of the
european convention but others
will not be covered by the european
conventional human rights
for example public interest lawyers was
a case where a uk tank stopped
and in broad daylight a rifleman aimed
shot and killed an eight-year-old girl
playing in her yellow dress in a bazaar
street
there are many other cases like that and
the logs add to the number of cases that
will not be within the jurisdiction of
the european convention
but
we will argue in a case shortly
that the common law here in the uk
provides the same remedy
as the european convention
namely that there must now be a judicial
inquiry into the legality of all of
these deaths
if unjustified or unlawful force has
been used
prosecutions of all those responsible
must follow
so we're bringing forward a new case
seeking accountability for all unlawful
deaths
and we argue that there must be a
judicial inquiry to fully investigate uk
responsibility for civilian deaths in
iraq
the second area
is the huge number of logs that detail
horrendous torture and abuse of iraqis
by either the iraqi national guard
or the iraqi police service
the u.s and the uk appear to have
adopted a fragmented order that required
them to take no action whatsoever
once they'd established that this
torture and ill treatment was the
responsibility of iraqis
now this is completely contrary to
international law
it's well known that there's an absolute
prohibition on torture it may never be
used
accordingly all states are duty to each
other
to cooperate together to stamp it out
and to deal with incidents of torture so
that tortures know beforehand that they
will be found out and they will be
prosecuted for their war crimes
us and uk forces cannot turn a blind eye
on the basis it wasn't their soldiers
doing the torturing and that's what's
happened and is revealed in these logs
both states had the clearest of
international obligations to take
definite and effective action to stop
the torture by the iraqis
that they did not makes them
pill
complicit
bringing forward a second case seeking
accountability for the uk's failure to
act in these circumstances
the third area concerns the huge
and growing body of evidence about
killings
ill treatment and torture of iraqis
whilst in uk custody
there appeared to be many cases other
than that of bahamusa where iraqis died
in uk custody and were then certified as
dying from natural causes
none of these invest none of these
deaths have been investigated
many of these iraqis were hooded and
abused
and my law firm does not accept
the ministry of defense's explanation
that each and every one of these deaths
has an innocent explanation
additionally
there are hundreds of iraqis now
complaining of ill treatment and torture
often as a result of coercive
interrogation techniques by uk
interrogators within secret facilities
run by the joint forward interrogation
team
insofar as the logs add to this body of
evidence
they will help us gain a single inquiry
into the uk's detention policy and
practice in south east iraq
a court of appeal and high court judge
sitting together
will hear a case about all of these
incidents on the 5th to the 9th of
november 2010.
thanks very much
we're going to open up very very quickly
now for questions from the audience but
we have a surprise sort of announcement
and an unusual announcement because we
have an unusual addition
to the speakers this morning we have
here in the front row probably the most
famous whistleblower in modern american
history daniel ellsberg author of the
pentagon papers and we'll hear from him
shortly
uh i would request though entering the
questions that all the questioners
want to understand that the speakers are
pleased to answer any and all questions
concerning the release of the documents
the analysis of the data and conclusions
and the work that's been done
but i think i'd like if i may just to
open the question by asking daniel
elberg ellsberg
what's your reaction to this kind of
release of material it's quite different
than the one that you did yourself
well it's different and it's the same
in many ways this is the war that we're
facing right now
the one in afghanistan which i call
vietnam stan
has really more fundamental similarities
and it has differences i've been asked
here to make a couple of comments rather
than questions to you right away i'll
just say that
a couple of us here came over the ocean
last night the opportunity to stand with
julian assange and the rest of you here
in a circumstance that really i've been
waiting to see for 40 years and i that's
a number is not drawn out of the air
that's a precise figure
judy ehrlich next to me just
co-directed a film called the most
dangerous man in america
so she's working now honestly homer
hopes to do a film on julian assange
and his sources and i haven't talked to
her what the title was be but it seems
inevitable
the most dangerous man in the world
now how do you get to be the most
dangerous man in the world well first
empirically
if one country our country in this case
is pursuing for prosecution that person
regards him as dangerous over three
continents at this point in australia
and britain and america
the threat
that is made made by the pentagon as we
read over the last few days
of warning newsmen
to stand away from this material to
refuse to receive it and if they do
receive it to return it
seems absurd on his face we're not
dealing with the 7 000 pieces of paper
top secret pieces of paper that comprise
the pentagon paper the pentagon did make
a
demand the new york times that they
returned that pile of paper to the uh to
the new to the pentagon the times
refused
and uh until in fact never did return it
and refused to stop the presses until uh
that court order came down but with
cyber material it's all over the world
right now and in several papers right
now the the demand seems absurd i
understand the reason for those words
because they echo the words of the words
first used against me the legal words of
18 usc 793 paragraphs d and e
which for the first time
used uh the so-called espionage act
as if it were the kind of official
secrets act that you have in britain
which simply criminalizes the release of
any uh
classified material to any unauthorized
person we don't have such a law
and the irony now is that president
obama is making these clear threats of
applying this law to anybody who deals
with this information including not only
the journalists but the word supply to
the people who read it and don't return
it to the proper authorities
actually
president obama's threats are not
entirely without credibility here
because he has
started as many prosecutions for leaks
as all previous presidents put together
it's a small number it's three the last
one is bradley manning
it's small because we don't have an
official secrets act and prior to bush
and obama presidents took it for granted
that any application of the espionage
act was likely to be overthrown as
unconstitutional in our first amendment
by the supreme court but now facing a
different supreme court and after 9 11
obama is making a new
experiment on this issue
which will really change the relation of
the press to sources very radically as
it is any source with or without this
change in the law
who gave this kind of material 400 000
pages documents 800 000 pages
to wikileaks
would have to know that they were facing
a risk
of being where bradley manning is
right now in prison
accused of these things and we don't
know i don't know who the source is if
the president should prove
beyond reasonable doubt that it is
bradley manning
we can give him his unreserved
admiration from us and thanks for what
he did but whoever did it
in fact acted very appropriately in the
course of a hopeless deadly stalemated
war and which has one characteristic by
the way in iraq which isn't going to
come out clearly in these 400 000 pages
or in the discussion and that is that
the origins of the war were clearly
uh
in the form of lying to the publics of
britain and america and uh of carrying
on in the order to carry on a clearly
illegal crime against the peace a war of
aggression so all these civilian
casualties are killed in a war of
aggression we won't have to say also
the non-civilian casualties that are
reported here
are in the role of fighting against
foreign occupiers invaders and by the
standards of the world the question is
raised very much whether their death by
the invader
is not also to be counted among the
murders
until they continue
so i want very much to congratulate all
of you who are mining this material
uh for the
to learn what we could have learned if
it had come out earlier
oh
yeah okay no you want to do great yeah
yes craig murray here is representing a
group that was mentioned earlier
mentioned earlier giving me sam adams
award for intelligence uh integrity
and uh we want very much to
appreciate him in that guide
thank you
um i'm here
as a former recipient of the sam adams
award for intelligence for integrity and
intelligence my name is craig mully i
was british ambassador in uzbekistan
before i made a series of leaks about
using ak intelligence
sources use of torture
this award has been given to a number of
people
uh including last to colonel darley
wilkinson
in the uk to major thank grevel to
catherine gunn of gchq it's given to
people who in the public interest
leak details of the dark things that
governments do i'm very happy to present
this year's award to julian assange
[Music]
i think we'll take questions now from
the floor right right down there
go ahead
neil chandler from the daily star sunday
i'd just like to ask phil shiner um
you mentioned a
forthcoming case involving
uh
deaths and torturing of iraqi civilians
in british detention how many deaths are
you talking about
um further you mentioned the young girl
getting shot by a
squad in a tank could you give us any
more details on that where and when did
that happen
i'll do my best on both questions
on the 20th of may
2003 lieutenant colonel nicholas mercer
a uk
army officer who was head of army legal
wrote an order that says chillingly
to
all the troops who were there they've
recently been a number
of deaths of iraqi civilians in custody
with various units
now the mod have lied ever since
when panorama tried to find out what did
mercer mean by a number they said two
it's not two
it's probably
seven or eight and it may be more but
that was the 20th of may
2003
the ongoing disclosure
in the bahamut inquiry keeps turning up
more and more and more cases where the
royal military police have investigated
deaths
where there's a common pattern
often these men
are arrested
and subjected to severe abuse on arrest
in their homes sometimes women and
children are abused and sometimes
pregnant women have given miscarriages
etc
then these men are abused rifle butted
hooded
sometimes with two hoods in the extreme
conditions
and unsurprisingly
they die and every time they die it's
said that they've died of a heart attack
or natural causes they've never been
seen
by a uk doctor
usually somebody has accepted somebody
else's word or something that's been
written down on a piece of paper so i
can't tell you
how many iraqis we killed
whilst we held them
in uk detention facilities you'll have
to ask the minister of defense that
question as for the
small girl
it was a habit for her and her young
friends to play in the street
and often uk tanks would stop and get
out
and trying to win the battle for hearts
and minds they would give the children
sweets
on the particular morning in question
for some unknown reason that's never
been explained so i can't tell you
the tank stops at the end of the street
she's there in her yellow dress
a rifleman pops up
and blows them away
and you'll have to ask the minister of
defense why that happened
because they won't tell me
and that's one of the reasons and one of
the cases why we are calling for
judicial inquiry into all of these
deaths
back then
[Music]
i am deborah haynes for the times and
this is a question for julian and the
pentagon spokesman saying or said last
night that um the names of 300 iraqis
have been released as part of the iraq
war logs and their lives could now be in
danger are you worried that the careful
vetting that you outlined this morning
and maybe wasn't careful enough and
people's lives have been put at risk
no i'm worried that the press chooses to
credibly report statements like that
from the pentagon
in fact
the pentagon
would not have been able to review our
material in those few hours it is simply
logistically impossible
and we also have a strong confidence in
our redaction process which is an opt-in
process
so that statement by the pentagon
presumably
at its base is referring to their own
internal review
of their collection of significant
actions for iraq it is not referring to
our material but you will notice that
they do not say
that fact
instead they try and
issue some
deceptive statement to fool
the world press as they did
last time with some similar statements
into reporting something that is not
true
paul harrison from sky news
julian you said in your opening
statement that
you make a promise to all your sources
that uh you will in quotes
do them justice to all their for all
their efforts but given that we've seen
a very much a shrugging shoulders
attitude or turning a blind eye from the
americans thus far
according to these documents will that
not continue
and therefore the efforts of your
sources may well largely be in vain or
have you had positive noises from the us
already
well it's an interesting question
as to how responsive government is to
the condemnation of its people
and the rights of other people
but the shrugging of shoulders is of
course
the second
arm
of powerful people the first arm is
silence
so we've gotten beyond silence and now
we see an attempt to act uh in a
nonchalant manner about something that
is very serious
that does not mean
that it is not treated seriously rather
there is
or at least was
certainly early on with the afghan
material
and attempts to make it look like
it would not be treated seriously to
frame
the material
as if it was of no consequence
i highly recommend a daily show episode
which collected
all those
there's nothing new in this material
reports for afghanistan and as it has
turned out of course
that is not true in fact according to
pew research
total war reported in the united states
for that week increased three hundred
percent from 6 to 18
the
approval rating for the afghan war
decreased approximately 15 percent and
barack obama's personal uh rating
depending on which poll you read
decrease somewhere between four and
eight percent
so
those are only of course crude figures
that speak about
the whole rather than individual cases
but we can see continual reportage
was far away
high quality reportage in the past two
weeks from
norway
and espresso in italy
based upon that afghan material
a number of parliamentary inquiries um
i will be speaking at the un uh early
next month in relation to the upcoming
material so
i
expect
the same thing to happen for this
material from
for iraq
and maybe even more
we're talking about
uh five times the number of deaths uh in
the same period
we've also put together
i think a much stronger coalition a much
broader coalition at this time
involving not just print organizations
but
human rights groups and lawyers and so
on so i think
we're going to see
some concrete effects
if not just the perceptual effects about
how wars are conducted
an interesting note is that
when i made the opening
about
the truth being the first casualty of
war
we actually see that
most wars that are started by
democracies
involve lying
vietnam war and the gulf of tonkin
incident involved lying at the start of
the iraq war involved
very serious lies
which were repeated and amplified by
some parts of the press
which
leads us to say what
not that
isn't the world terrible because there's
a lot of lying by officials
but rather it leads us to a great hope
that
democracies don't start wars
unless there's liars
so if there's enough truth
early on enough
then perhaps we won't see these kind of
wars
over there in white shirt
isaac
hi question for julian edison from the
sunday times
um it's been some
suggestions in the hacking community
that
uh the systems that wikileaks use users
don't offer sources the full protection
that
you advertise on the site can you
comment on that
there is a lot of tabloid press uh
surrounding uh our organization and of
course every organization that has a
high profile is involved in
controversial activities uh i have seen
uh no reports that are credible
i know that down here yeah
yourself
can i just ask you a very general
question from your reading of all the
reports that you've gathered
how would you characterize the
conditions that existed in iraq in the
time period that you're reporting on
well i think john is probably the best
place to could you answer yourself first
i'm sorry would you mind
you you prefer the more ignorant opinion
but i i'll let john answer uh first and
if he misses something then i will
comment
our focus is entirely on uh the victims
and those who died
so what
we can see but it is simply a finer
detailed picture of what was actually
all very already very well known
by the world at large and present media
is this relentless grind of daily
killings
day by day in almost every town every
province in iraq
of checkpoint uh killings drive-by
shootings
with with no end and the the effect that
that must have on the ordinary iraqi
people is just um
uncalculable
in regard to the other kinds of uh
information in the logs torture
um and
other
observations we have nothing to say at
this point
[Music]
um
on the importance of the government
granting um a full judicial
investigation
if that doesn't happen
will they take each case on an
individual basis and string this out for
a decade and more therefore lessening
the impact of it so
the government coming around and
granting that um invest a judicial
review is crucial to your tech to your
process isn't it
it is the
government's position
is that it can deal with one case at a
time and each each case will take a year
um we have 142 outstanding cases so that
will take 142 years
the alternative is for the
administrative court
here in london to put teams of judges
into courtrooms to deal with these cases
within a proper time scale
both of those
we say are absurd
and the only rational
solution
to all of these cases is to get it over
with
and hold a proper inquiry
along the lines of the bahamus inquiry
which is just concluded
um and the mod really need to stop
covering up
which they do with greater and greater
desperation
um slurring everyone that they possibly
can
we all know
that something well many things went
badly wrong
in iraq we know from the bahamas inquiry
for instance
that we should have had a detailed
interrogation directive in force in iraq
that
directive would have told interrogators
what they could and more importantly
what they could not
do
the mod
in the bahamas inquiry say we're very
sorry we didn't have one
and we're very sorry also
that that meant
that the interrogators fell back
on training
techniques from chick sands and we're
also very sorry to admit
that the training was completely
unlawful
it involved forced nudity keeping people
naked if they wouldn't cooperate
harshing
invasion of intimate space the use of
threats one man said to the bahamus
inquiry the only limits
on coercion
were the limits of one's imagination and
i'm not going to try and explain the
horrendous things that people did to my
clients
when they let their imagination run wild
a lot of it involves pedophilia images
hardcore pornography
sexual intercourse and sexual acts in
front of my clients etc etc etc you
simply cannot say
that this
is all down to a few bad apples a few
rogue soldiers
a few isolated incidents it's horrendous
it's been covered up
and you the press are often the people
who allow it to be covered up because
you simply don't run the stories you're
obsessed some of you with what we might
have done in pakistan or what we might
have known in guantanamo bay i say to
you wake up
and and have a look at what's happening
in our high court
next month on november the 5th about
what we actually did we intend to open
that inquiry
and reveal
um
material which no one has yet seen
about the way in which we interrogated
people i invite you to turn up
in force in the high court on november
5th and find out what the uk actually
did and stop going on about what we
might have done or what we might have
known about what the us were doing
because i can tell you a comparison of
what we did which emerges from always
evidence which
i have to say none of my clients ever
have been found to be um embellishing
the truth let alone lying they've all
been found to be telling the truth so i
invite you to come along and find out
what we actually did
and just for one month stop going on
about what we might have been complicit
in
okay back there
don't you have unlike afghanistan that
on iraq
the public opinion has turned the page
we have been lied on
but life goes on the economic problem at
the moment and that there isn't the
interest for iraq that there was on
afghanistan this summer
to whom are you directing the question
well
for afghanistan we had 14 pages of the
guardian for iraq we have nine
and i suspect that's
uh probably a proportionate view in
the united kingdom's press about the
relative importance
but
iraq
is
now
just cool enough although remember
there's still 50 000 us troops there and
and
something like a hundred and
fifty thousand a hundred thousand uh
contractors iraq is now cool enough at
least in the public
imagination
to properly take a look at it
and that's not something that is yet
possible
with afghanistan
we we did a little bit of that with the
afghan warlord released because it was a
primary source documentation
but otherwise
views about
patriotism
and
the supporting of troops and so on
interferes with the process for iraq
i can see already in the news reportage
a much
fairer
and less defensive
[Music]
portrayal
of
what happened
what happened in iraq that has been
revealed
by this release
so these two countries do not stand in
isolation
these are both
modern
western wars
and the lessons
of iraq
which are ongoing remember this material
covers significant abuses occurring
during the first year of the obama
administration
can be applied
to afghanistan and can be applied to
other places
that western governments may choose
in isolation or in coalition
to invade
the war itself
in the united states i think is becoming
more of an issue
the republicans are using uh the
mismanagement
of the afghan war
against the democrats where one week
before the congressional elections
and
the democrats can point to rightly
the terrible abuses that occurred
under republi a republican
administration
i i hope
that will permit
raising of this issue
but i think in the last 24 hours the
the press has been i'm doing precisely
what they should
and there's a good and broad spectrum
and
you know the press when it concentrates
on a press issue um can
uh
overplay things but i think um their
response to this issue uh has been broad
and proportionate and will continue
okay
yeah anthony fiola with the washington
post um can you detail the steps the
additional steps that you took between
the release of the afghan documents and
these documents in terms of redaction
and to make sure that names etc were not
released
well i think
kristin covered that
pretty well but
um
the the
to make it simple because it's a fairly
long and complex technical process which
i can speak about uh later to some of
you but not not so we don't bore the
room um the
fundamental principle was
to start with everything
every single word and number
redacted
and then to wind that back
by finding
safe words and then
modifying the safe words and phrases
for the rare accounts
where
there were
dual meanings of
words and that process also involved
[Music]
some of the
investigative journalists and
researchers
consulting with us
to
give us a feel for what sort of
information
needed a special care
although i must say in that process
the human rights groups
were very helpful
and the bureau of investigative
journalism was also helpful
but none
of the mainstream press partners
in fact
provided any assistance whatsoever
to the demands
to get four hundred thousand
very serious
documents into the public record and
into history where they can have ongoing
effect
oh and i may add uh the pentagon of
course um
uh refused um it its statement was we
are not interested in a conversation
about harm minimization we are only
wanting to hear how the
documents will be returned and the legal
counsel
for the dod
also issued that statement to us in
private correspondence
right back there
enrico franceschini from republica italy
julian sometimes you're portrayed like a
man on the iran are you
worried about your safety you do you
think that your enemies are trying to
hurt you to get you
well i think i think that that question
has been answered a lot in the past i
mean if you have anything you want to
say to it but well i i mean i can only
sort of get people to
consider the words of daniel ellsberg
that we have a a serious case here where
the obama administration is trying to
create
new law
through
changing the interpretation of existing
law
in a similar manner to
i suppose the way in which bush
expanded the power of the presidency
using lawyers to
create a new interpretations of previous
arrangements
and
that's that is a serious business
that applies not just to me but the
statements made by the pentagon are
trying to be applied
to
all press
in the united states
and outside the united states
wednesday you wrote on your
twitter feed that weekly communications
infrastructure was under attack
do we have any
evidence log files ib addresses which
could help them
pinpoint who is making these attacks and
can you elaborate a bit more what this
attack was about
that matter is still being investigated
and i think is perhaps too far removed
from the the subject of this conference
okay very bad blue
julian beckham summer i had the feeling
you or you said you know you wanted the
truth to come out which you still want
to but i have the feeling now that where
you said you know a lot of wars are
started by
um democracies you hope
that this procedure might stop that
happening in the future so has your aim
broadened all together
no um
we are pursuing the agenda that we have
always pursued
in the red
hold on a microphone is coming to you
there okay go ahead hi anne mcmillan
canadian broadcasting you mentioned that
you hope the lessons will be learnt from
iraq
what would you say are the main lessons
that have come through these four
hundred thousand league documents
well it's too early to tell yet um it is
the responsibility
of the press and the opportunity of the
press and human rights groups and legal
outfits to in fact draw those
conclusions but
i mean
iraq
as we can see
was
a bloodbath
a bloodbath
on every corner
of that country
the stated aims for going into that war
of improv the rule of law
did not eventuate
and
in terms of
raw
numbers
of people arbitrarily killed i
worsened uh the situation in iraq
yep right down there
to a microphone right over here
thanks
till charles from sweet deutsche title
magazine from munich germany um in your
press release you stated that it gives a
the current league gives a pretty good
account of the war in iraq without the
month um may 2004
and march 2009 why
we don't know why those months are
missing
it's important to remember that this
material
while
the most comprehensive and detailed
report
of
any war to ever have entered into the
public record
is far from complete
it is based upon the statements of u.s
soldiers who are
often um
in a position where
they have incentives to lie such as when
they're reporting uh on their own
activities
no one says i unlawfully uh killed a
civilian in the writes a report about it
it is only material that is of the
secret level or below
events which were
subsequently classified as
top secret
are not present it doesn't cover us
special forces it doesn't cover the cia
it doesn't cover
uh the military activities of any other
nation in the coalition partnership or
the activities of the
iraqi army
except
where
the regular united states army
interfaces with them so sometimes the
regular u.s army will pull security for
the cia
engaging combined operations with
the iraqi army with
u.s special forces with
uk forces so we get
small glimpses through a corner of a
window
for
those
organizations involved in the iraq which
are not
the us army proper
so we do glimpse their activities but
this is not a full account of their
activities it is a pretty full account
of the activities of the us army
we've got we've got uh time for one
further question i'll i'll actually pass
it over to you right here
you had your hand up the longest thanks
mary mata voice of america this is a
question
i'm asking anyone on the panel about
we the press
why do you think it's easier for us to
cover things like rape as a tool of war
in places like west africa
and other places
around the world where it's been widely
documented
as opposed to some place like
iraq
one of the things that we
have to face up to and we see it very
clean the bahamas inquiry
is
a historic
british colonial savagery if i can put
it like that the techniques that we were
using in the moosa incident
hooding
stress positions
food and water deprivation
sleep deprivation the use of noise those
all go all the way back to mandated
palestine through all the colonial wars
cyprus malaya aiden kenya and into
northern ireland and you might think
that when ted heath banded in 1972 it
stayed banned no not at all
if you look at what the british did
in iraq
it's a savagery
these iraqi men simply did not exist
they had been completely dehumanized
now my take is one of the reasons the
press are largely silent
on all of this is we just don't want to
face
ourselves
that's my take on the on the on the
british
position and what we did in iraq you'd
have to ask the americans for their take
but i think it's important
that there's a
horrendous racism
and it's we see it in the british army
we see it very clearly in the bahamas
inquiry and i think we can see it very
clearly in everything that is going to
come out
when we get this case heard next next
month and again i invite the british
press particularly to pay attention to
this case it's important
okay we we actually have a one or two
more minutes left there was a hand over
here it was
secrecy is essential to empire and what
i was saying earlier was the united
states right now
no doubt is declining in various ways
but not in intention
and under obama as under bush we are
moving more toward the british system of
control of information which is after
all the official secrets act which is a
legacy of empire and where that torch is
passing the republican administration a
republican house and senate if that
comes into being in the next month
is almost certain to pass a british type
official secrets act essentially ending
leaks uh of the sort we've seen over the
last 40 years 60 years which means that
wikileaks becomes more indispensable
than it has been it becomes the future
of unauthorized disclosure it'll become
more and more important to make these
disclosures anonymously and what has to
be disclosed
as
julian was saying honestly
wikileaks is not sufficient what we've
seen so far
is not what we need it's only a
beginning it's not the pentagon papers
strictly speaking we still need the
pentagon papers of afghanistan and of
iraq
on the decision-making and the
accountability but for that matter the
pentagon papers were very inadequate too
they weren't the white house papers the
ci papers it took this generation to get
most of those and we haven't had any of
it really on the later wars since so
what we need
is uh the closest to it in a way are the
classified documents that were shown to
bob woodward for his latest book so
possibly uh woodward could contribute to
the net all the documents he was shown
top secret that would come close to
being the pentagon papers of the white
house papers of afghanistan would be
very worthwhile short of that
one of his researchers could give those
documents to wikileaks and that would be
very worthwhile and if not one of his
researchers somebody in the
administration should give that type of
material to wikileaks bradley manning is
accused of doing what he could at the
field level at the risk of his life very
admirably he's a hero in my opinion to
end this war he did what he could
what's needed is for people who have
access to information that will help us
understand this war in a way that will
enable us to stop it
to
show us what they know with documents
and actually wikileaks offers itself as
the best vehicle for they're doing that
okay thank you um i think in fact what
we're going to do now is uh
not run a photo call which was booked
here for simple reasons of time now
because it's gone over quite
considerably but we have a short film
produced by wikileaks to help to explain
some of the technical issues uh involved
in reading the documents it's a very
short film but might be helpful to you
because it comes from a knowledge of
those documents directly
you cancelled it
okay we are not going to see it then
this is how to read the daughter that's
that's the one yeah that's the one so
that's just the slides are we still
doing that
we still have this film don't we it's
live
okay
let's do it yeah okay sorry it's gonna
happen sorry
so
because we are so incredibly overloaded
presently you might not have actually
seen this yet but um
this is it warlogs
[Music]
this is
warlocks.wikileaks.org it is the
interface to explore and analyze
these 400 000
classified documents about
the war in iraq
it is a similar interface to
what we produced subsequent to our
initial release for afghanistan
a bit a bit more sophisticated and able
to handle
many
tens of thousands of people
simultaneously
so this is the website
you can see
automatic graphing
of particular elements you can search by
keyword
here's an example
of selecting one of the categories on
the side that is produced by the us
military these are types regions attacks
on type of units and several other
categories
that are not produced by us but they're
the internal military categories by
clicking on these
you'll see them appear here these are
boolean so this is an and the records
must have both of these
type criminal event region
uh baghdad this is multinational
division baghdad
and this is a list
of reports with sort of keywords in
context the underscores
are reduction
and this is looking a bit further down
on the side panel here so you can see
graphs um the number of documents uh for
each one of the numerical fields so
civilians killed date host nation killed
host nation wounded friendly killed etc
quite quite a few of these very easy to
use
here's an example of going into a
particular
record
so bodies found in a carb in the
vicinity of baghdad you clicked on here
expand acronyms very important otherwise
this is almost completely unreadable
and here it is in red the things that
have expanded in acronyms killed in
action would have been kia died of
wounds bow
and on the left
the
the structured data
concerning this event
and will go down a bit this one's quite
interesting here it's not often used but
this is critical incident reporting
sometimes will include a field which is
may cause international media reportage
so actually if you want international
meet something to report you just hunt
on this field and they've done part of
the work for you in some cases obviously
some units where they are involved
themselves in a crime
don't like to
suggest that they have done so through
the use of this field
this is a slightly
more interesting one a full text search
for oga sometimes a p sometimes appears
here as a type of unit oga stands for
other government agency
it's an internal euphemism for the cia
or the defense intelligence agency
typically the cia
and so you can find
these cia related records
small arms fire attack on oga convoy in
baghdad
expanding acronyms here you can see this
unfortunately the reduction is
in fact far far too heavy uh but was
necessary
to prevent any sort of political attack
to distract from the real issue
um
as time goes by and we work through this
material manually um we will be able to
decrease the uh levels of reduction but
in this report not too bad it's mainly
the names and some specific
saying government support little as it
is should continue for npr and for pbs
michael gordon is going to be joining us
he writes for the new york times long
time military correspondent to talk
about the wikileaks
what's in the documents and its impact
on the us military some reaction from
overseas including the iraqi government
and the front page of the washington
post or the new york times i should say
has this story let me just read to you
it's from his colleagues john burns
wikileaks chief on the run trailed by
his notoriety the story focusing on
julia assange in his remarkable journey
to notoriety ms mr assange founder of
wikileaks whistleblowers website sees
the next few weeks as his most hazardous
yet he is making his most brazen
disclosure yet
391 000 secret documents on the iraq war
he held a news conference in london
saturday yesterday saying that the
release constituted the most
comprehensive and detailed account of
any war ever to enter the public record
phillip knightley the great
investigative reporter an australian
who for the past
30 or 40 years has made the uk his home
said
that
the first casualty of war is the truth
but the attack on the truth by war
begins long before war starts and
continues long after a war ends
in our release of these 400 000
documents
about
the iraq war
the intimate detail of that war
from the u.s perspective
we hope
to correct
some of that attack on the truth
that occurred before the war
during the war
and which has continued on
since the
war officially
concluded
julia assange yesterday in london and
michael gordon is the chief military
correspondent for the new york times
good morning thank you very much for
being with us
first of all how damaging is this
pile of information 381 000 documents
and by one report
maybe several hundred thousand iraqi
deaths
well um
first of all i i'd like to explain how
the new york times has handled it which
i think is different than what wikileaks
is doing
um there are approximately four hundred
thousand tactical field level reports
and the times has had access to this
for some time and i've read through them
uh what we did at the new york times is
we read through these um reports we
tried to call from them things we
thought were relevant
to the situation in iraq today this is
not exposure for exposures
sake
and then we picked maybe 20
2-0 documents to post on our website we
redacted information from from these
documents that
may have jeopardized iraqi lives or
undermined current military operations
we showed these documents to the
pentagon we asked the pentagon did they
think any additional
cuts were needed before we posted them
and then we they did not recommend any
additional cuts they didn't like the
fact we were
using the documents but they didn't see
the need for any additional cuts and
that's what we showed we didn't put up
four hundred thousand documents we read
a lot of documents and called relevant
information what wikileaks has done is
different from what we've done but you
obviously got the information from
wikileaks correct and who is the source
behind the leaks
well i don't know i mean
the wikileaks acquired these documents
probably from the
intelligence specialists who
used to work in iraq i mean that's just
a supposition of my part i don't have
any direct knowledge of this they made
this information available as they had
but a previous cash on iraq on
afghanistan to new york times
european-based publications but we don't
take editorial guidance from wikileaks
and
what they did is they established an
embargo for when the information can be
made public but we pretty much did our
own thing but in this day and age you
made your own editorial decision the new
york times the documents if you want to
go through all of them are available on
on different sites
and so as somebody who's looked through
this material what stands out what what
do you take away from what you've read
in the last couple years what i take
away i think's a little different from
what the spin that i've picked up in
some
publications elsewhere
i think they identify a number of very
important issues
that
the united states really needs to pay
attention to
over the next year as american forces
leave you know american forces are due
to leave iraq by the end of 2011 i was
last in iraq and september
here are the issues that come up in the
reports
first
there's very serious tensions between
the kurdish and arab populations in iraq
and american forces have played a very
important and useful role in heading off
problems between these two groups that's
documented in the reports a very
constructive role an essential role
what's going to happen when there's no
american forces there
rule of law
the iraqis are responsible for their own
judicial system their own detention
facilities the americans because we're
leaving have been handing over prisoners
to the iraqis while some of these
prisoners the documents make clear
have been beaten up roughed up harm has
come to them the american forces have
intervened to stop this on many
occasions on other occasions the reports
indicate they reported up the chain of
command and pretty much left it to the
iraqis to do something about it but when
there are no american forces there or no
international presence what's going to
be
the state of rule of law in iraq and
then lastly
something i wrote a lot about the
documents
explain a really significant iranian
role
in providing weapons training to rather
extreme shiite militant groups in iraq
to
try to influence the course of events
there the american forces have been a
bit of a check against this iranian
influence what's going to happen when
we're gone i think if you read the
documents carefully with an eye to
what's happening in the future i think
it points to the need for some sort of
um
well if international presence or
western presence or potential u.s role
if the iraqis want it after the sofa is
um is gone is over with let me pick up
on that point with with uh the reaction
from the iraqi government very concerned
by the release of this information and
secondly your point about iran and its
long-term impact on destabilizing that
part of the world we've seen the
rhetoric from the iranian government but
now these documents indicate that they
provided munitions to iraqi insurgents
against the u.s well first of all the
iranian role has been noted for some
time in iraq i've written about it
previously but what happened is i
actually had critics here in the united
states who would say oh this is just
spin from the u.s government this is
just something the white house is
putting out well these reports are
tactical level reports they don't come
from dick cheney they come from kind of
low level american units over a period
of many years 2004 through 2009 and
what's really striking is that this
iranian role continues well into the
obama administration so now president
obama has reached out his hand to tehran
he tried to engage him
i interviewed him on on this during the
campaign he said that's what he was
going to try to do and yet this kind of
clandestine role of training shiite
militants in iran
and supporting them has continued i
don't know that that's surprising but
it's interesting that it's reflected in
these reports and
does this in any way the release of
these documents changed the culture in
the military in putting
this information on paper where at some
point everything is going to be out
there in the public record but maybe now
sooner than the pentagon papers back in
the 1970s does it change the way that
the military does its business first of
all these are nothing like the pentagon
papers these are tactical field reports
by units
if there are nearly 400 000
a lot of them rather tedious and mundane
they're not all
full of information but no i mean the
military has to report it has to report
to up its chain of command they don't do
this for the public they do this for
their own chain of command and for their
own organization i think it may lead the
military to put different procedures in
place so that its own intelligence
officers do not share hundreds of
thousands of documents with an
organization that's highly critical of
their operations i realize you can't
release your sources but when did you
begin looking when did they you get
notified that these documents were going
to be coming to you and how long did you
have to sift through the material well
i'm
just a reporter there i i wasn't part of
whatever this arrangement was but i i've
been working on them for a couple months
we'll get to your phone calls 202 is the
area code
737-001 is our line for republicans in
202-737-002 for democrats our guest is
michael gordon who covers the pentagon
for the new york times ron is joining us
from north carolina good morning welcome
to the washington journal
thank you for speaking i'd like to ask
mr gordon what is the most damaging
thing that you've read in the wikileaks
and who in our government hides it from
the public like
who's corrupt in our government that's
hiding these secrets supposedly
well i i i don't think i i did it did
not change my understanding of what's
happened in the iraq war which i've
covered
since
it began and i've spent some
considerable time
on the ground
in iraq so
i what i think the documents
do is it they flesh out a lot of what we
already know about iraq and they reveal
some
episodes that had
previously
been unknown
and but what i didn't find
you know i think the thing that probably
the pentagon is most sensitive to
is cases of abuse in iraqi detention
facilities this is abuse against iraqis
by iraqis not by americans
but it raises a question as to what the
american oversight role should have been
and how active the united states should
have been in trying to stop these
episodes in many cases i know we did
what it suggests in some cases the
americans didn't
joe with his point about the
instability in iraq i guess is the best
way to put it he writes we replaced the
brutal dictatorship in iraq with a
brutal democracy
well
um
what's happening in iraq now is
vitally important and it's a little
disconcerting to me uh that
there's not how little attention it
seems to receive in the united states
and and really how little our own
government talks about it but iraq's in
in the process they had an election in
march in the process of forming a new
government
they haven't formed it yet they're
negotiating it uh they're
it's a work in progress and prime
minister maliki is almost certainly
going to continue as prime minister and
the question is is this new government
going to be what the americans want a
unity government that's representative
and incorporates uh other parties some
of them at least sympathetic to the west
or is it going to be iranian influenced
that is maliki will be there but the
rest of his coalition will be almost
entirely shiite including
parties that are very sensitive to the
concerns of tehran that's the political
struggle that's going on in iraq today
the extensive reporting of our guest
michael gordon chief military
correspondent for the new york times is
available on the new york times website
and you can check out the war logs and
also the latest on the wikileaks story
which broke on friday our guest is the
author or co-author of a number of books
including cobra ii the inside story of
the invasion and occupation of iraq also
the generals war the history of the 1991
persian gulf war he has been with the
national journal and the associated
press i'm sorry the national journal and
been with the new york times since 1985
rick is joining us republican line from
brian ohio good morning
yes good morning
good morning
i would like you to compare it
and contrast
richard nixon's
response to the pentagon papers
vis-a-vis
or president obama's response to the
wikileaks
i think i think it's a false analogy i
think that these are not the pentagon
papers
this these are tactical level reports
hundreds of thousands of them
by every unit a lot of them are very
like unit a goes from point a to point b
and id goes off or
there was a raid at a particular
location
these are not sort of investigations of
how the policy arose or even even
intelligence analyses they're not top
secret
so first of all they're not the pentagon
papers
second of all
i mean the pentagon and the obama
administrations made it clear
that they are unhappy
with
the disclosure
of these
documents
but i frankly don't think there's much
they could have done to prevent it at
this point they're in the hands of an
organization
that is posting them on a website and
distributing them to news organizations
on various continents
but the comparison and it's pointed out
in your story is uh the quotes from
daniel ellsberg in the new york times
today he said quote i've been waiting 40
years for someone to disclose
information on a scale that might really
make a difference said daniel ellsberg
who did expose the 1 000 page secret
study of the vietnam war back in 1971
that became known as the pentagon papers
well with all due respect to mr ellsberg
i think that's a false analogy these are
not the pentagon papers and i frankly
don't think they're going to change in
any fundamental way
american policy in iraq
or
nor did they change by the way american
policy and afghanistan i do think they
raised some important questions
about what our policy should be going
forward and the issues that the american
government needs to attend to who is
julian assange
well i don't really know because i've
never met the man
but my colleague
john burns who's posted in london
uh did a a long story about him today's
new york times and interviewed him in
length in london but he's an australian
uh he's um the paramount leader so to
speak of wikileaks he seems to be a
controversial figure within his own
organization which seems to have some
divisions and he's previously been
highly critical of the american
government and based on what john burns
writes today on the run uh at least
figuratively and trying to keep out of
the public eye although he did come
public yesterday well he seems to have
convinced himself that he's um
uh
in peril and needs to be on the run i
don't know what the actual situation is
our next call is kay joining us from
atlanta with michael gordon of the new
york times good morning
good morning
mr gordon you stated earlier that you
didn't know the source of the leaks but
it was my understanding that
someone from the military leaked this
information i recall a story a few
months ago when we first had the first
wikileaks that there was someone in the
military who was pretending to be
listening to music cds but was copying
these documents to the cds isn't that
the same source of these wikileaks and
why are we demonizing mr assange and not
the military personnel who copied all
this documents on the disk and released
it and the person even wanted to know
why america wasn't outraged and why we
weren't talking about it he seems like
he wanted to be
a hero for putting this information out
so that the american people can see it
it was a military personnel from my
understanding who
is the source of these documents and not
a cia operative as you stated thank you
now you misrepresented what i said i
didn't say was a ci operative i said it
was an american military i said exactly
what you said
that it was an american military
intelligence officer he worked for army
intelligence he was an intelligence kind
of low-level person
in a base in iraq
who
is believed
to have uh downloaded really all of
these uh reports and provided them to
wikileaks according to media reports but
what i so you know what you say um
certainly fits with my understanding of
what happened but what the point i'm
trying to make is i have no independent
knowledge of this i've not investigated
it
uh there's a uh the guy is being held in
a military brig they're doing their own
he's almost certainly going to go to
trial
i've just done no reporting into who
actually provided it or how that happens
so my understanding is similar to yours
but it's basically based on media
reports front page of your newspaper
this morning the iraq archive private
gunman fed turmoil can you explain
well this again is an issue that um
is familiar to a lot of people it's the
issue of contractors and we know that in
iraq blackwater
uh very often played a negative role uh
you know they weren't really up to the
standards of training of american forces
didn't have the discipline and there was
a very notorious episode in baghdad
where
they were very free in
with their gunfire and killed a lot of
civilians
and what the article by my colleague jim
glance does is he he called through all
of these reports he found other cases
of
where contractors fell short of
certainly the sort of standards that
the u.s military sets and how they
conducted themselves you know when they
used fire um
in their dealings with iraqi civilians
it's it's a very important issue and one
point i want you to elaborate on quote
there have been many abuses including
civilian deaths to the point that the
afghan government is working to ban many
outside contractors entirely
well this is known uh president karzai
has been critical of
contr western contractors uh there may
be some degree of afghan politics in
there he may be trying to free up
contracts for afghan contractors but
certainly the role of contractors on the
battlefield is an important important
one you know when the united states
forces leave iraq at the end of 2011 the
state department plans to hire thousands
thousands of security contractors to
protect its personnel in iraq there is a
legitimate role for contractors to
protect diplomatic personnel uh but um
they they became uh in certain
situations that are almost a kind of a
well they played
because they weren't as well trained as
the military because they were a little
occasionally i think shot too freely i
think they created a lot of problems
there as well i realize there are so
many variables involved in this question
down the road but when the history books
are written about our involvement in
iraq what will it state
well i'm writing a book now about our
involvement in iraq so i'm right in the
middle of it i think what it'll state is
that
the americans got off on the wrong foot
in iraq through poor post-war planning
that our initial military strategy
was lacking
and that this was uh one factor in the
rise of sectarian violence that the
surge was a necessary step
in terms of trying to tamp down the
sectarian violence in iraq and reverse
the military uh
kind of momentum it will gain some
momentum there militarily
but that the true test of of american
policy is going to come this year and
next year when this new iraqi government
forms and if it's a government that's
representative
inclusive
reasonably democratic at least by
standards in that region which are not
high
i think then you could say
the american policy was pretty much on
track if it turns out to be sympathetic
to iranian
influence or if a new
civil war breaks out then i think that
will be a major setback so i think this
next next year is really um a decisive
chapter in trying to turn out and trying
to determine
uh what really happened in iraq and and
what it means for american policy so
it's really astounding to me how little
in interest there is not on your part
but on the part of
well a lot of people and just really how
little even our own government talks
about it when's the book coming out and
is there a working title i don't have a
working title i'm willing to take
suggestions
it'll certainly cover events over the
next year and um
i'm trying to
to uh you know i'd like to be certainly
done by a year from now and let me go
back to an earlier caller who pointed
out that some of the lessons that we can
take away for the media
is there a lesson should the media have
been tougher and asking different
questions leading up to the iraq war in
the post-9 11 environment that we all
faced
yes the media
should have been tougher myself included
and
and i i think a lot of the questions
that um
were not asked are not the famous ones
so much about the wmd but about the
the assumptions that went into the
administration's
war planning uh which basically assumed
a fairly short and benign uh occupation
what the american government
really knew about iraq and the internal
uh situation and really the extent of
the post-war planning was supposed to be
planning for the first war but it just
became planning for another phase of the
war
all the plans are wrapped in secrecy the
administration wasn't communicating much
about it congress really didn't perform
its role well because they didn't really
hold serious hearings on the subject
like they did for the gulf war but i
think the media
could have pressed harder on that and of
course a new chapter on the iraq war
will be coming out when president bush's
book is out early next month
right but it'll be president obama um
you know this is no longer just bush's
war it's uh president bush's war and
president obama's war president obama
inherited a situation president vice
president biden's been very active in
the political discussions
in baghdad in fact when i was there in
september i was with vice president
biden so
this is like afghanistan this is a
conflict that spans two administrations
and both will bear responsibility for
the outcome we're getting the
perspective of michael gordon from the
new york times chief military
correspondent
about the the war in iraq and the
release of these documents by wikileaks
and also uh excerpts available on the
new york times website called the war
log and the reporting of our guest jc is
joining us from prescott arizona good
morning
well steve
uh to uh mr gordon in your book will you
have the decency to uh
go and question and interview some iraqi
citizens
and then include their opinion about
what's going down in their country
and i thank god if there is a god
uh for a julian assange because
you people sit here uh every day and
make decisions about
the sectarian violence in another nation
affairs
between the people there and you have
things in this country that are not
straightened out and you're right you
should have
been more astute in our questioning i
mean been more questionable to the bush
administration about what they were
doing but it's just not about the war
plan it's about how and why i mean they
changed week after week the reason why
we were in there and you all embedded
importers our reporters going in
supposedly
uh uh representing uh the press
you guys were bought and paid for from
the beginning and then you come back and
you invest in the stock market
and and uh everything that you say is
right now supports the idea that you all
have a right to go in
invade take over
and just
run a lot of people into the ground and
you come back as if it's no big deal and
like you have credibility as this
somebody should sit there and listen to
you and you want to demonize mr assange
jc i'll stop you there you made a couple
of points michael gordon a chance to
respond
well first of all i think you don't
understand the role of the media very
well i i didn't
i didn't run the invasion i covered the
invasion i was in iraq for some time i
was embedded with our forces there and
i've talked to a lot of iraqis so
i have a pretty good understanding of
what how the iraqis feel about the
american presence about the war and it
won't surprise you to know that there's
no one iraqi opinion if you're a member
of a minority group in iraq and you feel
like
if the americans leave you're going to
be
suppressed or worse
by
by elements of the government of the
security forces you you sort of want the
americans to stay there until there's a
more stable situation if you're
a member of a
kind of an extreme faction that you
think you can take over part of iraq
then you want the americans out of the
way uh but i didn't run the invasion and
by the way um that most democratic party
supported it uh at the time so i i think
if
i i do think questions about the state
of post-war planning should have been
asked by everybody but i think they
should also been put not merely to the
white house but to
the congress that supported the
uh the conflict kathleen is uh the
mother of a member of the service she
writes shock and awe disgusted me my son
was doing this this isn't loving and
giving freedom to people
i cried while watching
any
um i guess she's um
she's opposed to the war she is yes um
well
i i think um
i'm not taking a kind of a public
position on should we or shouldn't have
gone to war my stance is more like we're
there and what's the responsible thing
to do and one thing that was apparent to
me before the surge
was that if american forces had left
immediately
and and completely
in the 2006 time frame
uh the civil war there would have
intensified so um
sometimes uh the simple thing is not
always the easy thing or even the
correct thing to do under the
circumstances i mean a course has been
laid out under president obama and
president bush to have all our forces
out by 2011 and but to maintain some
degree of engagement and there's a
possibility of
of um having a training role after 2011
i think i heard ryan crocker speak on
friday the former u.s ambassador we
covered that speech yeah well it was a
very important speech and he was talking
about the need to um to stay engaged and
involved
with iraq because the iraqi clock as he
puts it and the american clock are
different this is a long-term project if
we want to see stability
in that very important part of the world
could it look something like south korea
in terms of our troop presence over
there not not to the level that we have
in south korea but but it's been a
long-term commitment uh 60 years after
the war
i don't think so i think that the middle
east and uh i think the american
military presence is is in a very
nationalist country like iraq is i don't
think they would want a large
and very visible american military
presence but i do think you know if you
talk to iraqi interior ministry people
or army or security officials they want
some sort of american role after 2011 to
train their forces because they know
they can't control their airspace they
can't control their borders they still
are fielding weapons and they're still
going to have a problem with an
insurgency they'll want that sort of
thing the problem is this is caught up
in terms of politics in iraq and it's
caught up in politics in the united
states you've been to iraq on how many
occasions
um i can't really remember because
i've been there i was there for the
invasion and i was there then i wrote
cobra too but then i've been there every
year since 2006 but i would sometimes go
for
three months at a time come back here
for a few months go back there for uh
several months
so um
it's not really the amount the number of
times you've been there it's how long
you've been on the ground but i've been
in most parts of iraq with american
forces
[Music]
and
pre-surge surge and post-surge
and it's a very complicated
society
one of general petraeus's aides used to
say people who think they have all the
answers for iraq or people who haven't
spent enough time in iraq let's show
your book and we'll get a call from jim
in winston-salem north carolina good
morning
yes good morning um and thank you
gentlemen um for
being there this morning i've been
listening for the last hour and a half i
believe
um
we've only been on for about an hour but
maybe well about an hour okay okay uh
i'll uh i stand corrected you can we're
glad to have you as long as you can be
with us go ahead jim okay yes sir um
um i um and and and i'd like to have a
comment afterwards
uh but uh um
uh i i think that uh this is an example
of
of um um
the obama strategy and uh and um uh with
um uh concerning um our intelligence
agencies and and uh it wouldn't surprise
me if wikileaks wasn't sponsored by um a
liberal party of some group or some
think tank of some sort uh
to
get the news out since abc and nbc and
cbs and someone earlier i heard say that
there were so many conservative voices
out there that uh you know and no
liberals will well just about every one
of the uh abc groups you know the
alphabet uh
programs uh
were
or sponsoring liberals and during the
election um you we all noticed um
exact last election we all noticed how
much uh they talked about the war and
how
um uh bad it was but i don't think that
kennedy and let's go back this far
kennedy and eisenhower and those guys
um
when i was very young of course um uh
i'd like to say that uh uh you wouldn't
hear of any
um so-called leaks i mean that would be
a national tragedy hey jim i'm we're
short on time so i just want if you want
to sum up with a quick question and mr
gordon can respond
okay
go ahead okay uh just that uh that uh
can during the kennedy era you we would
never have that any uh uh problems like
that so i'll just you know let you uh
end that i'll end there and and i'll
thank you for your thank you jim
i don't think you can hold the obama
administration responsible for the leaks
of uh wayward intelligence officer
in iraq and i and since i've been the
new york times 25 years i've written a
lot of stories about a lot of uh
internal documents and i've done it
during all administrations um this is
hardly the first time we've had to
grapple with how to handle classified
information i've done it under
republicans and democrats i don't really
see much difference in that regard and
clearly without stating the obvious
technology has changed over the last 40
years the internet not the least among
in terms of getting information out to
different groups right that's a big
difference now an independent
organization really an international
organization with no ties to the
american government like wikileaks
can put this in this information was
going to come out in some form
it's just we we got an early look at it
and tried to
uh do a responsible job in digesting it
and publishing it
if we hadn't done it it still would have
come out in
in a form but i don't think every people
would have been as
been able to make a whole lot of sense
out of it cobra ii the inside story of
the invasion and the occupation of iraq
co-written by our guest michael gordon
of the new york times
johnny has the last question joining us
from paris kentucky good morning
good
morning uh my question is can you hear
me yes you can
uh my question i just have two comments
and a quick question the first comment
npr they should get their funding second
comment mr gordon is correct this
information was to come out eventually
in some form
but i think the most important question
hasn't been asked yet
the most important question to me is if
this upcoming election the republicans
take back the house
in the senate then all of a sudden our
economy gets great
all businesses start building jobs start
being created
the american people need to ask why can
this happen overnight and cannot happen
through an administration who is trying
to do the best for our public trying to
fight two wars because iraq is not over
with yet we still have fifty thousand
people there
my question is why can it happen
overnight why can't it happen now thank
you mr garden gordon have a good day
thank you johnny
well my only i don't
don't have any comments on domestic
policy or politics uh my only
perspective is somebody who's been in
iraq uh since the invasion and been
there
most years and seen in all different
phases
is uh you're absolutely right it's not
over yet it's mostly in the political
realm fortunately our forces are out of
the city but even though the
administration declared an end to combat
there's been fighting since then they
don't call it combat it's merely
fighting americans have died but um
we're really moving into a different
phase and american forces are to leave
by the end of 20 2011 they may continue
to be there in small numbers but our
involvement in iraq is still i think
important and and the united states
still has a lot of influence there and
both iraq and afghanistan are long-term
uh kind of propositions and if you take
a short-term
perspective to either of them you almost
certainly will fail my final question to
you is do you have questions having
looked through this material is there a
question that is looming out there that
you want to get answered
in terms of
our involvement in iraq and what you've
read and seen
well the material didn't didn't
enlighten me
beyond you know i i've been
working on iraq for for quite a while i
found the material useful
primarily because it
in the case of iran or the kurdish arab
issues it brought a few things to light
that i i didn't know but it didn't
change my fundamental uh understanding
that the things i'm really focused on is
really this political year in iraq
what's going to happen in the formation
of the new government there and really
what degree what i think the fundamental
question is what how much influence does
the americans
do the united states have in iraq now
political influence and how much is it
prepared to use to try to get the
outcome that that
i think we'd all like to see
michael gordon is the chief military
correspondent for the new york times
thank you very much for being with us
this morning thank you we appreciate
your time
our sunday round table coming up in just
a moment patricia murphy and von ververs
will be with us to look at some of the
latest polling information and look
ahead nine days before the election the
president back on the campaign trail
again tomorrow and of course the midterm
elections and
politics of 2010 dominating the sunday
morning programs
nancy callow is following all of that
joining us from the c-span radio studios
re-airs of the network tv talk programs
begin at noon eastern on c-span radio
today the issues include of course the
fall midterm elections and the war in
afghanistan
first hear nbc's meet the press host
david gregory welcomes republican
national committee chairman michael
steele and former congressman harold
ford of tennessee he's now chairman of
the democratic leadership council
at one o'clock it's abc's this week host
christian amanpour host tim kaine
chairman of the democratic national
committee and retired general hugh
shelton former chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff
fox news sunday with host chris wallace
begins re-airing at 2pm eastern his
guests today include pat toomey the
republican nominee for the senate seat
in pennsylvania and joe manchin the
democratic nominee for the senate seat
in west virginia
at three o'clock it's face the nation
from cbs host bob schieffer talks with
karl rove former adviser to president
george w bush and representative chris
van hollen chairman of the democratic
congressional campaign committee
finally at 3 30 p.m it's cnn's state of
the union candy crowley moderates a
one-hour debate by florida senate
candidates governor charlie crist and
independent democratic representative
kendrick meek and republican marco rubio
again re-airs of the network tv talk
shows begin at noon eastern with nbc's
meet the press one o'clock here abc's
this week two o'clock fox news sunday
face the nation from cbs at 3 and
finally at 3 30 pm cnn state of the
union listen to them all on c-span radio
on 90.1 fm in the washington dc area on
your iphone or on xm satellite radio
channel 132 or anywhere online at
csbandradio.org
video library search watch and share all
free it's washington your way
washington journal continues
first amendment lawyer floyd abrams
joins us he represented the new york
times during the pentagon papers case
thank you for being here
thank you similarities to the pentagon
the pentagon papers case differences how
do you compare the wikileaks situation
to that
there are obviously some similarities in
the sense of
classified documents
leaking
to individuals
who were not authorized to have them and
then becoming public
but i'd say the biggest difference is
that the pentagon papers was basically a
historical study
of how the united states became involved
in the war in vietnam
it became public in 1971
when the new york times obtained a copy
of most of the volumes of a secret study
prepared for the then secretary of
defense but the material was all
historical there was nothing more recent
than three years before
and the time source daniel ellsberg had
not given it what were called the
negotiating volumes the most sensitive
volumes of this study which dealt with
efforts to end the war
here
the wikileaks leaks
i would say are much more sensitive
certainly much more current
but much more sensitive as well i mean
here you have a uh by way of example uh
you know an american diplomat quoting
the king of saudi arabia
saying that he wished israel
would bomb iran
and cut the serpent's head off
now that i mean that's an extraordinary
thing
and there was nothing like that nothing
as
alive
perhaps dangerous
to publish i would say dangerous to
publish
probably nothing as newsworthy also
then the final difference though is that
the pentagon papers showed
a lot of lying throughout the years by
the american government
to the american people
about
our increasing involvement in vietnam
and how we became involved and the like
uh i don't think that the wikileaks
leaks
involve that at all in fact i think
generally the government comes out
pretty well certainly it does not show
anything like a pattern of misbehavior
by the united states or its diplomats
this comes to us from the wall street
journal a recent story that says soon
after the contents of sensitive u.s
diplomatic cables were blasted across
the tops of u.s and european newspapers
television commentators editorial
writers and politicians began calling
for the arrest of the man behind the
website that fed the information to the
papers we're talking about julian
assange and the article goes on to say
though that trying to bring him to
justice will be another matter
floyd abrams what could really be used
what could be the vehicle to prosecute
him how far for example does the
espionage act go
well
we have an espionage act
it is very old it was passed in 1917
it is archaic in a lot of ways it's
phrased very broadly
so on the if all you did was read it
you would think that articles that you
read every day in the newspapers violate
the espionage law
and that's a problem with the law if a
law seems to cover too much it often
winds up covering nothing
but
is it possible is it plausible that the
department of justice could mount
a
criminal prosecution
i'd say yes
it is
it would be a hard case
but a possible one one of the elements
they have to prove which is ordinarily
very difficult is a sort of bad faith
on the part of the person who has
documents or is revealing information in
documents or not returning documents
which are secret in in one way or
another
i think they might be able to prove that
bad faith although mr assange would
certainly argue that look he offered to
share the information with the state
department and to
get the benefit of their views
on what he should publish and whatnot
but taken as a whole
yes the espionage act could allow
prosecution but it would be difficult
and another thing is we'd have to find
him
uh that's not easy yeah let's talk about
finding him in a moment absolutely but
you know i wanted to you mentioned in an
npr interview last week that mr assange
has actually as you said gone a long
ways down the road of actually talking
himself into a possible violation of the
espionage act what are you hearing from
him and how does that potentially add
some weight to a charge
well i mean the some of the statements
he's made
are
on their face
saying
i want to frustrate the united states
ability to carry on a foreign policy i
want to frustrate government
efforts to go and do things around the
world
the espionage act is couched in terms of
people having unauthorized possession of
documents with reason to believe
that they can be used for to the harm of
the united states or the advantage of a
foreign country
well now we have mr assange out there
seeming to celebrate
every time a document
seems to put the us in a bad light that
this is what he did with respect to the
initial uh dump of documents about
afghanistan uh in which when uh he uh i
think uh
uh in a terribly reckless way
included in the documents that he made
public
ones which disclosed the identity
of uh afghan individuals who were
helping the united states and when
confronted with that he basically said
well anyone that's helping the u.s
ought to be exposed
so that sort of statement is the sort of
statement that if the government were to
prosecute they would use against him now
to be fair he would say
but look i wrote a letter i said to the
state department tell me what's so
terrible and what i have here
and i'll think about it so you know it's
not so easy
floyd abrams first amendment lawyer with
cahill gordon and reindell he joins us
from new york city let's get to your
calls we're speaking with mr abrams
about the legal issues surrounding the
wikileaks dump last week tisch
independent caller in mount vernon
washington good morning
hi good morning and thank you for taking
my call
just like the last person that was on
there talking about home foreclosures we
citizens of the world need to we have a
need to know for far more of the
information that's being hidden in so
many areas
the last guy was just talking about all
the home foreclosures and he was saying
things like subprime owners you know
they they shouldn't have homes kind of
thing and that not everyone can afford
to and we need healthy buyers and
there's no free lunch and everything
however
get us back on track here
we have a wikileaker here i am if we
have had a wikileak
thing going on in this program
uh you know to show what's going on
behind the scenes rich people people
with cash can still go and buy those
homes they can still go by many times
any if any buyer could have bought a
home at those prices but the thing is we
have a need to know in this world okay
well let's let's leave it there and
let's go to floyd abrams about that need
to know i mean does that make a can mr
assange make that case
well uh he certainly would try to and
and let me say that i i i think the the
theme of the caller
is correct and that is to say
there is a need for more information to
be made available
to more people
more often
by their governance
excuse me and one of the problems here
and a problem that we've had for many
years
is that there remains a significant over
classification
of documents uh uh in washington that
that too many
secrets aren't secrets too much that is
classified has no business uh being
classified
and and certainly one of the directions
we should be moving towards in the
future
is making
more information more available now that
doesn't mean
that the sort of thing i referred to
earlier i mean the identification of of
individuals in a position to be harmed
in afghanistan
ought to be made public but it does mean
that as a matter of policy
we ought to be aiming at making more
information available and and trying to
do things to avoid the the over
classification
which has plagued
our government for many years
eric democratic caller in illinois good
morning
good morning mr adrian
um
in many respects it's hard to make the
u.s look
any worse than how it's actually
responded to this event
i mean we've seen
in recent years
china
uh using drastic measures to block
websites and the internet and i hear
that there's attempts
by
some some uh groups to try to do that to
wikileaks
we've also seen uh elements from russia
uh assassinated dissonant in the united
kingdom
now they're right-wing pundits like
jonah goldberg and william crystal were
advocating murdering the head of
wikileaks
well look i certainly agree with you
that
the
call
for the assassination uh and there have
been some calls
of mr assange are uh you know outrageous
uh uh
unacceptable
um
uh you know that said uh
there are also there's lots of room for
criticism uh of what he's done
uh and lots of room to
try to at least
move our law uh in a direction
which would make it more difficult for
this sort of thing to happen again i
mean look one of the reasons that this
has happened
is a change of technology
so much information is now available so
easily
in a miniaturized form
it's put together it's
you don't need to rifle through files
anymore for a pfc in the army to have
access for example to information about
discussions of general petraeus
and the afghanistan leader
is is madness
and one of the reasons it happens
is a new technology which which we have
to somehow deal with
which makes everything so compressed so
available
and available to too many people
i mean that at the same time that i
think we ought to make more information
available
we ought to try to have some more common
sense about what information is
genuinely
secret we do need some secrets we do
need to protect some secrets
and we have to try to find a way to do
that at the same time as we make more
information
more candidly and more vigorously
available to the american public so do
you think that wikileaks is comparable
to a news organization that would be
deserving of free speech
protections
i don't consider wikileaks a
journalistic uh organization
but it's not only journalists who have
free speech protections
we all have it whether or not we are
journalists
wikileaks
has played a sort of hybrid role here
a sort of
quasi-journalistic role in one way
by providing information
sometimes as i say dangerous information
but by providing
information
publicly at the same time it's almost
acting as if it's a source
i mean it makes information available
first to certain newspapers
with the promise that they won't reveal
it until a fixed date
almost as if it is the internal source
almost as if it is the pfc
uh who
it appears
was the original source of the
information wikileaks has a first
amendment argument
and it is a serious first amendment
argument
if it is ever charged at the same time
and that's why this issue is so
difficult as a legal matter at the same
time the government
has a genuine and serious
national security argument to be made
with respect to the behavior
often the misbehavior of wikileaks jack
republican caller in providence rhode
island welcome
ah good morning
um the reason yes thank you the reason
for the call is um
the wikileaks
leak
of this uh various information
concerning iraq afghanistan etc etc
um
it could probably parallel
some things that occurred during uh
world war ii no definitely the public
did not have access to information so
quickly at that time
where prior
uh to pearl harbor you know which is
coming up uh
actually tomorrow the date
uh back in i think uh november of 41
secretary of war pardon me stimson
stated and this can be downloaded now
it's public information
that i'm going to paraphrase it
we have to maneuver the japanese into
firing the first shot without doing too
much damage to ourselves and this is on
admiral kimmel's grandson's website
now that's uh
pretty damning evidence as far as i'm
concerned that the united states was
looking for ways to get into war with
japan
uh i have to say i i'm not an expert on
the circumstances
of the united states being attacked by
the japanese
but there was a lengthy period
at that time
of
negotiations
with the japanese
and of demands uh by both sides
which uh obviously led everyone involved
to be thinking about all the
possibilities my impression was that all
that was meant by that sort of statement
was that if there was going to be a war
not that the u.s wanted a war but if
there was going to be a war
we ought not to be the one to provoke it
this is an ap story just out wikileaks
swedish web hosting company says its
servers have become unresponsive and are
probably under attack prq company
spokesman mikhail vyborg says the cause
of the disturbance isn't immediately
clear but says he believes it's probably
because of a so-called disturbance a
rather distributed denial of services
attack wikileaks is facing a attacks on
a variety of fronts uh paypal has
cancelled its ties to wikileaks
amazon.com did as well looking at a new
york times piece from
just yesterday
there's all sorts of other ways that
that that the service is being damaged
and wikileaks twitter feed said
that paypal had surrendered to u.s
government pressure floyd abrams what is
the role of the us government and other
governments to
inflict some sort of pressure on private
companies to play ball with what the u.s
government wants
well as a strictly legal matter
the u.s can
urge
but not require
uh
companies to behave in some
some particular way once it becomes
a requirement or anything like it
then the first amendment comes into play
again
in terms of those companies
i do think though that the the issue
of
whether private companies
that disapprove
of wikileaks behavior
should
demonstrate
the level of their disapproval
by taking the sort of action
uh that you uh
advert to
is a is a very important one and a
another um a very difficult one
uh these companies have the the right
the legal right and indeed the moral
right i think uh to behave uh
as they wish
and to take steps that the they think
are in the interest of the country as
well as themselves
on the other hand
you know we would be very concerned
in other circumstances
if private companies who disapproved of
what a newspaper was printing
refused to sell newsprint or refused to
make paper available or took other steps
of a more modern
sort of way
to keep dissident information
from from coming out so that this is
another
very very sensitive area which has been
uh
brought into being as a result
of what wikileaks has done let's hear
from an independent caller in
connecticut good morning peggy yes good
morning thanks east ben um i just wanted
i'm kind of surprised at my own reaction
uh to join the assange and the wikileaks
uh because i kind of feel like we're uh
shooting the messenger and i don't know
if he's uh
exposed other secrets uh basically in
other countries like he's exposing them
the united states government and that i
know he's got access with this young man
allegedly who has done this thing i'm
really surprised because um personally i
can't wait to hear what the financial
revelations will be if they ever get
exposed i'd like to kind of see what's
going on in in that department but uh is
do you are you surprised that this has
shown such a
wide variance than than valerie plane's
case because that to me was just
dismissed with a stroke of a pen and uh
life goes on i thought that was very
serious but thank you for any comments
you might have thank you
of course the valerie plaim
situation if you're referring of course
to the commutation by president bush
of scooter libby's sentence
was
dealt with
as you say with the stroke of the pen
the the conviction stands
but there was no
sentence to uh jail
i am interested though you know in your
uh comment uh about assange
in the sense of
uh
some contribution you may have made
uh one of the reasons i find this all
a very difficult area
is that as one can see by reading
our newspapers
some of the material which has been made
available
even though i don't think it shows
misconduct
by the united states
really does permit
a better understanding of certain things
going on in the world
at the same time
that very better understanding can
compromise our ability
to accomplish what we want in the world
when wikileaks reports about yemen for
example
about the
yemenis leader
saying to the u.s ambassador in
in substance
that
you the u.s can continue to do the
bombing
of al qaeda areas in yemen
and we will say that we did it
that in general is precisely what the
united states and i think the u.s people
would think is is a good thing you know
we we want to deal with
uh to combat uh al-qaeda
at the same time we can certainly learn
a lot
we learned something of significance of
interest
in learning that that conversation
occurred are we better off on balance
knowing that or are we better off simply
letting it happen without knowing
as a general matter those of us who
toil in the first amendment vineyards
you know you usually say
uh you know more information more
information
the more you get into deep national
security areas
uh
the the closer that question becomes not
as a legal matter but the closer the
question becomes in terms of what we
should want as a people if we could will
it
if we could choose do you see
sort of a
50 50 moment here where some of the
things that mr assange has brought to
light
could be in this sort of
moment of free speech adding to the
public knowledge and do you see some of
it also as potentially breaking a law i
mean
what is the balance that you see here
well uh or how did the scales tip which
way does it go
yeah yeah let me say first of all what
he has done would violate
the law in just about every country in
the world
there are two reasons
why it's a very close question here
one is the first amendment we really
mean it when we say
that we protect freedom of speech
even in situations
where the speech may do us some harm
unless we're really
really very persuaded as a general
matter that that the speech is just
about sure
to do so that's one difference between
the us and abroad second
we happen to have
legislation which is so old
so badly drafted
uh
so
hard to parse in terms of when it will
be applied and when it could be applied
that we never know
never know
when the government could or might or
even sometimes should
take action uh under it for example i'm
very concerned that if the government
were to start an espionage
one of the consequences
and the unintended consequences
could be
significantly to threaten the ability
of the american press at its best at its
very best to report about serious
matters relating to national security
which all of us would say the public
ought to know about
uh i mean that's that's the drafting
problem here if anyone wants to do new
legislation and that is one of the real
things that i hope the department of
justice is thinking about as it
considers
whether to start a prosecution of mr
assange or not floyd abrams first
amendment lawyer with cahill gordon and
reindell in new york city and he
represented the new york times in the
pentagon papers case nearly 40 years ago
taking the position that the first
amendment protected the new york times
and the washington post's right to
publish a classified report on the
vietnam war mr abrams a handful of
senators senator ensign lieberman and
brown are looking at tightening up the
espionage act they're introducing
legislation they're calling the shield
act and they say it would give the
administration
increased flexibility to go after
wikileaks and julian assange what do you
think needs to be done to tighten up the
espionage act
i think there should be a way
to
narrow the espionage act
in a way which
could be used
in circumstances similar to
what mr assange has done
but i have to say
it's not easy to draft without really
getting into areas which might
compromise the first amendment congress
drafted legislation just a few years ago
indeed congress passed legislation which
basically said
that
any
communication including publication of
classified material
was a crime
uh fortunately in my view fortunately
president clinton vetoed that bill
because
so much is classified
that the notion of of making the
classification alone
the basis for a criminal prosecution
would subject a lot as i said earlier of
the best
and most important american journalism
to prosecution
so
yeah should congress have a look and see
if there's some way to to tighten the
statute
in a way which could catch the worst
abuses while allowing
the
broad protections of the first amendment
still to hold sway yeah that they should
look at it but they better be very
careful because it is very easy
particularly when people are angry
at what what mr assange has done it's
very easy to draft legislation which
would make things worse not better
let's take a look at comments that
senator john kerry made yesterday on
meet the press about wikileaks
you heard senator mcconnell say this is
a
high-tech terrorist secretary
defense secretary of course had a
slightly different view of what the
fallout actually is and this is what he
said this week i want to show it
now i've heard the impact of these
releases on our
foreign policy described as as a
meltdown as
as a game changer and so on i think i
think those descriptions are
fairly significantly overwrought
the fact is governments deal with the
united states because it's in their
interest
not because they like us not because
they trust us and not because they
believe we can keep secrets
do you disagree with that in terms of
what the damage done here is i think
there there is damage it may be a little
bit more profound than the secretary i
don't think it's goes to the extent that
some people have been saying but yes
there is real damage
social security numbers of individuals
have been
made public
technology about roadside bombs has been
made public the relationship of a
president let's say of yemen
who was involved with us in helping to
fight domestic terror
in yemen
has been exposed for parts of his
relationship with the united states it
could be very damaging to our efforts
there there are many similar kinds of
efforts in germany some people are
calling for the return of the ambassador
in other places they won't talk to some
of our people for a while this hurts
senator john kerry speaking yesterday on
meet the press mr abrams as you hear him
and reflect on his comments also those
of defense secretary robert gates
what in that says to you this could be a
prosecutable this this could be a breach
and
how much credence do you give to
the effect that the document drop has
had
oh let me say first uh
i think they're both right i think
there's been a vast
overstatement of the degree of harm
uh to that extent i agree with secretary
gates
but i think senator kerry is correct uh
there are a number of specific
inclusions
in the material made public which i
think do harm and have done harm and are
likely to do more harm
and i think that as the department of
justice
sits back
and considers
whether to start a prosecution
one thing that they they will
necessarily
consider in exercising their discretion
is just how much harm has actually been
done
you know it's been suggested
that the first witness for the defense
in any case would be secretary gates
uh that is to say that that mr assange
would would try to get what secretary
gates
said
just the material that you just showed
shown or secretary gates to say it again
as a way of ameliorating
any concerns on the part of a jury or a
judge or to try to get the case
dismissed
but as i say i i think that
the level of harm
and and we on the outside can't really
know it but the the genuine the true
level of harm is one factor which the
department of justice is likely to and
should
take into account in deciding whether to
proceed i should add another one
is whether we can
succeed in a prosecution i mean the last
thing we want i think
is to go and indict mr assange
and have some european country refuse to
extradite him to the united states
tracy joins us republican in annapolis
maryland good morning
hi hi floyd
i had a couple of quick comments and a
question first comment was i wonder what
mr assange's reaction would be
to having his criminal file released
throughout the globe he has accused two
rapes in a country that is using
interpol they consider it serious enough
to go after him i wonder if he considers
that that information should be public
information
you know you mentioned assange wrote a
letter to department of defense giving
them the opportunity to scrub the
documents
let's take that a little bit further
assange clearly feels that he's in a
position and has the authority to
release things that others feel should
not be released
that means if there was a discussion
between assange and department of
defense the department's defense might
say on a particular item this can't be
released and he would say you have to
convince me
and i will decide
if you have convinced me so assange a
non-citizen
puts himself at the level of judgment
exercised only by the president of the
united states
well i i think you make uh
two interesting points
uh first and it hasn't been talked uh
enough about
there are significant privacy issues
here
with respect to what has been released
here and elsewhere by mr assange senator
kerry referred to social security
numbers for example
being released
in other circumstances wikileaks has
provided the banking information
uh
and the identity of members of uh
far right-wing political organizations
uh uh i mean there there are serious
privacy issues
with the wholesale revelation of certain
types of information
which uh wikileaks
in my view has simply taken no account
of at all and and putting aside the
question of whether there should be a
criminal prosecution uh that is
certainly one of the reasons that that
that i believe
uh that mr assange has behaved in a
generally reckless uh manner
you know be beyond that uh you know i
think you make a good point
that uh
there are areas here uh uh which which
in which material you know has been
released which uh he would not want
released uh about himself
uh and uh i i
that
there's irony in that but but there's
also
uh reason in that uh you know to sort of
uh at least throw up our hands
uh and uh and and say that there's a
very significant inconsistency uh in
what he does and as you point out what
he surely would like or not like you
mentioned that finding him extraditing
him is a huge challenge the new york
times reports that he has not been seen
since being in geneva on november 5th
he's believed to be staying somewhere in
southeastern england but what is
america's ability to extradite him and
are other countries interested perhaps
in filing charges or prosecuting him for
the wikileaks
issues specifically
i i don't think we'll find other
countries uh uh
seeking to
find him
i'm less concerned about the finding him
issue we've indicted a lot of people
through the years
who we then had to try to find
and
we sometimes have
found them later on general muriega
sometimes we've not been able to find
them robert vesco for example
in cuba
i i think as a diplomatic matter and as
a general matter of american national
interest
if the conclusion
of the department of justice
is that
even if he is apprehended in say
switzerland or sweden
that they would not extradite him
because they would consider this quote
political unquote
rather than pure
law enforcement
and european countries do not extradite
people for political crimes
i don't have a view i don't know uh what
the answer to that is but if i were in
the department of justice and if i
thought that there was a very good
chance that even if he were apprehended
abroad
that
what we would litigate
uh uh over there and a very good chance
that we would lose if that is the case
i would weigh that very heavily uh i
mean i i don't think
we want to be on the losing side of this
case
if we bring it
boca raton florida john democratic
caller welcome
morning c-span good morning
good morning
to most of what you've been saying and
pretty much in agreement but i think
perhaps you got off a little bit on the
wrong tack initially
when you were trying to describe the
differences between wikileaks and the
pentagon papers
i mean uh i think that's really not
germain it's a little bit like trying to
to discern whether it's different to rob
a bank in virginia than it is in new
york
uh but i'd like since you described here
as a first amendment attorney
i'd like to ask you if
on a different tack if you if you feel
that
corporations should be defined as people
and what do you think the impact of the
citizens united decision is going to be
down the road thank you
well i should say first by way of
candor i was involved in that case
i was one of the lawyers that argued to
the supreme court
that
the mccain feingold law was
unconstitutional i thought and think
that that significant parts of that law
in limiting speech of corporations and
unions was unconstitutional
now in terms of what the impact of the
decision will be
it did not have much of an impact in the
last election
the democrat democrats and their
supporters and republicans and their
supporters each spent about the same
amount of money in all the congressional
races and all the gubernatorial races
sort of added up uh together
and in fact in the 63
races where the democrats lost in the
house the reason for the republicans
taking over the house democrats outspent
the republicans in two-thirds of them
so so far
it has not had
much of an impact
we'll just have to wait and see if it
does
if it's a bad impact
there still remains the possibility
that congress may pass legislation
requiring more in the way of disclosure
by corporations
and unions
if they do or when they do
spend money on elections and and i think
more disclosure
is not only allowed by the citizens
united ruling but i think it's a good
idea and to our florida caller this
wikileaks leak is considered to be the
biggest of its size since the pentagon
papers release back during the nixon
administration and our guest floyd
abrams
defended the new york times in that case
so that's the point of reference i
wanted to mention one one item on
twitter dennis writes that our
government has ordered all federal
employees not to look at what is in the
public and by proxy all americans he
says
wake up and the story from the new york
times yesterday says don't look don't
read government tells workers to avert
eyes from the leaks and it talks about
how the defense department is reminding
federal employees and contractors not to
read the secret cables because even
though they have been made public they
are classified documents let's go to
thomas in st petersburg florida
independent line good morning
good morning and i was concerned or
would like to hear more about
whistleblowers themselves
how they have become criminalized in the
criminalization of the truth it really
seems and the slandering of people who
come out with
truth in the whistleblowers
excuse me
and the
fact that mr assange himself has been
had the charges of rape dropped and then
picked up again or molestation
and if you go on the web you can find
out the charges themselves have to deal
with
consensual sex but he didn't use a
condom and then refused
to i guess or is having
uh not going back to getting an std test
for these uh two ladies
but the fact that whistleblowers
themselves
they have a
a court system where they can have
their
rights protected but it seems like the
courts themselves are really geared
against them
i i really have no uh uh knowledge of uh
mr assange's uh sexual
behavior or misbehavior
um
nor about uh
whether he's being
mistreated uh by the judicial system uh
in in sweden
i would say though
that
there is a need to protect
whistleblowers
and there is also a role
in a free society
for criticizing even whistleblowers even
people who think they're whistleblowers
if we think that they've behaved in
a way which is contrary to the interests
of society so when i for example use the
word reckless about him
i mean it i think he deserves it
that that might even be a soft word to
use
that doesn't mean
that i don't think that some of the
material released
is a newsworthy or even b
important uh but i do think that he's
behaved
in a way which warrants criticism
david california republican welcome
david
oh thank you for putting on a good show
here
i have two
quick points the first one is
i'm outraged at the difference between
the u.s government prosecuting the
messenger
versus prosecuting the murder
that was
revealed by wikileaks the helicopter
murders of the civilians
by the u.s military
and the two reuters newspaper people
the u.s government is
aggressively going after assange but
they are ignoring the murder that took
place from
the military and the second one is i
disagree with mr abrams
that he just wants to make this a little
bit
uh
change law just a little bit i think the
laws are backwards the burden should be
on those who are making things
classified the burden should not be on
the public
to
correct things that have been improperly
classified i don't think the public
should bear the burden
of
trying to figure out what is
properly in the public domain i have to
second that earlier phrase that caller
said
that we are criminalizing the truth
um
let me respond to your second point um
under president clinton the
classification rules were changed
so that there was a presumption
against classification that was repealed
under president bush
i think it would be important to sort of
to reinstate
the clinton standards i i agree with
your
second point that that it is important
to
put the burden on the classifiers to
justify
the classification decisions
and i think that we we should move
in that direction
as much as possible floyd abrams quick
response to this question from twitter
if the documents are classified why not
prosecute the new york times for
printing them
well
first there are all the problems i've
identified in terms of the current law
but but i want to take the question the
way i'm sure it was meant
putting aside the language of the law
why shouldn't we be able to prosecute
the new york times and the real answer
is
that
it is very important one of the prime
prime protections the first amendment
affords us
is to allow individuals who
learn information
such as the new york times has learned
to comment on it
to discuss it uh and as a general matter
uh to reveal it
uh
the pentagon papers case was one example
but but here uh the the new york times
day after day
has been commenting on material
made public by others
by mr assange
uh it's not the times that is
making it public the information is now
out there
and i do think that once the information
is out and available
that it is useful it is significant
and it is important to discuss it uh and
to protect the process
uh and the and the entities that are
engaged in that discussion finally
as i said before
too much is classified we if we start
prosecuting entities simply because
materials classified
i remember in the nixon administration
the white house menu was classified
uh it i mean we live in a world in which
individuals with the power to classify
routinely over classify
and and that that makes it all the more
dangerous to use the fact of
classification the fact that someone in
the executive branch has said this ought
to be classified as a basis for
prosecution
floyd abrams first amendment lawyer with
cahill gordon and reindell joining us
this morning from new york city thank
you so much
thank you
coming up next we'll talk about offshore
drilling in the recent obama department
obama administration decision to ban
offshore drilling in some locations in
the united states we'll be joined by
eric molito with the american petroleum
institute but first a news update from
c-span radio
it's 9 22 a.m eastern time a white house
official says the president will
reiterate today that if tax cuts for the
highest earners are going to be extended
he wants to see unemployment benefits
extended as well his speech at noon
today in north carolina comes as
negotiators continue work on an
extension of the bush era tax cuts for
all income brackets
more on the situation in north korea
secretary of state clinton welcomes the
foreign ministers of japan and south
korea to the state department today to
talk about last month's artillery attack
and north korea's recent disclosure of a
uranium enrichment facility the three
countries have so far declined china's
invitation to a wider meeting that would
also include china russia and north
korea they say that to sit down with
pyongyang at this point would reward it
for bad behavior you can hear secretary
clinton's remarks later this morning on
c-span radio
and defense secretary robert gates is
visiting the uss abraham lincoln which
is deployed off the coast of oman he
watched two f a 18 hornets head out to
support battlefield operations in
afghanistan an increase in air missions
is coinciding with the troop surge of
about 30 000 troops ordered by the
president reports say that aircraft
dropped one thousand bombs and missiles
in october one of the highest monthly
totals in the war
those are some of the latest headlines
on c-span radio
washington journal continues
frederick hits is the senior fellow at
the university of virginia's center for
national security law joining us from
there this morning to talk about the
legal issues surrounding this wikileaks
case and mr hitz let's begin with the
espionage act of 1917. can
the wikileaks
leader mr assange be prosecuted under
that law
i've seen a lot of commentary i've taken
another look at the statute myself
i'm not sure you probably remember that
that uh law was passed
at the height of america's preparation
to go into world war one and was really
directed along with a sedition act that
went with it to
make sure that people were not
speaking violently against the action of
the government and joining the allies
against
the central front but
it hasn't really been used very much and
the most recent case of any significance
was the new york times
pentagon papers case
in which the supreme court chose not to
limit publication
or enjoined publication of the papers in
the new york times because
it didn't believe that the
elements of the espionage act were met
i therefore think applying it to a
broadcasting entity like the wikileaks
assange
operation
will have some difficulty
now there's some other theories that
have been propounded for example
knowing
knowingly publishing documents that were
classified knowingly publishing
documents that in effect were stolen
might give rise to
a prosecution
one of the first things of course the
united states has to do
is gain jurisdiction over assange
himself he's
as we now know
uh in custody in britain
uh
awaiting the results of the british
determination
on the swedish request for
extradition
let's assume he's extradited to sweden
they do what they
uh do with him
would they then turn him over to the
united states for possible prosecution
in our country
i'm not sure that that's at all settled
and so there are a number of issues to
be sorted out
there has been as you know a lot of
discussion
in washington and elsewhere that if the
espionage act
doesn't reach mr assange
perhaps we ought to try
to pass a law that would make this kind
of
activity unlawful
and you have one potential
precedent for that
about 20 years ago when counter spy and
one or two other outlets
were publishing the names of american
intelligence agents serving abroad
with the intention of
doing harm to them either having them
removed from the countries where they
were serving
or
otherwise it led eventually to the
assassination of a chief of station
richard welch
in greece
and we passed the law that made it
unlawful to intentionally
out
cia officers serving overseas with the
intention of doing them harm so
there are a lot of
theories i suppose
that could be worked through to try to
find a law that might meet what mr
assange has done there are three
senators that are introducing a bill
thursday last thursday aimed at stopping
this wikileaks by making illegal to
publish the names of military or
intelligence community informants how
would this
would this add to the laws that are
already on the books and could it be
retroactive
well that you see that looks like i
hadn't seen that but i knew that they
there were several that were
intending to uh some several members of
congress that were intending to
introduce bills
that seems to go down the theory that i
just explained the agent
uh intelligence agency agents protection
act that was identities protection act
excuse me that was passed 20 years ago
trying to make it unlawful to reveal the
names of serving military
officials
overseas but there
that earlier statute was interpreted
very narrowly you had to find the intent
usually a pattern of or practice that is
publishing them in a magazine like
counter spy on a continual basis
in this case in the wikileaks documents
on a continuing basis
might meet that
intention but
assange might say that his intention is
doing this is to let the uh light of the
sun in to let the air in in these
matters he didn't it doesn't intend to
harm them so
uh i think action
sounds like it is being prepared the
question is will it pass constitutional
muster in our country well i want to
read a little bit from the espionage act
of 1917. it says whoever having
unauthorized possession of access to or
control over any document relating to
the national defense or information
relating to the national defense which
information the possessor has reason to
believe could be used to injure the
united states or to the advantage of any
foreign nation willfully communicates
delivers transmits or causes to be
communicated delivered or transmitted or
attempts to communicate
to same to any person not entitled to
receive it or willfully retains the same
and fails to deliver it to the officer
or employee of the united states
entitled to receive it so someone said
it's written too broadly but it it it
seems to fit under these circumstances
it does but it it
applies most particularly to the private
who uh took these documents downloaded
these documents and provided them to
wikileaks
it doesn't necessarily apply to the
entity that publishes them
uh
for all the world to see
that's that's been the distinction
there's been this
first amendment concern that the
pentagon papers
seem to enshrine that
the guilty party is the person if there
is a guilty party is the person who
uh illegally uh uh
grabs the documents and makes them
available not the entity that publishes
them all right our guests they'll have
to make that clear
they'll have to make that clear if
they're going to go down that road our
our guest is frederick hits he is a
senior fellow at the university of
virginia center for national security
law
background on him he was the first
statuary cia inspector general under
president george h.w bush and served in
the capacity until retirement in 98 and
was among the many investigations
that he led at the cia was the aldrich
ames espionage case fort mccoy florida
donald democratic line your first phone
call go ahead yes i'd i'd like to make a
case for the government's uh
responsibility in this
and it's uh i'm a retired i.t manager
and i'd like to make two comments and
then a question
the
two comments of background
the
in the early days of data processing or
i t technology whatever you want to call
it
the poorest paying jobs for programmers
and like database designers and so forth
we're with the government or with
insurance companies or banks
and
the
the good programmers and so forth were
always
more apt to go with a top quality agency
now if you remember ross perot's bid for
the presidency his millions of dollars
were generated by
making a deal with the government that
his data processing enterprise
could do the job for half the money that
the government was spending
and uh that's where he made his money by
taking a contract from the government to
take over certain uh
you know data processing jobs all right
donald so what's your point
my point is
that the government
uh in this case designed a database with
all this information in it with no
security
and uh that a pfc could could get at
this information at all ridiculous all
right let's leave it there frederick
hits
well i'm glad that questioner uh
was able to pose his his concerns
because that's my primary concern
in this whole matter and i go at it from
a totally different viewpoint
we have made enormous strides
in the government between the fbi
between the cia and the entire
intelligence agencies
in sharing information
in the wake of the tragedy of 9 11.
remember the 9 11 commission report that
pointed out that had there been
better exchange of information had the
dots been connected we might have
we might have been able to
unfurl that plot before it occurred
since that time
and since the passage of the
intelligence reform and anti-terrorism
act of
2004 all efforts have been made to break
down the silos break down the the
barriers between sharing of information
especially in the law enforcement and
intelligence community so
we would have
a horizontal coverage what we had you'll
remember
in 911 was a plot that was hatched in
the in a mosque in hamburg
worked on in spain and then transported
to the united states for execution
you had the international world mixed in
with the domestic world
in our country we had at least two
agencies that were responsible for
the domestic side and most
particularly the domestic side and one
for the international side the twain did
not mix
and what's happened here we finally got
information sharing and wikileaks has
taken advantage of it so you've got uh
cables that originated in the department
of state available to a pfc as your
caller said so he could dump him into
the wikileaks hoop i'm afraid this is
going to set back
information sharing a great deal and
that concerns me all right george is a
republican in san antonio texas you're
next
yes ma'am i have concern with the
wikileaks i believe that wikileaks is a
matter of constitutional right
and gives the person its power to
publish whatever is truly affecting the
american people
and what i mean by that if you remember
several years ago with the tragic uh
instances where they were using air
force men to uh
to inject uh syphilis and that was well
published and nobody uh paid the
consequences for that
but i think that that's a constitutional
right
and that people are free to do that
under the constitution and if it's
affecting america then they should be
able to post that information and have
answered frederick hits
i don't think so i i can understand the
caller's concerns
but
that constitutional right insofar as it
exists
is changed when a person goes to work
for the government like this private
he swears an oath to honor the uh
responsibilities associated with
handling classified information
in fact he contracts with the government
that he will preserve the secrecy
handle the materials in a sensitive way
and he's contractually bound by that
just as every retired intelligence
officer has to if he wants to write a
book as i did has to take it back to the
agency for them to look it over and make
sure there's not classified information
being conveyed
so when you take one of these sensitive
jobs you have to recognize
that your free speech rights if that's
what you want to call them
are curtailed when you're dealing with
classified information next phone call
tammy independent in mopen oregon you're
on the air
hi yes um
i actually am in agreement with the
caller previous to the last one
i do believe that
providing information to the public is
good
we need to be seeing what's going on in
our name in all countries
and it just seems to me
that uh criminalizing whistleblowers
just gives
continues to give these powerful
companies complete control of what we
need to know apparently we're just on a
need to know basis
mr hitz
well uh i can understand that point of
view in a in a uh in an abstract sense
but surely you don't mean that we can't
have confidential
exchanges of information between our
diplomats abroad and the
foreign
individuals officers that they're
dealing with surely there has to be a
way
that the government can
maintain the privacy of these
conversations and the confidentiality of
the information that comes from them
this isn't one of those situations where
we're protecting wrongdoing
what we're protecting is the
confidentiality of exchanges between our
diplomats and our military and our other
personnel serving overseas when they're
working on behalf of the united states
mr hitz i want to show you and our
viewers
the press conference that attorney
general mike
holder held on monday addressing eric
holder excuse me
addressing the wikileaks issue here's
what he had to say
national security of the united states
has been put at risk the lives of
people who work for the american people
has been put at risk
the american people themselves have been
put at risk
by these actions that are i believe
arrogant misguided and ultimately
not helpful in in any way we are doing
everything that we can we have a very
serious active ongoing investigation um
that is criminal in nature i authorized
just last week
a number of things to be done so that we
can hopefully get to the bottom of this
and hold people accountable as they as
they should be
mr hitz the language that the attorney
general is using there legally what is
he saying
well he's saying they're they're
scrambling around trying to find a way
to apply a statute currently on the
books
that might
allow them to
prohibit assange from continuing to
publish this information that's the hard
part how do you deal with it
as i say one theory might be it's
classified information that was stolen
uh from the the the originators of it
and nobody has the right to reproduce it
it's protected uh information
uh they might try the 1917 espionage act
root but i think as i say after pentagon
papers
that'll be tough but they're clearly
either going to find something that's
currently on the books to try to stop it
or go along with the congress and and
and try to pass a law i think the
important thing to
focus on is though what the attorney
general said
it can't be the right of just
john's q citizen to disregard the
protections given to this information
and turn it over to wikileaks even if he
or she is in objection to the policy
being discussed when there are lives on
the line when there are confidential
sources that have supplied that
information when the government has
tried to
maintain
uh its its
confidentiality of communications on
these sensitive subjects for one person
to sort of arrogate to themselves
the authority to do this would break
down our whole system of communication
uh
in sensitive matters like this
and you know we couldn't we couldn't do
our job united states couldn't be uh
wouldn't be able to operate overseas in
sensitive areas
melba is a republican joining us from
california good morning good morning
you're on the air go ahead with your
question or comment that's right i just
wanted to say whatever happened to the
freedom of speech that's all that's my
comment very brief and very short i'd
like to hear about the freedom of speech
thank you
mr hitz
i i i think freedom of state speech in
the united states thank goodness is
alive and well but freedom of steep
speech doesn't really apply to a
situation uh such as this when you have
confidential documents
sent back to washington dc for the
secretary of state and the national
security adviser to understand what the
mechanics of the negotiations are
between
an important foreign power
and ourselves
there's no freedom of speech in the
context of of uh sort of revealing a
private and classified conversation a
conversation which if revealed has the
potential to do harm to the national
security that's taking freedom of speech
uh too far and into a new area you
touched on this a little bit mr hitz
about prosecuting
the wikileaks founder on the issue of
stolen documents and the secretary of
state
hillary clinton after a press conference
told reporters that she said i won't
comment on any specific alleged cable
but i will underscore
that this theft of u.s government
information and its publication without
regard to the consequences is deeply
distressing she uses the word theft what
does that mean
well i think the i don't think there's
much question in anybody's mind that the
private who uh uh downloaded these
documents and delivered them to mr
assange is going to be tried uh
court-martialed and likely to have if
he's done it likely to have a long
prison sentence so the actual theft
of was was let's say
can't pre-judge him but let's say uh
attributable to him the question is what
did he do with the you know with his
ill-gotten gains in this case he took to
them to assange with the knowledge that
they would be published and the question
then becomes what is the obligation
of assange or wikileaks to honor the
classification stamp and to take note of
the fact that these documents were
stolen
and just as in your private capacity if
you
if you took possession of a car that you
knew to be stolen and drove it away
uh you would be subject to prosecution
that i think may be the theory that
they're going to work on and may have
the most success with
he was knowledgeable that these were
ill-gotten documents and and that part
could be
in your opinion easy to prove
well i think it can be in the sense that
uh there doesn't seem to be much dispute
that he obtained these documents from
the private and he was
not entitled to to spread them in this
way and all the documents that we've
seen in the newspapers contain the
classification stamp there isn't much
doubt but what it was confidential
information or secret information all
right let's try to get in one last phone
call here vero beach florida ow
democratic line go ahead
al you with us
alan vero beach florida one last call
for out lost him sorry about that so uh
frederick hits real quickly before we
say goodbye to you what happens next
here
well as i say i think you've got just
what you pointed to several members of
congress
looking for ways to fashion
legislation that might reach this if we
can't get
get at the problem
with the laws that are currently on the
books but i don't think it's going to go
away because as you know
we have seen maybe the most salacious
the most sensational
of some of the documents that have been
turned over to assange but we're given
to understand that wikileaks if it stays
in operation is going to publish more so
the problem's not going to go away all
right frederick hits with the university
of virginia's center for national
security law thank you for joining us
this morning
it's been my pleasure
that does it for today's washington
journal we'll be back tomorrow morning 7
a.m eastern time with more of your
comments more of your phone calls your
tweets and your emails as well the house
is about to come into session here this
morning and they will continue their
work on the continuing resolution
providing temporary funding for the
government through next september 30th
the british house of commons is in
recess so prime minister's questions
will not be seen tonight
instead from london a debate on whether
whistleblowers make the world a safer
place
among the participants is wikileaks
publisher julian assange the debate was
hosted by the new statesman and the
frontline club this is 90 minutes
good afternoon everyone hear me there at
the back just making sure that
i'm audible um it's good to see so many
of you here as fawn said i'm jason kelly
editor of the new statesman
when we announced that we were having
this debate
we we've put we've put it up on our
website and i think within a matter of
hours we've sold all of our tickets
seven 800 tickets within a matter of
hours 100 tickets within a matter of
hours
we thought about switching venue we had
a long waiting list of people wanting to
come here this evening in the end we
stayed where we are here at kensington
town hall and i think it's a fine venue
the motion before the house this evening
is this house believes whistleblowers
make the world a safer
the subject of the debate is to coincide
with a special issue of the new
statesman
on freedom of information which is guest
edited by the human rights activist and
journalist jemima khan
and i'm pleased to say she's here this
evening with us and this has been
something of a media sensation so
congratulations to my mom on a fantastic
issue of a new statement
i know you don't want to hear me speak
so i'm going to introduce the speakers
very soon but a few brief words about
the format each speaker will have no
more than seven minutes to make his case
i shall encourage interject interactions
between the speakers interjections in
the form of points of information in the
style of a classic oxford union debate
so without further ado may i introduce
the team which will be proposing the
motion
could you step forward clayton swisher
julian the songs
i gather you some of you must recognize
that gentleman
madi hassan
opposing the motion we have sir david
richards
we have bob ayers
and we have douglas murray
i
no heckling yet please i'll say a few
brief words about each of our speakers
clayton swisher has a wonderful tire
choice it's your head of al jazeera's
transparency unit he's the man who
brought you the palestine papers which
were media sensation in january 2011.
our second speaker proposing the motion
really needs no introduction but i shall
try all the same
um julian assange was born in queensland
australia he's editor-in-chief
of wikileaks organization that i in my
opinion has changed the direction of
world history
julian has probably facilitated more
acts of whistleblowing than any other
individual
leading american politicians
have called for his assassination
and his continuing subject of ongoing
espionage investigation
in this week's issue of the new
statesman
julian has written an article in which
he describes i think in a resonant
phrase
called wikileaks the intelligence agency
of the people i think that's a rather
nice phrase
the final speaker proposing the motion
is mehdi hassan who works for the new
statesman he's a senior editor politics
he writes about politics economics world
affairs and when he's not writing he
tends to be speaking
and you may have seen him on newsnite
and other political programs before
joining the new statesman he worked for
channel 4 and he worked for sky news i
understand you're writing a biography of
the labour leader ed miliband and i i
presume um all the best bits will be
leaked long before publication
opposing the motion we have sir david
richards
a very distinguished
diplomat
30-year service postings to baghdad
new york where you worked on the u.n
security council brussels
in 2003 david returned
to baghdad and later became the uk
special representative to iraq
your final posting was head and i have
your title here
head of defense and intelligence at the
fo
bob has had a long and distinguished
career inside us government he was
director of defensive information
warfare within the ministry of the
department of defense
from 1990 to 92 and it says here he was
responsible for the security of more
than 40 000 classified intelligence
processing systems at 55 locations
across the world you sure it was only 55
locations
douglas murray is an author and
journalist
and has recently moved to become
assistant director of the henry jackson
society
he's also a ubiquitous media commentator
and i think you were due to be in new
york this evening is that right so i'm
very grateful you rearranged your flight
to be with us here this evening
without further ado clayton can i ask
you to come forward and speak
thanks very much
[Applause]
actually one thing i think it might be
quite exciting to do before you speak is
who have you here have a view about the
motion so the motion is this house
believes whistleblowers make the world a
safer place
so
informal voting but a show of hands
those of you who would support that
motion
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place who would oppose
that mate relief
only a few of you oppose it so you've
got a lot of work to do to make people
change their minds
and which of you have no view at all
wish to abstain for now
it's interesting so it's as many as
those who are opposing
so um clayton over to you thank you mr
speaker my fellow panelists ladies and
gentlemen it's a pleasure to be here in
london good afternoon
i've been asked to participate because
like my colleagues i do believe in many
of you and the value of whistleblowers
i am speaking on behalf of al jazeera's
transparency unit and for anything that
i say that's wrong i'm speaking for
myself
i do believe that whistleblowing is a
vital effort in this day and age now
more than ever
we live in a time of unprecedented
government secrecy
and unprecedented wrongdoing
added to that we also have
a phenomena of
an untoward
collusion
between the mainstream media
organizations and government
that have surrendered a lot of the
journalistic principles of keeping
governments in check
and holding them to account
whether it be because of political
leanings or they want to get invited to
the next christmas party i don't know
why but many of you see this in the
reporting
on television and in newspapers and it's
a distressing trend
in this era
of journalism
at the very issue of whether or not to
support whistleblowers is the value in
the principle of anonymous speech
now as i said i'm representing al
jazeera but i'm also an american
and this is something in my country
which we have a very rich tradition in
anonymous speech which we took from our
british
forefathers
it was used at the turn of uh at the
beginning of our country in discussion
over the federalist papers over what
form of constitution the u.s government
would have people posted anonymously
long lengthy critiques of what a future
american government
should have and they did so because they
didn't want retaliation they didn't want
people to
hurt them for having a public discourse
and time and again the us supreme court
in the united states has upheld the
value of anonymous speech
recognizing that it releases inhibitions
it helps break taboos
and in fact what's what's very
amusing about the whole criticism of
using anonymous speech these days is the
fact that governments have nearly
perfected
anonymous speech
let me give you a clear example
oftentimes
foreign governments
the united states government uses the
media to help make policies
go over well with the public they
message through anonymous sourcing they
go to journalists and how many times did
you see in the run-up to the iraq war
this senior administration official
saying about wmd or this senior
intelligence official
speaking to this organization on
saddam's intentions
so when it serves their interests they
have no problem picking up a phone
calling us journalists and it happens
all the time
and making their making their passing
along their information why because the
powerful can they make the rules right
well it's the same thing
when it's turned on its head now they
attack
the leaks and disclosures and the
anonymous sourcing and it's wrong
this is the future of journalism when we
have as i said in the beginning the
unprecedented wrongdoing and the
collusion of so many journalist
organizations with these governments
people are finding ways in the digital
age of taking massive amounts of
information and putting it out on the
internet
now at al jazeera we recognized that
trend and we set up
in recent months the transparency unit
because we wanted to have a way to
receive these tips
and have a channel securely that people
could come to us and pass information
along if we were not able to obtain that
information through traditional
investigative journalism
now we're not a town prior organization
we don't publish immediate we take in
information we vet it we authenticate it
we stand it up we give it context we
give it nuance and a tv our challenge is
to turn documents
into television that informs the public
and helps make better choices to our
viewers we did that with the palestine
papers back in january some of you may
have seen it we partnered with the
guardian this was our first disclosure
if you will
it was 1700 documents of secret
negotiations between israelis
palestinians and americans
and it showed the inner workings of a
process gone awry since two thousand two
thousand and ten we took a lot of heat
for doing it but we stuck to our guns
and already in the business we faced our
first challenge which is what to
withhold
what don't you put out there
were under tremendous pressure from the
british government in fact we fielded
calls from mi6 to withhold publication
of the name of an alleged mi6 officer
who proposed a secret rendition program
to take mid-level hamas operatives and
to
intern them with eu funding now this is
a plan that's illegal under
international law
we had a rigorous discussion inside
about whether or not we disclosed the
individual's name he was listed as a
british consul in jerusalem at the time
and we had multiple sources saying he
was in fact mi6 and at the end of the
day we said
if this was a libyan intelligence
officer would we withhold his name no if
he was venezuelan would we withhold his
name no
when you get rid of the my country tis
of thee
objection that journalists often want to
have
it's a it's a liberating feeling
we put the name out there and guess what
the world kept turning
no one got hurt
the end was not nigh
but what we did in all of our
disclosures where we gave context and
information because if you just put
documents out there and you they don't
have any
any background to them
people don't really benefit it's no use
in putting a deluge of data if you don't
tell people why it matters to them and
why they should know about it and in
fact they probably won't look at it
now the critics of my colleague julian's
organization wikileaks
many of them are journalists
and i've thought about what they've said
about him in particular and about
wikileaks and the impact it's had on in
our profession
and i come away with with two
two thoughts i'd share with you
one is sort of a more basic
human
critique which is
they're hating on him because he got a
scoop they didn't
okay if he was an american or if he was
from an establishment organization
they'd be talking about what awards are
going to give him and the editors would
be having all sorts of discussions on
the appropriateness of what they put out
there
and the second point
is that a lot of the organizations to
get back to my earlier statement they
don't have the editorial cojones to
publish
okay this is
evidence let me take you back to 2004
when the new york times final 30 seconds
new york times came up with uh the
they found new information that the bush
administration was surreptitiously
eavesdropping on u.s citizens the bush
administration weighed in on new york
times got them to delay publication
until 2005 after bush was safely
reelected they also withheld
the washington post journalist david
finkel also withheld the apache
helicopter footage that wikileaks put
out there why did he withhold this in my
country tis of the
rationale
the people will know what not to put out
there we see this in egypt when they go
into the ministry of interior and they
see
sex tapes the people didn't put it out
there because it violated privacy
the masses know what's appropriate and
what's not to put out there and so do us
journalists and we should be entrusted
with that thank you clayton thank you
very much
[Applause]
speaking against the motion
today
[Applause]
thank you very much mr chairman ladies
and gentlemen i think even even before
the vote uh the preliminary vote i
realized that uh those of us who've been
asked to oppose the motion uh had got
our work cut out
especially in this forum but anyway we
will do our best
but the risk of making our position
worse at the outset
uh i concede that in certain
circumstances there is a valid case for
whistleblowing
when other remedies have failed and
there is evidence of illegality or
deceit or abuse of power blowing the
whistle can be justified
but not everyone who leaks
a confidential document or even 250 000
of them
is entitled to call themselves a
whistleblower
many leak not to expose wrongdoing
but for political advantage or because
they disagree with a particular policy
or because they take the view that
governments should not be in the
business of keeping information secret
i see this is a problem for wikileaks
where genuine examples of whistleblowing
are buried in an avalanche of
confidential material which shows no
abuse at all
i also agree that to hold government to
account the public needs to be properly
informed
most democracies have accepted the need
for greater transparency and taken steps
to give the public access to more
information in the uk the passing of the
freedom of information act
with rather more government sucking of
teeth the growth of judicial review has
also played a huge part in opening up
the workings of british government
including including the most secret
but what i want to argue here is that
there are good reasons why governments
wish
and indeed our duty bound to maintain
confidentiality in some areas of their
work
freedom of information is not the same
as an information free for all
and the right to know does not
necessarily mean a right to know
everything
all of the time
here it's worth recalling the exemptions
built into the freedom of information
act
these include national security
defense
international relations and the
formulation of government policy
these categories may be broad
and no doubt too much information is
classified
but it is not too difficult to see why
our security and defense will often
depend on secrecy
whenever we get on an airplane we're
generally reassured if mildly irritated
by all this by all the searching and
baggage checking
but just as important to our safety is
the work done by the security and
intelligence agencies
since 9 11 there's been only one
terrorist attack in britain leading to
major loss of life
but those agencies have prevented a
number of other attacks which
in one case at least would have led to
many more casualties than occurred in
london on 7-7
the work of these agencies has to be
secret they cannot operate if their
sources and methods are exposed to
public view
one of the goals of diplomacy is to make
the world a safer place
but to be effective diplomacy too
sometimes requires confidentiality
the leak of state department cables
you said diplomacy requires secrecy as
well and you worked at the un you
mentioned wikileaks do you think the
people in this room have the right to
know that u.n diplomats were being
bugged by americans and that hillary
clinton said get every information you
can including their air miles
information do you think that was right
and we should have a right to know that
[Music]
there's quite a lot i could say about
that not that but i'll make one very
short point here i mean i thought
frankly that was a little bit absurd
having worked at the un i know that if
i'd like if i want information from a un
employee i go along and ask for it and
that un employee normally gives me that
information plus a cup of tea and a
biscuit so i think they they made fools
of themselves over that i will entirely
agree
um but i think i mean you've picked out
probably the only exception
[Applause]
the leak of the state department cables
has not shown the us government up to
its neck in conspiracies and cover-ups
what has been revealed by and large is
the normal traffic of diplomacy
information that governments wish to
keep confidential for the sake of their
working relationships with other
governments
negotiating with other governments
finding the compromises which the
lifeblood of international relations
will always be more difficult
if the bargaining process becomes public
at the u n security council resolutions
are voted in public their texts are
public explanations of vote are public
but the negotiation itself takes place
behind closed doors because fewer
resolutions would see the light of day
if that were not the case
getting diplomatic context to speak
frankly
or advisors to give candid advice in the
domestic arena depends on trust
when the lead russian and american
negotiators on the strategic arms
reduction treaty wanted to find a way
through the difficulties they faced they
went for their famous walk in the woods
they may have needed the fresh air but
they also wanted the chance to talk
frankly and to build trust
trust and frank speaking are impossible
if confidences and confidentiality
cannot be respected
without frank speaking
misunderstandings proliferate and the
quality of information on which
governments must base their decisions
deteriorates
not in my view a recipe for a safer
world
they're clearly two conflicting
principles locking horns here
the public's need to be properly
informed and thus able to hold
governments to account and the
government's need to keep some aspects
of what it does confidential to protect
its citizens
and to function effectively
there is no simple formula to resolve
the conflict
but if the right balance is not being
struck the democratic way to address
this is not by whistleblowing even if in
some exceptional circumstances it may be
justified
still less by wholesale leaking
instead we should improve the democratic
and constitutional processes by which
the executive is held up to scrutiny
parliament the media
the courts the rights enjoyed by
individual citizens operating within a
framework established by law
thank you very much thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you for that
this
talk
is about
not whether
sometimes information should be kept
secret by those
tasks to do so
of course it should the question is
whether
whistleblowers
and their actions make the world a safer
place
or not
or to rephrase the question
would
the absence
of whistleblowers
make the world
a more harmful place
we just heard this last speaker
saying that
when considering balance
between
the desire
of certain groups and individuals for
secrecy
and
laws that coerce
individuals at the point of a gun
to keep things secret
and
the rights
of all of us
to know
what our government is doing
that well this is simply a matter for
the courts this is simply a matter for
the democratic process this is something
to be ironed out
between us and cast into law
but i ask you
how are we going to know
if the secrecy process is working or not
because
when information is concealed we do not
know about it the only way
we can know
whether information is legitimately kept
secret is when it is revealed
all systems of censorship have that
problem encoded within them
and because
of that original sin
of censorship
they all must be held to outside account
the way that has been traditionally done
is by courageous individuals
who are privy to information
that they believe the public
is interested in
squirreling it out
often at very substantial
personal risk
to the public
and the public then
if the media which it really is
if the media is an honest conduit the
public then
decides
whether to support those actions or not
so perhaps
we should talk about some of those
actions
because if we're not talking about what
actually happens in the world
what are we talking about
we are talking about myths that exists
in our own heads and hypotheticals
so i
want to look at some situations in
history
that
have led
to war
and perhaps have stopped war
because
a war between peoples
certainly
does not make the world
a safer place
and the absence of a war
or the prevention of a war must surely
be
the ultimate in making people safer
the vietnam war was
triggered
by the gulf of tonkin incident
a lie
about
a boat off the coast a u.s boat off the
coast of vietnam
which the united states government
claimed had been attacked by the
vietnamese that claim was a lie
and there were people privy to that
claim at the time who knew it was a lie
and have come forth
in the last 10 years
to talk about how it was a lie
but if they had come forth if they had
broken
generals interpretations of what
national security secrets are
as the alleged
whistleblower bradley manning is alleged
to have done
then that war may have never have
happened
similarly
the disaster that has been the iraq war
we all found out about
doctored evidence and dodgy dossiers but
when did we find out we found out after
the war had already started
and the bloodbath that was iraq was in
full flight
why did we find out after was there no
one concerned in the planning who felt
that it was wrong
of course there were
but the fear that these individuals had
the fear of being imprisoned and jailed
for revealing that information to you
kept them secret
until later on in the process much later
on and this year in great britain
we are seeing
somewhat of an inquiry into that process
the chillpot inquiry
but recall
that wikileaks released the cable on the
chilcot inquiry
with the head or chief of defense
of the mod
telling the us ambassador
at the time that the inquiry
was being set up
don't worry
we're going to protect all your
interests here
similarly
there was a time in 2007
when there were serious moves afoot to
get up a war with iran
most of you in this room will probably
remember that feeling and that time
when bush's neocons
were pushing daily through their
mouthpiece in the united states
and in great britain
for that war
people like daniel ellsberg came
forth and said
do not do what i did
daniel ellsberg was the leaker of the
pentagon papers do not do what i did
and wait
four or five years until after the
vietnam war had started
do not wait come forth before this war
starts and stop it
sources did come forth to cy hearth
sources
who saw the planning for that war in the
pentagon
and as a result
there were moves
against it those sources
have not been caught they have not been
exposed
they did their best
they may have changed history
and they went back to their jobs and
continued on
it is that latter model
that we want to promote as much as
possible
whistleblowers
face difficulties
although it is rare that they end up in
prison they certainly
often lose their jobs and their
employment prospects but when they can
speak anonymously
they can change history
and feel proud of themselves
and their act and continue on
in 2008
we got hold of
the iraqi
sorry the us military's
classified rules of engagement for iraq
the rules that the u.s army and its
air support have to use when conducting
battles in iraq
and we worked with the new york times
to get that out
because
one section of it
spoke about how
the us military could cross over into
the border of iran
without senior authorization at the
commander level
when chasing someone in a battle
or a suspected terrorist or a number of
other situations
but most wars have started as a result
of border disputes
of one person crossing over one soldier
crossing over into
another country's territory
and in a way you can see the alleged
fabricated
gulf of tonkin incident
as one of those cases
the iranian foreign ministry held a
press conference
and
said that this was unacceptable
and later on we got hold of another copy
of those rules of engagement
from 2008 some months after that
publication
and the rules had changed
so the u.s soldiers were not permitted
to cross over into iran
i could speak for hours about what has
occurred in cablegate and all the
tremendous revelations that have
happened there
just
yesterday
the editor of the hindu the
most respected paper in
india
bought over 21 front pages from the past
six weeks that were based on
cable gate material
the indian parliament has walked out
four times and there is now a tremendous
anti-corruption movement that has been
building up in that country
something that hasn't happened
since the time of gandhi
coming to the final minute julian
just final minute
so i say to you of course
it is obvious
that whistleblowers make the world a
safer place
and when we try to look at the counter
arguments
we see hot air
it doesn't mean that everything in
government should be exposed what it
does mean is that the system of breaking
alleged laws
is working
and that must
be kept going that way otherwise laws
cannot reflect the reality
that we are in
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much julian um
when i saw the show of hands at the
beginning i uh realized what the
christians felt like in the coliseum
[Laughter]
don't worry there gentle bunch
yes yes uh just a point of clarification
uh the vietnam war was well underway
before the gulf of konkin incident that
was under the administration of lyndon
johnson and the war started under john f
kennedy's administration so your timing
was a little off julian
rather than address
specific
as we all know the french were involved
in that war for many many years the us
was also involved in swirling things in
many
thank you very much
please continue bob
thank you thank you
we were very polite when he spoke and i
expect something courtesy from him
obviously i'm wrong
please allow bobber hearing what i'd
like to talk about is not
the specifics of how many documents were
compromised or who said what to who
what i'd like to look at is
how we
as individuals and as organizations and
as groups of people
deal with issues of secrecy
the secrecy is something that we have
all experienced throughout our history
and there's various forms this takes
we have religious secrets as evidenced
by the gnostics
by some of the mythians
and by the knights templar
we have social secrets such as the
freemasons
and the knights of pythias
we have commercial secrets
trade secrets intellectual property
commercial and confidence material
and we have criminal secrets the mafia
has a secret code
and lastly
we have state secrets
all of these organizations
have a commonality on how they deal with
those secrets
one is the organization professes to
hold knowledge that is known only to
members within the organization
members in that organization are
expected to take an oath or make a
promise to retain the secrecy of that
information
and lastly
the members accept and acknowledge that
they will be punished for the revelation
of that information
this is common across all those groups
it's not anything unique to the state
as
people we've developed a very rich
language and nomenclature that describes
people who reveal secrets
we call them a snitch
a rat
a squealer
a traitor
or a
whistleblower
these are not terms i've invented these
are terms that we have invented as a
society to describe these people who
reveal these secrets
when we try to address the motivation
for revealing secrets we find this very
important
yes as someone who worked in government
also as a federal criminal investigator
just to clarify we also called snitches
people who came to us to rat on their
friends or to provide information to the
government so the pejorative term you're
using we also use to define people who
supplied us with information
[Applause]
the rationale for people who break this
this oath or this promise to retain the
secrecy of documents is as varied as
some of the things we've heard here
already today
people break their oath for greed
money advantage
they break their oath for revenge
they break through based on ideology
fear
or ego
there's a wide range of punishments that
we put in place for people to break
their oath and depending on the
organizational group you're in those
punishments vary if it's a religious
group you're in you can be
excommunicated for violating
your oath of secrecy
for the religious secrets in the
organization to which you belong
socially you can be expelled from the
group
commercially as julian said
you can be
fired
or even worse you can be subjected to a
civil suit
criminals can be put to death
especially if you rat on the mafia
and the state can put you in prison
or in some cases put you to death for
violating your oath to protect
information
people that break that oath we remember
them
and we remember them in a bad light
if you're british and i say the words
burgess
maclean
philby blunt
you know there were spies who gave
british secrets to the russians
if you're an american and i say aldrich
ames and robert hansen
you know those were men who violated
their oath and gave secrets
to the russians
if you're a russian
and i use the name
oleg pinkovsky
you know he's the man that betrayed the
motherland
and gave secrets to the americans
and if i say joe valachi
and you're in the mafia
you know velocity is the man who
testified against your organization and
was later sentenced to death
so today we're discussing the the
legalities and tech technicalities of
whistleblowing at least that's what the
motion is before so i think we've gone
beyond that
what is interesting is this motion
before us it really avoids some of the
basic human characteristics that should
be shaping this discussion
humans appear to share this belief that
people that betray their oath
are something that extends across
cultures it extends across societies
extends across continents
people that break through oath are
someone that we
revile
and we distrust
the question before us
at least the unspoken question before us
is
do individuals or organizations
who encourage us
to break that oath or facilitate our
breaking of that oath or promote us
breaking that oath
are they just as guilty as the person
who breaches the oath himself
thank you
thank you very much
i think actually this evening we have
some actual whistleblowers in the
audience and i'd like them to come
forward to say a few words
annie mashon please come forward and
pull more
and if you said that
poor if you could come to speak at this
annie is a former british security
service i think mi5
intelligence officer who left the
service at the same time as david shayla
who many of you will remember her
partner at the time
to help him blow the whistle about
criminality within the intelligence
service agencies as he saw it annie can
you tell us a little bit about your
experiences and also tell us a little
bit about your own story yes well thank
you very much for inviting me to speak
here i just have a few minutes uh two
points of information first of all if
you're an intelligence officer within
any of the uk intelligence agencies you
do not uh swear an oath you do not do
any of that sort of thing so slightly
different from the american system and
second point of information everything i
say now has already been cleared so if
anyone behind me is reaching for their
speed dial to special branch police
there is no need i can assure you
gentlemen
i join
i joined mi5 in the early 1990s along
with my ex-colleague and ex-partner
david shailer we both worked as
intelligence officers during our
recruitment there we were told
repeatedly that mi5 now had to obey the
law they've been put on a legal footing
for the first time in 1989 so it's a bit
of a shock during our six years there
that we saw such a cascade of
incompetence and criminality that we
felt compelled to leave and compelled to
go public in order to try and affect
some sort of change and that list of
incompetence and criminality included
files on government ministers and a
whole range of other prominent
individuals in the uk
it included illegal phone tabs
pi ira bombs that could and should have
been prevented which actually exploded
on uk streets
and then mi5
colluding in the cover-up about their
mistakes in the run-up in those
operations
it also included two innocent
palestinians who were convicted
wrongfully of an explosion outside the
israeli embassy in london in 1994 who
were sentenced to 20 years each and i
believe they still rot in prison
and it came to a zenith in 1996 when
david was officially briefed about
an mi6 funded plot to try and
assassinate colonel gaddafi of libya and
in this case mi6 was funding a bunch of
islamic or islamic extremists or
islamist rebels now i suppose the only
difference between then and now how the
years change things is that of course
now they're funding limited rebels but
they're doing it more openly we all know
about it
anyway what to do we hadn't signed up to
the agencies to collude in that sort of
activity we joined up to serve our
country and try and make a difference
now in the uk under the official secrets
act there is a clear bright line against
disclosure which means you can't go to
anybody apart from the head of the
agency which has committed the crime in
order to report the crime you can't even
go to your mp or to the police legally
under the terms of one one of the osa
so what to do
we decided after many sleepless nights
to go public to go to the press and to
hope that the ensuing um ferrari would
enable an inquiry would pile on the
pressure from inquiry into this
incompetence and criminality
this meant that we had to literally go
on the run around europe
we ended up living in hiding for a year
in france and we ended up living in
exile for another two years outside the
uk
we had to stand by and watch as friends
and family
as student supporters and even
journalists were arrested and in some
cases convicted because they dared to
expose these crimes to help expose these
crimes
and of course david went to prison not
once but twice first of all in 1998 when
the british government failed to
extradite him from france and secondly
after he had returned voluntarily to
stand trial under the official secrets
act and he was convicted and went to
prison in 2002
but in fact what happened that was worse
was the way his reputation was ruined in
the press through spin and through media
manipulation
and why does this happen because you
would think that the fourth estate would
hold the spies to account whereas in
fact they are very easily controlled by
both the government and the intelligence
agencies not only through the defense
and security advisory committee which is
a sort of media self-censorship
committee used to be known as the
d-notice committee but through the
application of the official secrets act
through the application of libel laws
through the application even of
terrorism acts and terrorism laws
and we also see as well there's a
section in mi6 called information
information operations which spins and
controls media news as well
so of course if we lived in an ideal
world where we had transparency and the
respect for human rights and freedom of
information and an ethical foreign
policy we wouldn't need the press to
continue to support whistleblowers or
you know even to do their duty to
support whistleblowers but we don't we
live in the real world of this nebulous
war and terror of illegal wars in the
middle east and the erosion of our civil
liberties and we need some sort of
channel to protect whistleblowers
and at the moment we don't have that
legal channel i suggest that we do need
one in the laws of this land but until
we do we have wikileaks and they provide
protection to the whistleblowers rather
than allowing the poor whistleblowers to
be persecuted and prosecuted so i say
thank you very much to wikileaks and i
hope they continue their work for many
years to come
before i introduce paul moore does the
wonder if anyone opposing the motion
wishes to come back
on that on some of the points and he
spoke about criminality within mi5
incompetence plots to assassinate
gaddafi does anyone wish to talk about
that come back on any other point she
raised douglas
douglas murray
can i just ask miss mackin if you ever
signed the official secrets act
well thank you
you try to present to this audience the
idea that you don't have to have some
kind of silence or secrecy if you're
going to engage in the secret service it
would seem to me inherent in the name
that if you join the secret intelligence
services you can keep secret sadly you
and your friend david shayla showed you
couldn't
and and what's more by the way if i may
say so ms mackin
um she's leaving the uh security
services you've made a career as a 9 11
trooper 911 conspiracy theorist and i
saw you and mr shayla testify before
lord savile a few years ago that one
time i've seen you having to speak on
oath and you were the shortest witnesses
that that inquiry in its 13 years ever
heard because you didn't have anything
to say
and because you came pretending you had
secrets and it became clear you didn't
know anything you were very low level
and you go around the world trying to
present yourself as an expert in this
area you didn't know anything you were
in services for a short time you broke
an act you signed and now you try to
present yourself as a free speech expert
it's laughable
[Applause]
thank you douglas i think i think on
this occasion can i just make two things
can you do something the pronunciation
your name the friend
yes okay so it'd be nice if you get even
more right could you please come back on
that
briefly though briefly yes well actually
the evidence we gave to the savile
inquiry was about a fake um agent called
infliction and we ensured that the
evidence given by mi5 officers about
this source was changed because of our
evidence so that was one thing we signed
the official secrets act to protect
official secrets not to protect crimes
and actually whatever level we worked on
and whatever level we worked on i'd say
we probably know a damn site more than
someone who has never worked on the
inside at all as an intelligence officer
so thanks for your informed comments
thank you annie for that um robust
intervention um
paul moore um tell us a little bit about
your experiences at hbos
from where i i believe you were
dismissed for warning
hbos and others about the extent of that
reckless banks over exposure and risks
so please tell us a little bit more
again
i'd like to hear your story what
happened to you what the consequences
were and maybe for four to five minutes
please
yes um you may think that blowing the
whistle on a bank has nothing to do with
death
but it does
the banking crisis has driven 100
million people into poverty
and
killed many millions of those people so
it does have something to do with death
i say one thing to bob
dwight eisenhower once said
never confuse honest dissent with
disloyal subversion there is a
fundamental difference between people
who raise and speak truth to power
from a position of ethical decency and
those who are doing it for subversion
i'm very pleased
hague lifts the lid on britain's secret
past times front page today we're a
government that believes in transparency
and openness it is what people expect
and it is what they have a right to
transparency is the key to truth
anything done in the dark
is not
nearly always the truth and it is the
truth that sets us free
we only grow by taking risks
and the biggest risk we ever have
is being honest with ourselves and
others
but this above all to thine own self be
true for then it must follow as the
night the day thou canst not be forced
to any man of course
obviously proper
whistleblowing makes the world a safer
place
it prevents disasters
it prevents wars
on a micro basis it removes people from
organizations who are criminals or doing
civil wrongdoing and on a macro basis it
leads to major change of policy process
and transparency leads to a better world
in my case i'm glad to say after i was
fired by james crosby for trying to slow
down halifax bank of scotland
that it has led to some changes some
good changes some protections for chief
risk officers i haven't got sufficient
time to go through some of these things
but there's not nearly enough change
that's come out of it and the principal
reason for doing what i did was to drive
change in the policy so that we can be
protected from the way the banks work we
have not done nearly enough about it
we're still not doing transparency on it
there's never been a proper inquiry
because if you did a proper inquiry the
vested interests would be found out the
vested interests of governments uh
regulators accountants rating agencies
etc
in fact
we're thinking of driving a mass
movement to get the transparency around
this because mark my words
if we don't solve it this time the next
time it will be a wipeout a complete
wipeout and many academics are saying it
and mervyn king's saying it
actually i'd like to blow this whistle
on the format of this particular event
how can you have an event of this nature
and not have a whistleblower standing up
here on the stage and being allowed to
speak for the proposition
i was given this
i was sent this whistle by an anonymous
admirer and on the side of it it says in
latin it is sweet and honorable to speak
up on behalf of the fatherland
now
excuse me whistleblowing
you have one minute whistle blowing may
make the world a safer place but it
doesn't make it a safe place for a
whistleblower and we've got to do
something about it you get treated like
toxic waste you get treated like a leper
you care more about the organization and
then they rubbish you i'm going to read
you something very personal i have
really
i have been in the depths of sheol over
this this is my son
writing a card to me on my birthday
on my birthday when i was in the depths
of suicide suicide around this i know
that you think this birthday stuff is
nonsense
but it is a day to celebrate your life
and what a great person you are know
this that everyone has flaws and i like
to look past those floors to the good
person and there is a lot of good in you
and a lot more than you give yourself
credit for i am truly proud of you and
everything you stand for which is mainly
integrity and truth
but don't worry
because actually we get transformed by
truth
and the reality is that you get
transformed by trouble so all the pain
and suffering has been worth while and
if you want to ask anybody how it
changes from
the valley of death to amazing grace ask
my lovely daughter emily who's in the
audience tonight and she will tell you
um thank you very much indeed thank you
thank you
so paul was blowing the whistle there
but that was very very poignant words in
in that card thank you very much um
we've had many questions for our website
for this event and what one julian which
seemed to occur again and again was this
idea of collateral damage um
putting innocent people at risk as a
result of whittle blowing or leaking
valuable information
um do you have a view on that be very
interesting to hear you on that please
so many people wanted to hear you speak
on that well i have a view on it
we have been in the business
for about four and a half years now of
exposing
actual
collateral damage
the deaths
added up
in total of over 140
000 people documented case by case
in the case of the us military and
assassinations
from kenya
to east timor
so that's actual
not only collateral damage actual murder
now if we speak about wikileaks
there has been a lot of hot air said
about our publications
by the pentagon and its supporters
and in fact by the press constantly
since
world war ii at least
about anything that the press publishers
that invest embarrasses the national
security sector but the facts are these
we have a perfect record in two respects
it is not perhaps a record that we can
keep forever
but to date we have never
released a document that was
misdescribed we have never got it wrong
ever
that anyone alleges
and no one has ever come to physical
harm as a direct result of anything that
we have published
so that's the answer
and that's what uh gates
the
defense secretary united states admits
it's what nato admits it's what the
pentagon has admitted on a constant
basis
but if you google for
the phrase blood on hands
and wikileaks
compare it to
flood on hands and pentagon without
wikileaks you see there are ten times as
many references to wikileaks and blood
on hands as there are to pentagon and
blood on hands
including all the wars that the pentagon
has ever done everywhere
so go away and think about that and
think about how is it that an
organization
whose opponents
say
that it has no blood on its hands but
there is some hypothetical risk that
everyone should be talking about
has managed to produce 10 times
as much history
embedded in news pages
about its opponent
having blood on its hands when it has
none
thank you
i'm very keen to keep this debate as
balanced as possible and i would very
much like to hear from douglas murray
i'd like you to come forward now
i thought we needed a long period
on which particular whichever you want
to say um do you want me to preempt my
speech yes please give you i'd like you
to deliver your spirit
okay very well
well
uh
do you want to say anything now
no i i'm i'm happy to hold i'd like to
hear that okay all right
thank you maddie hassan please step
forward everyone's been waiting for you
i'm worried about how one-sided it is
too i know paul's been whistling away
but paul there's about five of us on our
side and three on their side and by the
way paul i've been to countless debates
on fox hunting and there were no foxes
on the panel at all but um i'm joking
with you paul i'm joking
i don't want to talk about uh i don't
want to talk about wikileaks there's too
much wikileaks stuff julian with respect
i don't want about julian i don't talk
about me i don't talk about paul
i don't want to talk about phil b
burgess and maclean i want to talk about
a man named joe darby
joe darby was a uh joe dobby is a high
school graduate from small town
pennsylvania
who joined the us army reserves at the
age of 19 and was posted to iraq at the
age of 24. in january 2004 completely by
chance he was accidentally given two cds
containing hundreds of photos taken by
us military guards at a small prison
called abu ghraib
darby switched on his computer put the
cds in he saw iraqi prisoners hooded
gagged
forced to perform sex acts on each other
with electrical wires tied to their
genitals being threatened with dogs
being attacked sodomized raped the u.s
investigating officer anton taguba said
those pictures showed torture abuse rape
every indecency
by handing over those cds to the u.s
investigating officer
joe darby to use the lingo of the
military or to use bob's language
ratted on his friends on his fellow
soldiers
and when he ratted on them
he was immediately in fear for his life
because they weren't arrested those guys
they wandered round the base with
weapons he went to sleep with a pistol
under his pillow when he went back home
to see his wife he was told that they
had to sell their house and move town
because it was no longer safe to live
there anymore he had to be followed
around by six armed bodyguards for six
months he eventually quit the military
all because he decided to blow the
whistle because he helped us the rest of
the world uncover one of the worst
crimes perpetrated by the us military
abroad in recent years and there are a
lot to choose from
darby
darby was asked
darby was asked by cnn's anderson cooper
in an interview oh because if they'd
been given to somebody else they might
not have been reported would that have
been a bad thing said anderson cooper to
which darby replied they say ignorance
is bliss
but to actually know what they were
doing
you can't stand by and let that happen
you can't stand by and let that happen
ladies and gentlemen that is what
whistleblowing is all about and that is
why it is so important and if the
opposition side want to argue today that
whistleblowers don't make the world a
safer place that they risk lives rather
than save lives instead of pulling out
ancient examples from history about
spies perhaps they should all book a
ticket fly to baghdad and tell the
inmates of abu ghraib prison that
whistleblowers don't matter they have no
impact on the world they don't make the
society we live in a safer place i would
like them to go and talk to those people
and say joe darby shouldn't have blown
the whistle he shouldn't have come
forward he shouldn't have spoken out
whistleblowers perform these invaluable
life-saving tasks in many occasions and
remember let's be very clear and bob's
coming i'll take your point in one
second i just want to clarify before you
make your point bob goes on and on about
traitors
traitor spies who went to the soviet
union and sold secrets i'm not sure
which dictionary bob uses that is not a
whistleblower i'm not here to defend
spies i'm not here to prevent leakage
i'm here to defend people
who speak out against dangerous
dishonest or illegal activities that's
who i'm here for who are you here for
bob
i'm i'm here to be entertained by some
of the speakers this evening
not you but carry on
allow bob to have his point
the comparison
of the man who
turned over the cds of abu ghraib
and a person who violates an oath to
secrecy is a very different thing the
man who turned over those cities he had
no oath that he was breaking he had no
responsibility to an organization to
keep silent he behaved in a way he
should and for you to compare that
with someone who swears to retain a
secret and then
breaks that oath is wrong well thank you
very much for the point i'm not sure
that i don't i'm not sure we ever came
along to debate uh have a debate about
people who swear oaths and then break
secrets i thought we were having a
debate about whistleblowers and i
believe joe darby is a whistleblower and
is proud of being a whistleblower paul
with it without your whistle i'm not
going to let you in um but listen
this is a debate about people
this is a debate about people this is a
debate about people
it's not and actually paul's there paul
didn't take any oaths to protect his not
about oaths this is not about swearing
little uh secrets or signing documents
this is about people who speak out as i
said very clearly very clear definition
people who speak out against dangerous
dishonest illegal activities and it's
not just about politics and governments
let's be very clear it's about big
business and corporations too for
example take geoffrey wygand who was
vice president of brown and williams in
the u.s tobacco company portrayed by a
rather pot-bellied russell crowe in the
film the insider he was
he was he raised the alarm over the over
the nicotine that was used by his
company he was fired he was harassed his
children's lives were threatened but he
saved lives by becoming a whistleblower
because brown and williamson were then
forced by the us government to reduce
the carcinogenic ingredients in their
cigarettes on his evidence there was a
236 billion dollar case against big
tobacco the u.s food and drug
administration the fda said dr wygan's
assistance was central central to the
fda's investigation into the role and
effect of nicotine in tobacco products i
don't know bob whether jeffrey weigand
stood and put his hand up when he joined
brown williamson but he saw that they
were killing kids and he spoke out and
thanks to him again our world is a safer
place now in a perfect world
of course we wouldn't need
whistleblowers we wouldn't want
whistleblowers
but
surprise surprise we don't live in a
work perfect world shock horror we live
in a very imperfect world where our
governments and others lie to us
repeatedly
they engage in corrupt backroom deals
they break the law at home and abroad
and then they demand our trust
our trust year after year after year lie
after lie after lie and then they say
well you don't need whistleblowers well
stop lying to us and we won't have any
whistleblowers
show me a government
show me a government democratic or
undemocratic western or non-western
which hasn't been involved in cover-ups
or abuses of power of some shape or form
i remember john reed the labour minister
telling me trust me trust me i've seen
the intelligence the weapons are there
the weapons weren't there so david spoke
very eloquently said david was working
in the foreign office when his boss jack
straw was going around to downing street
to say and i quote the case for war
against saddam is thin
if only as julian pointed out we had
some whistleblowers back in 2002 2003
who instead of going to chat with andrew
gilligan in a bar had come and told all
of us the public about those dodgy
dossiers and those weapons of mass
distraction we would have hundreds of
thousands of innocent iraqis still alive
today had we had those whistleblowers
then
and
and in an imperfect world
in an imperfect world we need
whistleblowers in an imperfect world we
need whistleblowers until perhaps a day
will come when governments and
intelligence agencies and media
apologists will own up to the level of
deceit dishonesty corruption and
cover-ups in our public life and just to
conclude if you want any more evidence
of the important influence of
whistleblowers just look what happens to
whistleblowers if you want to know who's
on the right and who's on the rock just
look what happens to the people who blow
the whistle especially on their own
government look at daniel ellsberg
who was prosecuted threatened and
blackmailed by the nixon administration
which wanted to have him quote
incapacitated mordecai vanunu was held
by the israelis for 11 years in solitary
confinement he's still not allowed to
own a mobile phone or access the
internet and bradley manning of course
is being held right now by the obama
administration in solitary confinement
for 23 hours a day where his underwear
is taken from him before he's allowed to
go to sleep at night and i'm amazed that
people on the right are so fearful of
whistleblowers the same people who go on
about the big state big government evil
bureaucrats and yet when whistleblowers
come along to put power in our hands the
people's hands they get all worked up
and say this is outrageous this is wrong
this is going to destroy the world no
whistleblowers empower us all by
exposing the truth and brave people like
joe darby jeffrey weigand dare i say
private first class bradley manning make
the world a safer place for their sake
not for my sacred julian assange's sake
for their sake i urge you to back the
motion and i beg to propose thank you
very much
um thank you mary hassan senior politics
editor of the new statesman um we're
entering the home stretch here now 10 15
minutes to go it's a question here
clayton i'd be interested for you to
answer um jerry metcalf has asked it
says whistleblower organizations may
become a powerful tool to control the
government but who is going to control
those organizations who controls the
whistleblowers and how can we know that
the information that they publish is not
being manipulated
i think the short answer to that is the
public
the public holds us journalists to
account and i think the public takes in
on whether material submitted
anonymously
is done to impugn someone is done to
defame is done to conceal an agenda
i think all of what we heard really
doesn't give enough credit to the common
man and woman that they can take in
information that's submitted anonymously
and make their own opinions and evaluate
it and determine whether or not this is
information being put out there to spun
or to strike some other agenda or if
it's to legitimately call someone out on
wrongdoing i think there needs to be a
broader conversation on how
journalists
whether it's al jazeera whether it's
wikileaks whether it's any news
organization who
who touches and takes in this
information about what we put out and
what we don't put out i think those
conversations are taking place for
example
you know i i in my own uh in my own
opinion i don't think that it would be
good to put out information related to
critical critical infrastructure
vulnerability i don't think that the
public would be better served to know um
so absolute absolute openness you don't
support i don't and i don't think
journalism does that journalism we do
have
some context some background some nuance
we don't just vomit information without
vetting it thinking about what he likes
just promising information or does it
need media partners to i think earlier
you spoke about context and information
well i'll let julian speak for wikileaks
but what my my observation has been is
is that wikileaks has partnered with a
number of organizations that have and to
wikileaks credit it has allowed a
diversity of views on the subject he's
not monopolizing it and nor did al
jazeera with the palestine papers we
partnered with the guardian because
sometimes there's information that's
just too important for one news
organization to have and it would just
be too obvious for someone to say al
jazeera you didn't put out everything or
you spun it or or guardian you so when
you when you partner i think you get you
get more accountability and you get more
safeguards but i think that the short
answer is this is a new this is a new
type of journalism there does need to be
some sort of code of ethics and
standards and i think
as as as a new form of journalism it's
being worked out and i think the proof's
in the pudding and that's why it's so
popular and i think that's why this man
was voted by time magazine one of the
most popular figures in the world
because he's brought in and added to the
global discussion over what governments
are doing behind closed doors in their
names
douglas murray could you please step
forward
thank you
well um
well thank you very much um i'll be
trying to get you on all evening i know
i
i
i was never going to give up the
pleasure of being last in the running
order at least because it allows me to
disagree with some of my uh some of the
previous speakers and also to agree with
them um i'm sorry to
enter a note of boring uh bipartisanship
here but i agree with madi um it is
perfectly true that democracies and
democratic governments can be and in
most cases are at some point dishonest
and yes they can be corrupt this is true
democracy is a deeply flawed system
uh it isn't at all perfect it's not
perfect any more than the world is
perfect it is as churchill said the
worst system going apart from all the
others
and
i think we have to be aware very aware
in this discussion
of the difference
between open societies democracies
in which
evils can come to the fore
and do
and those systems in which they never do
and cannot
are there flaws in our governments of
course flaws in our systems of course
but by and large a democracy like
britain a democracy like america
has a lot of checks and balances along
the way
different departments
different officials
different
parties coming to power elections
elections every few years elections
which have just thrown out the
government that maybe was critical of
over iraq and i suspect will soon throw
out the current government here
um
making your biography a biography
possibly terrifyingly of the prime
minister
um
all of these things are true but
who knows what we should know who
decides
well
leakers
and people like mr assange and let's
just be clear tonight after all we have
mr sanjo on the panel so it is likely
we're going to be talking about
wikileaks and leaning in that direction
in this debate
decide they
know what you should know they can tell
you but do they know
ladies and gentlemen what they're doing
it's very very easy indeed i'm a
journalist so i spend a lot of my time
doing it and it is very easy to
criticize government when it goes wrong
it's also enjoyable
but governments
to some extent not perfectly tend to
know what they're doing do the leakers
do wikileaks know what they're doing
my own personal feeling is this
that when you
unleash
thousands and thousands of documents
that were never meant for the public eye
were never meant for your opponent's
eyes were never meant for foreign
intelligence agencies eyes
you introduced an element of chaos
it's like war
it's very hard to contain once you start
it
you may think you know what you're doing
you may think that you're going to lead
to great criticism of the american
government but what about the collateral
damage
in your campaign
are you sure you know what you're doing
when you
release secret uh documents
relaying secret conversations between
say the fragile government of the yemen
or jordan
or a conversation with the king of saudi
arabia saying that he hopes the israelis
do bomb iran
are you sure you know what you're doing
when you introduce an element of chaos
like that into a region which i can
assure you doesn't need more conspiracy
theories
miss mackin miss mashan i'm so sorry
i'll get it right at some point uh
talked about with great pride of her
release of the information that mi6 were
looking at trying to assassinate colonel
gaddafi
are you sure that it was a good idea
that you let colonel gaddafi know that
no
no i'll you'll get that i'm going to ask
you quite a lot of questions so you'll
get a chance no no no no no you'll get a
chance to answer my questions in a
minute mr assange when i finish speaking
continue on miss martin said that she
knew she was proud of the gaddafi thing
are we sure that it was a good idea to
let colonel gaddafi know 10 years ago
that mi6 had been looking at
at doing that to him you can sit down
you're going to have time i can tell you
um
[Music]
is mr assange sure
are you rejecting the interjection no
yes of course i'm in rejection
because i'm trying there will be time
because i'm trying to get through my
speech there will be time
is mr assange sure that he has read
through all of these documents and knows
better than foreign intelligence
agencies what they are likely to draw
from them maybe he does maybe he is
indeed the god-like figure such a person
would have to be
what about
aimed leaks after this new era of
journalism this new era of journalism it
strikes me it's very like the old one
people get to pursue their interests
if they hate america they can release a
whole load of stuff that they want to
make america look bad in the world if
like al jazeera you're implacably
hostile to the state of israel you can
release information which you think no
no no you'll get your time to
[Music]
you'll get an opportunity to sit please
be patient to sit in your in the state
of qatar not exactly an open democratic
government
and release as many papers as you can
that you think will show the state of
israel in a bad like very much like the
old journalism very much like it
are you sure uh ladies and gentlemen
that these new advocates of all this
freedom and openness are really as brave
as they present themselves clayton had a
lovely line earlier by the way i'll do
it for you he said he said that after
releasing the palestine papers i can
almost not keep a straight face we took
a lot of heat for doing it
i'm amazed you're here clayton made he
said what happens to whistleblowers well
it appears if mr assange is anything to
go by it's a lovely life
you can make a lot of money you can get
a lot of admirers you can present
yourself as a great advocate of
something you don't understand entirely
and you can pack out a hall in four
hours
now finally no no no no finally have to
take one no no no no you surely haven't
no no no they're gonna get a moment look
there are states in the world today
there are states in the world today
which really are hostile which really do
kill journalists i can't help noticing
that wikileaks and these other
organizations don't go for them why has
the russian government's secrets not
come out is it because the fsb
is it because no no is it because the
fsb actually kills journalists
actually does it
doesn't give them platforms
sit down and be quiet
please no shouting from the floor point
of information douglas has accepted it
julian assange
i have had
colleagues in kenya involved
with us in exposing
some 500 extrajudicial assassinations in
that country in the last three years
who themselves
have been assassinated
so i would ask you
to please do your research before making
comments like that well mr assange you
don't seem to be that bothered
if i don't say so um the most respected
guardian journalist nick davies relayed
the conversation with you about afghans
when he said that you had said they are
informants if they get killed they've
got it coming to them point of order
we are
free with people
the process of suing the guardian in
relation to their comment perhaps
you nick davies in the guardian it's not
nick davies it's david lee
one second we don't wanna [ __ ] get
generated
and mr science perhaps you would like to
speak to der spiegel who was also at the
meeting and has their own view of those
events which are precisely counter to
what you were saying
julian should an advocate of the open
society using libel laws to sue
newspapers
lies have no social utility the truth
has a social utility the abuse of libel
laws is a terrible thing that is why i
was involved in constructing the world's
strongest legislation
in iceland to protect us all from the
abuse of libel laws and have complained
constantly here in the uk
but actual lies by powerful
organizations that abuse the size of
their megaphone
in an industry
must have a recourse
and that recourse
is in the courts and the court of public
opinion thank you very much
um
can i continue one second
i will not tolerate any more points of
information i would like douglas to be
able to finish his speech please go
ahead i think i read from that mr sanch
thinks that libel law is good when he's
using it
um
as i said i very much look forward to
wikileaks revealing the full extent of
the russian secret services killing of
journalists it doesn't seem to me right
that at a meeting organized by
journalists club we don't raise this
fact the fact is the cia doesn't hunt
down and kill its critics the fsb does
and i'd love to see that reflected a
little more in your work daniel patrick
moynihan the late daniel patrick
moynihan said that by and large he'd
noticed as a diplomat throughout his
life that the complaints of human rights
abuses happened in exactly inverse
proportion to the human rights abuses in
a country
that the more you were able to hear
about them the less likely it was that
they were going on precisely because in
closed societies you don't hear these
stories i would love it if these new
organizations did blow the whistle on
these but i just note that they don't
finally
democracies as i said at the very
beginning
are imperfect things but the best things
going
they have to among other things
including elected representatives have
to answer questions they have to answer
questions sometimes those questions are
unpleasant they have to be answered and
when they're not answered you and i the
public get to throw out the politicians
that we no longer trust and we do
so those people who are very critical
like mr assange of the workings of these
governments
should perhaps answer some questions
themselves
and since we have the opportunity here
tonight and you'll allow me a little run
at this and then you can come back mr
assange
i'd like you to answer a couple of
questions you are after all
a an organization dedicated
to
freedom of information
who funds wikileaks
are you willing to reveal
all of your sources of funding
how can you demand transparency from
governments
when you as an organization have no
transparency yourselves
who works for you
who you involved with
who are your employees where are you
even based
none of these things get answered let's
have some more questions what's your
connection with israel shamir the
russian nationalist and holocaust denier
who says he was an employee of yours
furthermore what gives you the right to
decide what should be known to the
public and what should not governments
are elected you mr assange are not
finally who guards the guardians or in
this case who guards the guardians
guardians
it seems to me
that wikileaks is and will continue to
be a very unsatisfactory place to do
this from
i'm finishing with this
in his hislock relayed a couple of
months ago in private eye a telephone
conversation with you he said that in
the course of that telephone
conversation you said there was a
conspiracy led by guardian journalists
against you which included david lee the
editor alan russ bridger and john
campbell from index on censorship all of
whom you said you're quite jewish
and then when you realize that mr
russell is not jewish you said well sort
of jewish
i would like to know
whether i'm going off the point i'm
coming back to the point i can assure
you i would just like to know
all the rest of your attributes aside mr
assange somebody who has gone so far
into the fever swamps of conspiracy
theory whether you are really better
placed than any government to decide
what these ladies and gentlemen and i
and all of us can know thank you
[Applause]
douglas murray assistant director of the
henry jackson society newly appointed um
we've run out of time
but julian after those
final statesmen or allegations from
douglas would you like to come back and
say anything very briefly julian assange
very briefly to conclude the debate
obviously
mr murray
has nothing to say about the motion here
tonight
since he has resorted
like so many
of that type
to
personal attacks
on me
and our organization
which are of course
unfounded
and which
i hesitate to respond to directly
because i perceive them to be
a corruption of what we are all here for
but i cannot let
some of them go without comment
the most interesting of your views
is about
who decides whether
a media group
or organization
should be supported or not
i think that is
an interesting
question
and the answer in our case
is you decide
we are a publishing organization and we
publish the works of whistleblowers
we publish it to the world
and the world
is interested
in what we do all the fruits of our
labor
are visible to the public
because that is the type of labor that
we are engaged in
unlike
organizations which are supported
by oil
or by politically resting money out of
the tax base
or by advertisers
we are directly supported on a
week-to-week basis by you
you vote with your wallets
every week
if you believe
that us facilitating whistleblowing
is a worthwhile endeavor
or not
if you believe that it's not
if you believe we have heard
you do not support us
and if you believe we need to be
protected in our work
you keep us strong
that dynamic feedback between us
whistleblowers and the public
i say
is more responsive
than a government
structure that is elected
after sourcing money
from big business once every four years
thank you julian i will allow one final
point of information and then we will
close the debate very quickly have you
never received any money from anyone
other than the individuals of the
general public
and two
you have just confirmed to us you think
you're better than our governments
it's you that's meant to speak for us
thank you then the lady there has done
the job then your fawning clack have
done the job for you
thank you douglas murray um
i asked earlier
at the beginning of the debate for your
position i remind you what this motion
was again
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place
one second
i know i know julian has to go for
obvious reasons but one second who
believes
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place what is your
position on that now
roughly the same maybe fewer um who is
against the motion
anyone that's staining
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place
i'd just like to say thank you very much
to ryan gallagher of the frontline club
thank you to adam bury of the new
statesman for all their organizational
works thank you again to jemima khan for
our wonderful guest state of the new
statesman which you can all buy outside
and thank you for being such a good
audience thank you very much
next a conversation
good afternoon my name is von smith i'm
the founder of the frontline club
a co-founder actually
co-founder with my wife pranvera who's
hidden amongst you somewhere
um we're very excited to be doing this
today this is the largest event we've
done at the frontline club
and i'd like to thank will at the troxy
center and all his team
i'd like to thank you for coming
to this fantastic place
i'd like to thank um
dan our branding man because i'm
standing in front of 100 logos which are
all
new so thanks dan our new look
we're not shy of our new look
um
i'd like to thank the frontline club
staff
who've worked extremely hard to put this
on
particularly flora and millie and so
thank you all
i'm extremely proud of you all
the frontline club
exists to promote what's best in
journalism
and to
put on debates and discussions like this
and we're a social enterprise and if you
wish to support us come to paddington if
you haven't already been
where we can feed and entertain you um
we do 200 events a year as a social
enterprise the money you spend tonight
and any money you spend at the frontline
club helps us do this work so we're very
grateful for it
if you want to help julian or slavoy or
democracy now um you can buy some books
or put donations at the end and that
facility will be there now it's julian's
40th birthday tomorrow
so if you want to help him with those
exorbitant legal fees then you know give
generously at the end
um
so
all that remains is for me to welcome
amy goodman of democracy now amy
is a multiple award-winning journalist
um has and and and is the main presenter
for democracy now and has flown all the
way for america to be here and
she's a pretty fine person and i'm
extremely glad to hand over to her now
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
well good afternoon it is a great honor
to be with you this afternoon and a
shout out to all of the people who are
watching this broadcast all over the
world
we are live streaming this at
democracynow.org by the way how many of
you watch or listen to or read democracy
now
we have
we've given out about a thousand flyers
of where we broadcast in uh britain uh
and also
um where you can watch read and listen
to the broadcast
we're also live streaming we've offered
the embed for anyone to take to put on
their website
the nation is live streaming us
michaelmore.com is live streaming us
free speech tv is broadcasting democracy
now across the united states and there
are many others i hope people tweet in
facebook and let us know what you're
doing with this broadcast
it's extremely important
because information
is power
information is a matter of life and
death
we've learned that through
these remarkable trove of documents that
have been released in the last year
the iraq war logs the afghanistan war
logs and what's been called cablegate
the u.s state department documents that
are continuing to be released
why does it matter so much well we'll
talk about that this afternoon
but let's just take one example
that came out in the iraq war logs
february of 2007.
the
war log show
that two men were
standing iraqis under an apache
helicopter
the men have their hands up
they clearly are attempting to surrender
the apache helicopter can see this
so they're not rogue the soldiers call
back to the base and they say what
should we do these men have their hands
up
the lawyer on the base says you cannot
surrender to a helicopter and they blow
the men attempting to surrender away
that was february 2007
now we will fast forward to july 12 2007
and video that has been released by
wikileaks this devastating video
of an area of baghdad called new baghdad
where a group of men were showing around
two reuters journalists well one was a
videographer and a young up-and-coming
videographer named namir noor elding
and one was his driver syeechima he was
40 years old he was the father of four
and they were showing them around the
area
the same apache helicopter unit is
hovering above
they opened fire
the video is chilling i am sure many of
you have seen it if you watch or listen
to democracy now we played it repeatedly
discussing it with various people from
julian assange to soldiers who were
there on the ground over time we
dissected this
the soldiers opened fire you have the
video of the target
and you have the audio of the sounds of
the soldiers cursing laughing but not
rogue
always going up the chain of command
asking for permission to open fire
explosion namir nor el dean and the
other men on the ground are killed uh
saeed shema you can see him attempting
to crawl away
and then a van pulls up from the
neighborhood
and they're attempting to
pick up the wounded their children in
the van and the apache helicopter opens
fire again and saeed
others in the van are killed two little
children are critically injured inside
now
i dare say that if we had seen what came
out in the iraq war logs in february of
2007
if we had learned the story at the time
after it happened of the men with their
hands up trying to surrender there would
have been an outcry people are good
people care people are compassionate
they would have called for an
investigation perhaps one would have
been what would have begun
but it might well have saved the lives
of so many
certainly
months later
perhaps that same apache helicopter unit
under investigation would not have done
what it did
and maybe namir noor elding the young
reuters videographer and his driver said
shema not to mention the other men who
were killed and the kids critically
injured
none of that would have happened to them
that's why information matters it is
important we know what is done in our
name
and today we're going to talk about
this new age of
information we're joined by
two people many of you know well
earlier i asked a young man
who had come to the gathering why he had
traveled so far he said are you kidding
to be with two of the most dangerous
people
well the national review
calls slovenian philosophers as slavoy
zizik the most dangerous political
philosopher in the west in the new york
times
says he's the elvis of cultural theory
slavoy jizzak has written over 50 books
on philosophy psychoanalysis theology
history and political theory his latest
book living in the end times
and we'll talk about
what he thinks and talks about around
the world
now we're joined
by another man who has published perhaps
more than anyone in the world
in fact he wrote a book
on the
underground computer information age
called underground the integr
international computer underground
but with the iraq war logs the
afghanistan war logs now the u.s
government cables that have yet to be
fully
released i would say
that julian assange is perhaps the most
widely published person on earth
today we're going to have a conversation
about information and
i'd like to ask julian to begin
by
going back to that moment in 2007 as we
talk about the iraq war logs
and talk about the significance of them
for you and why you've chosen to release
this information
well amy
i suspect under that criteria perhaps
rupert murdoch is the most widely
published person
on earth
something like
people say that australia has given
two people to the world rupert murdoch
and me that are fairly
big in publishing um
well
in some ways
things are very easy for us and very
easy for me
and that we make a promise to
sources that if they give us material it
is of a certain type that is a
significant
of diplomatic political ethical or
historical significance not published
and under some sort of threat
we will publish it
and
that
actually is enough of course
we have a goal with publishing material
in general but
it has been my long-term belief that
what advances us as a civilization is
the entirety of our intellectual record
and the entirety of our understanding
about what we are going through
what human institutions are actually
like and how they actually behave and if
we are to make
rational
policy decisions insofar as any decision
can be rational
then we have to have information that is
drawn
from
the real world and the description of
the real world and at the moment we are
severely lacking
in the information from the interior of
big secretive organizations that have
such a role in shaping how civilization
evolves and how we all live
so
getting down
into iraq so that was four hundred
thousand
uh documents each one written in
military speak on the other hand
each one having a geographic coordinate
down often to 10 meters a death count of
civilians
us military troops iraqi troops
and
suspected insurgents
so
it was the the first
um
rather the largest because we also did
the afghan war logs the largest
history of a war
the most detailed significant history of
a war to have ever been published
probably at all
but definitely
during the course
of a war and so it provided a a picture
of
the everyday scholar of war from
children being killed at roadside
blocks to over a thousand people being
handed over to the iraqi police for
torture
to
the reality um of
close air support and how modern
military combat combat is done leaking
linking up with other information such
as this video that we discovered of the
men surrendering
being attacked so
it's
as a as an as an archive of human
history
this is
a beautiful and horrifying thing both
both at the same time
it is that the history of
the nation of iraq
in the most significant recording
during
its most significant development in the
past
20 years
and
while we always see
newspaper stories revealing
and personalizing
some indiv if we're lucky some
individual event or some individual
family dying
this provides
the broad scope of the entire war and
all the individual events over the
details of over 104
000
deaths
and we work together to statistically
analyze this and with
various groups um around the world such
as a iraq body count uh who became the
specialist in the specialist in this
area and lawyers here in the uk who
represented iraqi refugees to pull out
the stories of
15 000
iraqi civilians
labelled as civilians by the us military
who were killed who were never before
reported in the iraqi press never before
reported in the in the u.s press or in
the world press even in aggregate
even saying today a thousand people died
not reported in any manner whatsoever
and
you just think about that
15
000 people um
whose deaths
were recorded by the us military but
were completely unknown um to the rest
of the world that's a
a very significant thing and compare
that to the 3 000 people who died in 9
11. and imagine the significance
for iraqis so
that is something that
that we specialize in and that i like to
do and i've always tried to do is to
go from the small to the large
not just by
abstraction or by analogy but actually
by encompassing
all of it together and then trying to
look at it and abstract uh through
mathematics or statistics um
and so to try to try and and push
both of these things at the same time
the individual relationship
plus the the state relationship uh plus
the
the relationship that has to do with
civilization as a whole
the importance of wikileaks today in the
world
well uh
to answer properly this question is just
you can withdraw and give me two hours
no but i will try to condense it first
let me say also how proud i am to be
here and let me mention something which
maybe most of you don't know that how
difficult even it was to organize this
event like it had to be moved two times
out and more out from central london
and so on so again what i want to say is
let me begin with
the significance of what you amy started
with these
shots i mean not shooting but video
shots of those apache helicopters
shooting on you know why this is
important because the way ideology
functions today it's not so much that
let's not be naive that people didn't
know about it but i think the way those
empowers manipulate manipulated yes we
all know dirty things are being done but
you are being informed about this
obliquely in such a way
that basically
you are able to ignore it
and the
can i make a terrible uh maybe sexual
offensive but not dirty don't be afraid
remark you know like
a husband sorry for male chauvinist
twist a husband may know abstractly
my wife's is cheating on me or and you
can accept okay i'm a modern tolerant
husband but you know when you get the
photo of your wife doing things it's
quite a different thing and it's i would
say with all respect something similar
it's very important because the same no
i'm not dreaming here the same thing i
remembered happened i think about two
years ago in serbia
you know people rationally accept that
we did horrible things in srebrenica and
so on but you know it was just abstract
knowledge
then by chance all the honor to serve
media who published this they got hold
of a video effectively showing a group
of sharks
pushing to an edge and shooting a couple
of bosnian prisoners and the effect was
a total shock national shock although
again strictly
seeing nobody learned anything new so
here so that i don't get lost if you
allow me just a little bit more here we
should see the significance of
wikileaks
many of
my friends who are skeptical about it
are telling me so what did we really
learn isn't it clear that every power in
order to function you have collateral
damage you have to have a certain
discretion what you say what you don't
say but to conclude i will propose a
formula of what wikileaks is doing and
it's extremely important of course i'm
not a utopian neither me nor julian
believes in this kind of a
pseudo-radical openness everything
should be clear and so on but
what are we dealing with here another
example from cinema very short ernst
lubich
you find there a wonderful joke where i
think towards the beginning of the film
the hero enters a cafeteria and says
can i get some coffee with cream please
and the waiter answers him sorry
we run out of cream we only have milk so
can we give you can i serve you with
coffee without milk
that's the trick here like when we learn
something from the media like if i may
reply repeat the metaphor they behave as
if they are serving
uh coffee with cream
that is to say of course we all know
they are not
telling the entire truth but you know
that's the trick of ideology even if
they don't lie directly the implications
the onset is a lie and you bring this
out
you are not so much
putting them
cutting them catching them as they put
it with their pens down lying on behalf
of what they explicitly say but
precisely on behalf of what they are
implying and i think this is an
absolutely crucial mechanism in ideology
it doesn't only matter what you say it
matters what you
what you what you imply to say and so on
so just to make the last point i think
that are we aware at what an important
moment
we are living today on the one hand as
you said
information is crucial and so on
we all know that exclusive even
economically i claim that one of maybe
the main reasons capitalism will get
into crisis is intellectual property in
the long term it simply cannot deal with
it but what i'm saying is just take the
phenomenon that media are trying to
get us enthusiastic for clouds like you
know computers getting smaller and
smaller and all is done for you up there
in a cloud okay but the problem is that
clouds are not up there in clouds they
are controlled and so on for example you
rely on
maybe you have an iphone but you
mentioned murdock no most mentioned here
do you know it's good to know if you
rely on your news through iphone or
whatever that apple signed an exclusive
agreement with murdoch murdoch's
corporation is again the exclusive
provider of entire news and so on and so
on this is the danger today it's no
longer this
clear distinction private space public
space the public space itself gets as it
were privatized in a whole series of
invisible ways like the model of it
being clouds which is why and again this
involves new modes of censorship i
repeat this that's why you shouldn't be
tricked when you say but what really did
we learn
new maybe we learned nothing new but you
know it's the same as in that beautiful
old
andersen's fairy tale
the emperor is naked the emperor is
naked we may all know that the emperor
is naked but the moment somebody
publicly says the emperor is naked
everything changes
this is why even if we learned nothing
new but we did learn many new things but
even if nothing clear the forum matters
so don't confuse
julian and his gang in a good sense not
the way they accuse you don't com don't
confuse them with this usual bourgeois
heroism fight for investigative
journalism
free flow and so on you are doing doing
something much more radical you are
that's why it allows such an
explosion of resentment you are not only
violating the rules disclosing secrets
and so on let me call it in the old
marxist way
the
press today has its own way to be
transgressive each ideology not only
controls what you say but even how you
can violate what you are allowed to say
you are not just violating the rules you
are changing the very rules how we were
allowed to violate the rules this is
maybe the most important thing you can
do
and yet julian even as you were
releasing information in all different
ways you then turned to the very
gatekeepers who in some cases who had
kept back
this information and you worked with the
mainstream media throughout the world in
releasing uh various documents talk
about that experience and that level of
cooperation and what has happened after
that
an organization
[Music]
now that you said this they will again
idiots accuse you you see he is the
authoritarian leader who
gives commands and talks
i'm not saying this is not true i think
this is the only way to really keep
things going
so if you if you want to have
an impact and you promise an impact and
you're an organization which is very
small where actually you have to
co-opt
or leverage the rest
of the mainstream press
so
under our model of how you make an
impact and how you get people to do
things that you wouldn't have been
otherwise able to do unless you have an
army that can physically go someplace
and panzer divisions that can roll over
um the only way that you can easily make
an impact
is
push information about the world
too many many people across the world
and so the mainstream press
has developed expertise
in how to do that and it is competition
also for people's attention uh
so if we if we had had
several billion dollars to spend on
advertising across the world even if we
could get our um
ads placed uh we wouldn't
easily be able to have made the same
impact that we did and we don't have
that kind of money
so instead if you like
we
entered into relationships with
now over 80
media organizations across the world
including some very good ones that i
wouldn't want to
disparage to
increase the impact and translate and
push our material
uh into now over 50 different countries
endemically
and that that has been yes
subverting the filters of the mainstream
press that
an interesting phenomena has developed
amongst the journalists who work in
these
very large organizations that
are close to power and negotiate with
power at the highest levels
which is the journalists having read our
material and having been forced to go
through it
to pull out stories
have themselves become educated and
radicalized and
that
is an ideological penetration of the
truth
into
all these mainstream media organizations
and that to some degree may be one of
the lasting legacies
over the past year
also by
you know
even
fox news which is much disparaged is an
organization that wants viewers it
cannot do anything else without viewers
so
it will try and push news content so for
example with collateral murder
cnn
showed only the first few seconds and
they blanked out
all the bullets going onto the street
completely blanked it out and said that
they did so out of respect for the
families the people were killed well
there was no blood there was no there
was no gore and then they cut out all
the most politically salient points and
the families had come forward
and said it was very important for us to
know that they'd already seen it but fox
actually displayed
the first killing scene in full
it's quite interesting
so
fox
not
perceiving itself
to be
amenable to the threat
of it not acting in a moral way
actually
gave people more of the truth than cnn
did
and so fox also motivated to grab in a
hungry way as greater audience share as
possible
took this content and gave it to more
people now afterwards of course they put
in their commentators uh to talk to talk
against it but i think
the truth that we got out of fox
it was often stronger than the truth
that we got out of cnn and similarly for
many
institutions in the media that we think
of as liberal
and perhaps slavery would like to speak
about that i cannot emphasize enough
like first i treated you not as an idiot
out of politeness but then i'm more and
more forced to admit that you really are
not an idiot sorry for that you know
it happens no because seriously i mean
what you said now is extremely important
with all the respect i have for and i
don't mean this in any way ironically
honest liberals who really believe
people should be informed and so on but
there are limits in their very mode how
they function so we should
ruthlessly not in an ethical way but
nonetheless ruthlessly use as you
pointed out in this difference between
cnn and fox every every window of
opportunity here and
let me add another example from a
totally different domain but from
fixing cinema tv series which i think
reproduces the same duality
we have
the usual hollywood left all this
uh all this
for to raise our spirit left liberal
pseudo hollywood marxism thrillers like
pelicans brief all the president's men
which may appear very critically like oh
my god
the president himself is corrupted
connected to certain
corporation and so on but nonetheless
this is ideology why because why
do you exit the movie theater in such
high spirits after seeing i don't know
all the and so on because the message is
nonetheless look what a great country we
are an ordinary guy can topple the
mightiest man in the world and so on and
so on on the other hand let me take
an equivalent in tv program of fox news
which would have been please don't take
me for being crazy
24 yeah yeah jack bauer and told that
the last season
of 24 i watched it with pleasure is for
me my god again as you approach it the
way you approach those shots it's for me
much more consequential in criticism you
get jack bauer who is in total despair
his whole world crumbles down he has to
admit
this way what he tried to do in previous
seasons of playing this role of somebody
should do the dirty job torture the
prisoners i will do it he says no i
cannot live with it it has to come
public his liberal counterpart
called alison taylor the president also
steps down you know what's the true
message of it the message is simply
within the existing ethical political
coordinates
you are just stuck into a deadlock there
is no way it's a very pessimistic
message much more honest that on that
all that uplifting hollywood marxism
what a great country we are and so on
and so on so yes at all levels even not
only at in journalism as such i agree
with you and i would even say that all
leftist tradition knows this for example
already marx said i'm no fetishist of
marx but nonetheless he said that we can
often learn more from honest
conservatives than from liberals because
what honest conservatives do is that
they don't try to sell you at the end
some uplifting [ __ ] they are ready
to confront a deadlock and that's what's
important today
i don't want to look distracted looking
down but i wanted to get these quotes
accurate so i have them on my phone
nothing threatening i just hear that yes
newt gingrich the former speaker of the
house in the united states
said julian assange is engaged in
warfare information terrorism which
leads to people getting killed
is terrorism and julian assange has
engaged in terrorism he should be
treated as an enemy combatant and
wikileaks should be closed down
permanently and decisively
bill keller of the new york times said
arrogant thin-skinned conspiratorial
judith miller who together
who often wrote or co-wrote articles
that appeared on the front page of the
new york times alleging weapons of mass
destruction
without named sources
said julian assange isn't a good
journalist didn't care at all about
attempting to verify the information he
was putting out or determine whether or
not it would hurt anyone
joe biden the vice president of the
united states said julian assange is a
high-tech terrorist congressmember peter
king of new york called for assange to
be charged under the espionage act and
asked whether wikileaks can be
designated a terrorist organization
not to just focus on the u.s tom
flanagan a former aide to the canadian
prime minister has called for assange's
assassination
and former alaska governor sarah palin
uh
called that's an interesting person i
first heard about her called you uh
julian an anti-american operative with
blood
on your hands
can you respond to these charges
well
you know
after bill keller said that i was thin
skinned it doesn't really leave much
ground to reply does it
um
sarah palin also once on twitter
complained about my grammar
which is really the biggest insult for
me i mean
calling for a drone attack um is
perfectly understandable but correcting
my grammar from sarah palin that's a
real insult
that event in the united states
was very interesting i mean obviously
the the calls are
uh
wrong and outrageous and so on but
the
social and political event in which they
occurred was was fascinating so within a
few months
we saw
a new
mccarthyist hysteria
arise within the united states in
december and january
january this year december last year
and
that
is quite worrying
that i new mccarthyism can come up so
quickly
on the other hand
yes there are a lot of opportunistic
politicians playing to their base
playing to their pals in the
military-industrial complex
on the other hand
you know
power that is completely unaccountable
is silenced
so
when when you walk past a group of ants
on the street and you accidentally crush
a few you do not turn to the others
and say stop complaining or i'll put a
drone strike on your head
you completely ignore them and and that
is what happens to power that's in a
very dominant position it does not even
bother
to respond it doesn't flinch for an
instant
and yet we saw all these figures in the
united states
coming out and speaking very
aggressively
bill keller in a recent talk um
as a way of sort of
perhaps legitimizing why he was speaking
about me
said that
if you have a dealing with julian
assange you are fated to sit on panels
for the rest of your life explaining
what you did
but actually no that's a choice by bill
keller
a choice to go around and try and
twist history and whitewash history and
adjust history on a constant basis why
why expend the energy do doing that why
not just knock off another front page of
the new york times
because actually these people are
frightened
of the true part of history coming up
and coming forth so i so i see this is a
very positive sign and i've stated
before that
we should always see
censorship actually
as a very positive sign and the attempts
towards censorship as a sign that
the society is not yet completely sewn
up not yet completely fiscalized but
still has some political dimension to it
i.e
what people believe and think and feel
and the words that they listen to
actually matters
because
in some areas it doesn't matter and in
the united states actually
most of the time
it doesn't matter what you say we manage
to to speak and give information at such
volume
and of such intensity
that people actually were forced to
respond it is rare that they are forced
to respond so
i think this is
one of the first positive symptoms i've
seen from the united states in a while
that act that actually if you speak at
this level
the cage can be rattled a bit and people
can be forced to respond in china
the censorship is much more aggressive
which to me is a very hopeful symptom
for china that it is still a political
society even though it is fiscalizing
even though everything has been sewn up
in contractual relationships and banking
relationships as time has gone by at the
moment the chinese
government and public security bureau
are actually scared of what people think
can i just add something again i i hate
myself because i want that what is that
movie called there will be blood no but
unfortunately there will not be a lot of
blood between the two of us because i
again agree speaking about china let me
tell you maybe you know it a wonderful
it's not an anecdote
which perfectly makes confirms your
point do you know that about two or
three months ago a chinese government i
don't know which agency passed a law
which formally prohibits in public media
they mean press books comics tv movies
all stories which deal with time travel
or alternate realities
literally i checked it up with my
friends in china the official
justification was that history is a
great matter it shouldn't be
left to such trifling games and so on
but of course it's clear what they
really are afraid of for people to even
imagine
alternate
realities other possibilities now again
to repeat your point i think this is a
good sign they at least need the
prohibition with us we don't need a
prohibition most of the time if somebody
proposes a radical change we simply
accept this spontaneous everyday
ideology but we all know what our
economic reality is like you propose uh
to raise for one percent health care
spending no it would mean it would mean
loss of competitive competition and so
on and so on so again i totally agree
with you here and just a final comment
of the persons that you amy mentioned
listen
a newt gingrich is for me sorry to use
this strong
word kind of a scam of the earth i don't
have any great no no i will be very
precise i don't have any great sympathy
for bill clinton but i remember when
there was this campaign monica lewinsky
campaign
newt gingrich was making all these
moralistic attacks
and then
it was confirmed in media i listened to
interview with him where he confirmed it
that
when his wife was dying in cancer two or
three years before nude grinvit gingrich
visited her in a hospital forcing her to
sign not even having the decency for
letting her die forcing her to sign a
divorce agreement so that he could have
married another woman and he was
at the exact time of uh
of uh lewinsky affair already treating
her with the secretary of him there and
so on and so on listen these are people
who simply my god i become here kind of
a moral conservative there should be
some kind of ethical committee which
simply
claims people like this are a threat to
our youth they should be prohibited from
appearing in public whatever now i will
make a more important point as to this
terrorism stuff
let me make it clear but i'm not crazy i
mean this in a positive sense yes in a
way you are terrorist in which sense in
the sense in which as i like to repeat
gandhi was a terrorist what you
are doing let's face the facts it's not
just something that can be swallowed oh
oh look all the interesting news in the
newspapers here this is happening
there's lavish iraq is dating lady gaga
and here
totally not true and here there's
wikileaks you effectively have
in a good sense
do we have a denial and official denial
on the lady gaga absolute denial on
everything
i mean
everything i didn't even listen to not
even one of her songs
my god i listened to shubert and human
songs i'm sorry i'm in a conservatory i
don't know her representative was not
that defiant they just said no my
friends were telling me the same you
stupid you should have said no comments
and then you will enjoy much more glory
and so
okay
let's go on no no i have a more serious
point to make about but what does this
mean
of course you are in which sense was
gandhi a terrorist he effectively tried
to
stop interrupt the normal functioning of
the british state in india and of course
you are trying to interrupt the normal
which is very oppressive functioning of
the information circulation and so on
but the way we should answer to this
point i claim is simply by another i
repeat myself here i know endless
paraphrase of that wonderful
line from brexberger's opera what is
robbing a bank compared to founding a
new bank what is your under quotation
marks terrorism compared to the
terrorism which we simply accept which
has to go on day by day so that these
things remain the way they are that's
where ideology holds us when we talk
about violence terrorism we always think
about
acts which interrupt the normal run of
things but what about violence which has
to be here in order for things to
function the way they are
so i think
if
i'm very skeptical about it we should
use in my provocative spirit i'm tempted
to the term terrorism it's strictly a
reaction to a much stronger terrorism
which is here so again instead of
engaging in this moralistic game oh no
he is a good guy like stalinis said
about lenin you like small children you
play with cats you wouldn't as norman
bates says in psycho you wouldn't hurt
even the fly no no no you are in this
formal sense a terrorist but if you are
a terrorist my god what are then they
who accuse you of terrorism so
to to to finish with another nasty dog
you know what they try to give us the
good news like all the news you are
giving us are these obscure
falsifications good news but you know
what are these good news the day those
in power are promising us let me give
you another wonderful jewish american
joke that was told to me by a friend
recently a guy has his wife at an
operation and then talks after the
operation with the doctor and the doctor
tells him listen first the good news
your wife will survive she will even
live longer than you and then
what's the bad news
the doctor says the bad news is you know
there are some problems like as a result
of the operation she will no longer be
able to control her anal muscles so
excrement will be dripping all the time
then there will be some strange fluid
all the time escaping from her vagina no
sex then she will not be able to blah
blah blah and of course the guy gets
more and more into a panic no my god and
then you know what the doctor does then
he taps the guy on the shoulder and say
no no don't worry this was just a joke
everything is okay she died during the
operation
that's the good news that they are
giving us at the end
i surprised
no dirty words you noticed this no dirty
words
because amy is always telling me when
she was kind enough to receive me in new
york flavor not even the s word s-h-i-n
no dirty words so
for that we can be taken off the air
but
i wanted to ask you julian about bradley
manning
mike huckabee who also was a
presidential candidate the governor of
arkansas
said that the person who leaked the
information to julian assange should be
tried for treason and executed he said
whoever in our government leaked that
information is guilty of treason and i
think anything less than execution is
too kind a penalty
um bradley manning as a young u.s
soldier who was in iraq
has been held for more than a year much
of that time in solitary confinement in
quantico in virginia
it was exposed that
his treatment was tantamount to torture
pj crowley the
white house the state department
spokesperson
spoke to a group of bloggers at mit and
said his treatment is stupid for that he
was forced out of the state department
bradley manning was then moved to fort
leavenworth because of the outcry but he
remains
in prison
he remains um
not tried
what are your comments on him
well first of all amy it's thanks
francine's quest asking this question
but it is
difficult for me
to
speak in detail about that case and
but i can speak about why it is
difficult for me to speak about it
so
bradley manning is
an alleged source of wikileaks uh who
was detained in baghdad and then
although there was very little
uh
no mainstream privacy at the time
shipped off to kuwait where he was if
you like
held in an extrajudicial circumstance in
kuwait
in a similar manner to which
detainees are held in guantanamo bay
eventually through some
legal
creative legal methods
he was brought back to the united states
and he's been in prison now for over a
year
he was being
kept in quantico on for eight months
under extremely adverse conditions the
quantico is not meant for long-term
prisoners other prisoners the maximum
duration
over the past year
has been three months
and
people that have been visiting bradley
manning
say
and we have other sources who say that
they
were applying those conditions to him
because they wanted him to confess that
he was
involved in a conspiracy to commit
espionage against the united states with
me
that
pressure
on manning
appears
to have backfired
so by all reports
this is a young man of
of high moral character
and when people
of high moral character
are
pressured in a way that is illegitimate
they become stronger and not weaker
and that seems to have been the case
with bradley manning
and he has told
us authorities
as far as we know nothing about his
involvement
now
there has concurrently been a secret
grand jury taking place six kilometers
from the center of washington
that grand jury involves 19 to 23 people
selected
from that area now why was it in
alexandria virginia six kilometers
central washington
that
that grand jury was placed and those
people drawn
well it has the highest density of
government employees
anywhere in the united states the us
government was free to select the place
and they selected this place in order to
bias the jury
from the very beginning
this is in fact wrong to call a jury
this is a type of medieval star chamber
there are these
19 to 23 individuals from the population
that are sworn to secrecy they cannot
consult with anyone else there is no
judge
there is no defense counsel and there
are four prosecutors
so that is why
people that are familiar with grand jury
inquiries united states say that a grand
jury would not only indict a hand
sandwich it would indict the ham and the
sandwich
and that's a real
threat to us
it a grand jury
which was
removed from uk jurisprudence because of
abuses
combines the executive and the judiciary
so this old
common law notion of the separation of
these branches of power is removed in
the grand
the
jury
government argues that these captive
19 to 23 individuals
are
the branch of the judiciary of the
judiciary that they perform a judicial
function
where of course actually they're just
captive patsies for
the department of justice united states
and the fbi
so they have been
going out and they have coercive powers
they can force people to testify and
they have been pulling in all sorts of
people that are connected to wikileaks
and people that are not
they have recently
a number of individuals that have been
pulled to the grand jury understand uh
what is going on
and they have refused uh to
testify and have pleaded the first
amendment third amendment
and the fifth amendment
um protection against self-incrimination
too
well i'm not sure the purpose i don't
have direct communication but from the
outside it appears to
nullify that political witch hunt in the
united states against us
now in response
the grand jury
has been instructed to
send out immunity certificates
so these are certificates that go to
subpoenaed individuals
that say that if you come to the grand
jury to testify your testimony testimony
cannot be used against you and therefore
you have no right to plead the fifth
what this means in practice
is
coerced
compulsive
interrogation in secret
with no
defense counsel there's not not even
lawyers for
for the subpoenaed witnesses are
permitted
into the grand jury it is just the
prosecutors
and these people from six six kilometers
away from centre of washington
that's something that should be opposed
there's another grand jury that has
sprung up here in the united states and
is investigating anti-war activists
engaged in this in the same sort of
witch hunt
so these are
really a
a classical device that was
looked at very critically in the uk 400
years ago
and the result in the uk is this concept
that there uh if justice is to be done
it must be done publicly
and that has been a concept that is way
late it's interesting why
or how it has been waylaid so that on
the surface this device of
well you want the police to have an
investigation executive says it wants to
conduct an investigation into some group
of people
well we get people from the community 19
to 23 people from the community and they
monitor the investigation they make sure
it's not overstepping and so on
but actually this has been turned on its
head uh and used as a way to completely
subvert the judicial system united
states
your comments like um
no first again i would like to say that
crucial are the terms that i think you
both mentioned all this
extra legal space unlawful combatants
and so on and so on the paradox is that
i think we should uh
read these terms as strictly connected
to universal human rights to what i have
nothing against universal human rights
what i'm opposed to is how
the reference to universal human rights
is de facto used in today's ideological
struggles that
in order to
sustain support within the space of
ruling ideology universal human rights
you have to
construct a space which is no not
no longer the space of the enemy
in this sense enemy to whom the rules
apply either geneva convention and so on
but you have to create to what the great
american thinker and politician dick
cheney referred to as the gray zone once
you know like we have to do something
discreetly don't ask us around about it
and so on and so on here i would say
things are even
more complex than it may appear because
what i find really terrifying
is that
concepts like unlawful combatants are
becoming legal categories now i'm not a
utopian here let me be bru and i will
maybe shock some of you brutally open i
can well imagine a situation where
well i cannot promise you in advance
that i wouldn't torture someone let's
imagine this ridiculous situations where
a bad guy has my young daughter and then
i have in my hands a guy and i know that
that guy knows where my daughter is well
maybe out of despair i would have
tortured her him whatever
what i absolutely opposed to is to
legalize this i think if
out of despair
i do something like this it should
remain something unacceptable you know
that i did out of despair i'm i what i'm
afraid of is that this system gets
institutionalized as it were where all
this will you know because we know what
is at the end of the road i had a
polemic just an exchange in new york
times with
uh alan dersovich who wants legalization
of torture and i read one of his
proposals it's an obscenity you will
have doctors let's say just a friendly
to scare you a little bit example amy
and me are the torturers you somebody
has to play this role will be tortured
no so let's say we call a doctor who
it's an obscenity who self sorry speak
for yourself okay sorry yeah okay no but
you know what i'm saying who who
investigates you and determines
you can torture him to that degree if
and so on and so on
for me what's horrible is not
of course it is torture at such but it's
even more obscene this uh normalization
of torture which is why yes more than
you i mean this respectively manning is
for me the hero because you have a
certain moment of glory and so on and so
on that poor guy who for me
is did something extraordinary you know
how difficult are these decisions that
simple elementary morality prevails over
legal considerations and so on i think
that
i hope i'm not a utopian i even like
don't you have any of these organs who
propose candidates for nobel peace prize
that would be a nice crazy movement if
there is a person who deserves
nobel peace prize today it's men or
people like that this you know why no no
i'm not bluffing here
simple ordinary people
and i'm not even idealizing him there
are many examples that i know of
ordinary people who were not anything
special they are not saints but all of a
sudden they see something like probably
he if he is the one
saw all these documents and something
told him sorry i will not be pushed more
i have to do something here this is so
precious today because it also goes
against
a note which is in a way true but it's
exploited by our enemies this idea
ideology today is cynical people are
totally duped and so on no they are not
i prefer i prefer her to play a little
bit of simple moralism from time to time
there are ethical miracles
ethical
ethical miracles there are people who
still care and so on and so on this is
very important because you know like
let's not leave this domain of a care
for simple dignified ethical ex2
agencies like catholic church and so on
who are they to talk about who are they
to talk about it we the left should
rehabilitate this i know it doesn't
sound very postmodern or clinical this
idea that there are out there quite
ordinary guys nothing special but who
all of a sudden has been a miracle do
something wonderful that's almost i
would say our only hope today
i'm sorry for that sorry for that
example don't be too mad
speaking on that uh
one of the difficulties for alleged
sources
and actually we have another one in
prison which
um has received very little recognition
which is a case of rudolf alma
who's in prison in switzerland for
allegedly revealing secret bank
information
there's no
trace to us but that is the allegation
that has been investigated um is that
if they put up their hands and say yes
yes it was me
it makes it very easy to defend them in
a moral way
it makes it very easy to shower them
with awards
um
but
until they do that yeah i don't
understand
their defense is that they didn't do it
so
um
it's very hard for for us to
um to start
praising people because inherent in that
praise is
uh we would be alleging that they are
guilty of the
of the offense speaking of banks julian
um you mentioned a while ago that you
had
a good deal of documents on bank of
america
but they haven't been released are you
planning to release them
there's a complication with those
documents and another
group of documents so we we are under
a type of
blackmail in relation to these documents
that is very
it will be dealt with over time but it
is quite difficult
to deal with at the moment so
i don't want to specify what type of
blackmail that is because it might make
it harder to
address
the situation
that it is
it is perhaps something like people
might guess
that
i you know there's a range of
possibilities and it's probably the
first or second possibility if you're if
you're guessing
well let's talk about the beginning of
wikileaks tell us about how you founded
it named it and what your hopes were at
the time and if at this point
you have been
disappointed by what you've been able to
accomplish or amazed by it
wikileaks how it started
i think
i am
amazed by it of course
i mean who couldn't be um
it's an extraordinary time that i have
lived through and to see
many of your dreams and ideals come into
practice that said um i think we're only
about a hundredth of the way there
in terms of what we have to
release and discover and collect and and
put into people's heads and uh solidify
the historical record uh we need a cable
gate
for the caa we need a cable gate for the
svr we need a cable gate or the new york
times actually
all the stories that have been
suppressed and how they've been managed
and once we start
getting that sort of volume and
concrete ties
and protect
um
the rights of everyone to communicate
with one another
which to me is is the basic ingredient
of civilized life it is
not the right to speak
what does the what does it mean to have
the right to speak if you're on the moon
and there's no one around it doesn't
mean anything
rather the right to speak comes from
our rights to know
and the two of us together someone's
right to speak and someone's right to
know produce a right to communicate and
so that is the grounding
structure
for
all that we treasure about civilized
life and by civilized i don't mean
industrialized i mean people
collaborating to not do uh the dumb
thing to instead
learn from previous experiences and
learn from each other to pull each other
to pull with each other together in
order to get through the life that we
live
in in a less adverse way
so
that quest
to
protect the historical record and enable
everyone to be a contributor to the
historical record
is something that i have been involved
in
for about 20 years in one way or another
so that means protecting people who
contribute to our shared
intellectual record and it also means
protecting publishers
and
encouraging distribution of historical
record to everyone who needs to know
about it after all
an historical record that has something
interesting in it that you can't find is
no record at all
so
that
long-term vision is something
that i developed in various ways
and i saw in around 2006
that
there was a way of
achieving justice through this process
that could could be realized using the
intellectual and
social capital that i had available
and so
that's quite a complex plan you should
perhaps read there's a couple of essays
on wikileaks to go into this uh in more
detail
so to pull all this together
[Music]
was a difficult thing to do it's um
and to plan it out and to marshal the
resources and to build
not only
an ideology that people could support
and were encouraged by and the sources
were encouraged by
but that people would defend
and it's it's one of the
i think it's extremely interesting
that although
twice
this
venue
was cancelled not this venue sorry twice
this the venue that we had rented for
this was cancelled including at the
institute uh uh for education from the
university of london under the basis it
would be too controversial
and so that's why we ended up with the
trotsky at this at this venue that
despite that
that actually
slap away zizek
myself and amy goodman have been made
managed to pack out nearly 2 000 people
in london on a saturday
at 25
pounds
a seat
so
i see that as extremely encouraging on
the one hand we have this sort of the
everyday tordry
institutional censorship
of
saying something is too controversial
therefore you can't hold it in an
institute of education
on the other hand
all of you came
and
i'm not sure that would have happened
five years ago in fact i'm pretty sure
that wouldn't have happened five years
ago
and that both of those things wouldn't
have happened five years ago
so that
when i said before that
censorship is always an opportunity
and censorship reveals something that is
positive about a
society and a society with no censorship
is in a very bad state
that this
if you like the censorship of not giving
us this venue so easily
is also related to why
you're all here it is the other side of
the coin that
people are worried that change is pop
that
change is possible
and you're here because you think the
change is possible and you're probably
right
so that's
been
a very interesting journey to see that
and i thought i was pretty cynical
and worldly
five years ago
and of course i was
simply a very young and naive fool
in retrospect
and
learning
how to
from being with inside the center of the
storm
i have learned
no not just about the structure of
government not just about how power
flows
in many governments around the world
that we've dealt with
but rather
how
history is shaped and distorted
the media
and
i think
the distortion by the media
of history
of all the things that we should know so
we can collaborate together as a
civilization
is
is the worst thing
it is
our single greatest impediment to
advancement
but
it's changing
we're we are routing around
media that is close to power in all
sorts of ways
and
but it's not a foregone conclusion which
is what makes this time so interesting
that we can rest
the internet and we can rest the various
communications mechanisms we have with
each other into the values
of
the new generation that has been
educated
by the internet
is being educated
outside of that mainstream media
distortion and all those young people
are
becoming
important
within institutions
so
maybe this is something i'll speak about
with you later amy but
um i do want to talk about
what it means
when
institutions how the most powerful
institutions
from the cia to news corporation
are all organized
at
all organized using
computer programmers using system
administrators using technical young
people what does that mean when all
those technical young people
adopt
a certain value system
and that they are in the institution
where they do not agree with the value
system and yet
actually their hands are on the
machinery
because there has been moments in the
past like that
and though it is those technical young
people
who are
the most
internet educated and have the greatest
ability to receive
the new values that have been
spread and the new information and facts
about reality that have been spread
outside mainstream media distortions
[Applause]
i feel now like that stalinist
commentator you know the leader has
spoken i provide the deeper meaning and
so on with pleasure now first i would
really like to begin with what you said
it's extremely important i have a
philosophical term for it when you moved
from right to speak right to know
communication and so on i think that as
many of you know in the history of
modern thought the first one to
formulate this was emmanuel kant in his
wonderful distinction between private
and public use of reason this
distinction is so wonderful because for
kant private use of reason is not i
gather with my friends in the kitchen of
my apartment or a pub no private use of
reason is for [ __ ] geological faculty
legal faculty political sciences where
what you are thinking debating
developing
serves a goal set up in advance by a
power structure or ideological structure
and so on for kant we here at the
distance from this hierarchic
uh political step in the sense of
establishment of course of establishing
power structural space we are the public
use of reason and why is this so
important because what i see wikileaks
as part
of a
global struggle
which doesn't concern only in the narrow
sense this domain of right to know in
the sense of right to information and so
on but even education you know you by
you i mean uk citizens here what horrors
are being made
now in the uk university reform new
privatizations and so on and so on this
is all one concerted attack on the
public use of reason it goes on all
around europe the name is so called
high education reform and the goal is
very clear
they say it it stood make
universities
more
responsive to
social life to social problems it sounds
nice what it really means is that we
should all become experts as the french
guy later minister explained to me in a
debate in paris
uh you uh
for example cars are burning in paris
suburbs what we need is psychologists
who will tell us how to control the
crowd urbanists who will tell us how to
restructure the streets so that the
crowd is easy to break up or whatever
like we should be here as a kind of
ideological
or specialist serviceman to resolve
problems formulated by others i think
this is the end of
intellectual life as we know it
and we should go here to the end you
know when all those right-wing
anti-immigrant bullshitters
are talking about uh sorry i used the
word i shouldn't yeah do it in stalin's
way put some music of some heroic
working-class song there sorry but more
seriously when we uh hear about uh oh
immigrants pakistanis muslims a threat
to judah christian civilization no sorry
the greatest asset of judeo-christian
civilization which you can even detect
it in notions of holy spirit as the
community of believers outside establish
structures it's precisely this
independent space of public
reason so i'm saying that if there is
something really to defend of the
so-called i hate the word also
judeo-christian legacy this idea of
democracy not only is this masturbatory
right to cast a vote totally isolated
but as you said
public space of debate communication and
so on then that should be our answer to
all those uh
populist anti-immigrants and so
anti-immigrant politicians and so on
not this white liberal guild or you are
you are defending judeo-christian legacy
and now we we feel guilty my god how
many bad things we did all the bad
things in the world called the result of
european imperialism okay maybe but what
we should say to them is who are you to
even speak about judeo-christian legacy
this
university reform today in uk this is
the greatest threat of to
judeo-christian legacy and so on
anti-immigrants they are the nightmare
imagine lepenian power in france and so
on that's the end of europe for me in
the sense of what is
progressive in europe so again this is
for me part of a much larger struggle
which especially with the problems to
date ecological problems for example it
is so crucial let me give you an example
which i think it's so beautifully clear
recently and that's why i would also
like to ask you if i may through you
right directly you and china not you you
use wikileaks and china because chinese
people will pay such a price for
precisely the oppression of public space
of reason where my chinese friends told
me this in
china now a month or two ago even the
government admitted the catastrophic
ecological consequences of those three
gorges then you know it's the greatest
artificial lake in the world for 250
miles 400 kilometers long now they the
government
admitted that
the problem is this one that lake is
just above some
subterranean faults where which they
move when there is an earthquake so they
admitted that the big you remember three
years ago or when the big situation or
where earthquake was if not triggered
definitely rendered much stronger
because of this and this is not
along the lines of what you must have
some proverbs like you know after the
battle everyone can be the wise general
no friends when i visited beijing
four or five years ago
my friends there told me
majority of geologists were already
warning
the government about these dangers
second thing because of this collection
of water there the effect of drought are
now much stronger felt 0.2 because the
water is too low the whole you know that
the yellow river is the main the main
transportation
line venue in china and the traffic
there is practically stopped and so on
and so on all this is
the end of public reason so now just to
uh just to
conclude just one more thing nonetheless
this is not a critical point towards you
but the point to clarify what
wikileaks can do we should not fatigize
truth as such we live in times of
incredible
ideological investments of
times when ideology is very strong
precisely because it's not even
experienced as ideology and what can
happen let me tell you a story from
israel my friends told me there
some five six years ago one of their
historians
wrote a more truthful account you know
of how also in the independence 4849 war
the israeli army did burn some
palestinian villages and so on and so on
a more balanced view and first all the
leftist critics uh had a kind of
intellectual orgasm or wonderful and so
on and then they got
a shock of lifetime when this guy said
no no no but i meant that was necessary
to do we should have done it even more
the line of this guy was we should have
thrown all the palestinians from the
west bank and we wouldn't have any
problems today
so
you know what i'm trying to say
that i disagree not with you but for
example with another person for whom i
have
respect noam chomsky a friend of mine
told me that chomsky told him recently
at lunch decade together in new york
that today all the obscenities are so
clear that we don't need any critique of
ideology we just need to tell to people
the truth no
truth must be contextualized in the
sense of what does it justify what does
it say what does it deny and so on and
so on so to really conclude this would
have been uh
my my point about
wikileaks that you are not just simply
telling the truth you are telling the
truth in a very precise way of
confronting
explicit line of justification
rationalization or whatever the public
discourse which is implicit
presuppositions it's not just about
telling the truth and this is very
important why now i conclude don't be
afraid because you know this wonderful
marx brothers
joke which i think serves perfectly as a
model of today's ideology why because
like if you listen to
if you have listened to someone like you
know that failed businessman who didn't
ruin the american army as a defense
minister donald trump's felt called no
no i read the biography of him they
prove it conclusively that my god he was
even a very stupid bad manager when he
was a it's a total meat that he was a
business genius but okay to the point
when uh
how uh
basically his cynical line about iraq
when it was discovered that there were
no weapons of mass destruction and so on
was that earth okay we were lying but we
were lying in a truthful way with a good
intention we manipulated you but this
was part of a larger strategy and so on
this is maybe the most okay intelligent
tricky and effective cynical defense of
a liar when he said okay i'm lying but
so what i openly confessed that i was
lying so in a way i'm truthful here we
should repeat that mark's brother's
saying and this is what you de facto are
doing i claim you know that wonderful
phrase from groucho marx i think when he
is playing a lawyer defending his client
and he says this guy looks as an idiot
and acts as an idiot this shouldn't
deceive you this guy is an idiot we
should say to donald trump
okay you admit you act as a liar you are
a cheater and a liar but this will not
deceive us you effectively are a cheater
and a liar we should not allow them this
space of selling their lives themselves
in a cynical way as a deeper truth this
is how ideology today functions
julian assange i wanted to ask you about
the arab spring
and about what you see as wikileaks role
in what started in tunisia unto egypt
we're seeing in bahrain yemen syria
libya
what role did wikileaks play
it's hard to disentangle but the
the story that we have back from people
who were in egypt uh and from the
newspaper al-akhbar
one of the great newspapers publishing
in the middle east out of lebanon you
lived in egypt for a time i i lived in
egypt during 2007. so i am
familiar with the mubarak regime
and
and the tensions within the egyptian
environment
actually i was
staying at that time rather unusual
circumstance
where
i
was staying in miss egypt's house
and
miss egypt's house other than having
paintings of miss egypt all throughout
was clustered right between the u.s
embassy and the british high commission
with a van outside filled with 24
soldiers in front of my front door
and so for the sort of work we were
doing this seemed to be the sort of the
ultimate
cover if you like to be right nested
amongst this
but
you know
some interesting egypt's a very
interesting place
at that time
you didn't feel
in most areas of areas of cairo
the the presence
of the dictatorship
in fact
if you look out on the streets
men
go to work they go to the cafes to have
shisha in the afternoon the pigeon boys
come out
onto the roof and there's weddings on a
saturday and a sunday
and in fact
the economic basis and the technological
basis to cairo
seemed pretty much the same as london if
you compare it to
australian aboriginals
so
to my mind actually
if if we say
that it is democracy
that rules
and manages united states or it is
democracy electoral democracy that
manages and rules london this is this is
completely ridiculous because when we
look at countries that are dictatorships
or soft dictatorships in case of
of
egypt
the day-to-day life and the
technological activities and the
patterns of behavior
for most people
are exactly the same
but it's when you when you stray into
those areas of egypt and areas of cairo
where the interior ministry is or where
the foreign ministry is uh that the the
level of paranoia and fear and and the
number of people
regarding submachine guns and so on is
increased increases
at that time
there was around 20 000
uh political prisoners of different
types in egypt
so
but remember egypt has a population of
around 80 million
so
this is always something that i am aware
of when when you have an intelligentsia
that writes
and writes about its problems because
this is the mirror image of the problem
we now have with the mainstream press
which is
writers always right to their own favor
and their own considerations and their
own self-interests
so
a country which goes from a position of
can go from a position of not treating
writers well to treating right as well
and not treating
everyone else well
by writers i mean people who have
ability to project a voice
so for those 20 000 political prisoners
in egypt they could gain no traction in
the western press
and yet
others such as in iran we hear about all
the time
it's very interesting that egypt was
perceived to be a strong ally
of israel and strong ally of the united
states
in that region and so all the human
rights abuses and political abuses that
were occurring every day in egypt
simply did not get traction and there
was one moment
where
um rather actually unusual for egypt but
perhaps a sign of the cleverness that
came to be represented in the arab
spring
where
these
20 000 prisoners
started
a strike
demanding conjugal rights
demanding that their
wires be permitted to visit them in
prison for sex
and then got some prominent mufti's to
come out and say
look
it's bad enough that these people are
political political agitators let alone
homosexual political agitators
and that is then something that was
picked up
by
the western press
because it had this this extra solicious
flavor
and
so that was my
some of my experiences
with egypt
when i lived there
later on
when we worked on cablegate
we selected
uh french partner le monde
in order to get the cables into into
french because we knew
that they would have an effect in
francophone africa
also
cables were published in early december
by al-aqbar in arabic from lebanon and
also al-masih al-um
in egypt although the material that was
published in egypt back in december
under muric was pretty soft
because of the the threats that that
newspaper was under but
al-masih al-jun pushed hard
and there was
a number of critical cables came out
about the tunisian regime and about ben
ali
now of course
the the argument that has often been
used including for example in the
electoral result that we're involved in
in kenya in 2007 is you just tell the
people
uh what's going on
and then they'll be angry about it and
they'll oppose it but actually the real
situation is much more
rich and interesting than that
rather
yes
the demos knows the population starts to
know and they start to know in a way
that's undeniable and they also start to
know that the united states knows the
united states can't deny
what was going on
inside
tunisia
and then the elites
within the country and without the
country
also know what is going and no they
can't deny so
as a situation developed where it was
not possible for the united states to
support the ben ali regime and intervene
in
a revolution in tunisia
in the way that it might have
similarly it was not possible for france
to support benelli or other partners in
the same way that they might have been
able to
also in our in our strategy in dealing
with this region
and uh our survival strategy for
cablegate
was to
overwhelm
that is we have saudi arabia for example
propping up a number of states in the
middle east um
in fact invading bahrain even to do this
but when these states have problems of
their own to deal with and political
crisis their own to deal with they turn
inwards and they can't be involved in
this prop up so
cablegate as a whole
caused these elites that prop each other
up into region within
the arab-speaking countries and
within between europe and these
countries and between the united states
and these countries
to have to deal with their own political
crisis
and not spend time giving intelligence
briefings on activists or sending in
the sas or or other
support
and activists within tunisia saw this
very quickly
i think they started to see an
opportunity
um and that information
our site
a number of wikileaks sites were then
immediately
banned by the nissan government
al-akbar was banned by the nizing
government
a hacker attack
was launched on al-aqbar many were
launched from us but we had come to
defend against them alakba was taken
down their whole
newspaper was redirected to a saudi sex
site
believe it or not there is such a thing
as a saudi sex site
and they rested it back through
involvement of the foreign foreign
ministry in lebanon and then
what i believe to be state-based
computer hackers because the degree is
the sophistication of attack came in and
wiped out all of our lack of cable
publishing efforts
the cables about tunisia were then
spread around
online
um you know in other forms uh translated
by a little internet group called tunis
leaks
and
so
present presented a number of different
facets
a sort of that everyone could see and no
one could deny
that the ben ali regime was
fundamentally corrupt
it's not that the people there didn't
know it before but it became undeniable
to everyone including the united states
and that the united states or at least
the state department
could be read that if it came down to
supporting the army or being our lead
they would probably support the army the
military class rather than the political
class so that gave activists and the
army
a belief that they could possibly pull
it off but this wasn't enough so all
that was intellectual
and and was making a difference and was
stirring things up in tunisia
and then you had this action by a 26
year old computer technician who said um
he self-immolated
on
in december
16
last year
and was hospitalized and died on january
4th
and that taking a sort of
intellectual
frustration and irritation and hunger
for change and undeniability to
an emotional physical act on the street
is then what
can change the equation but there's
other things a
sort of a a more
systemic issue that was gradually
breeding up
which is you had
aging rulers in the middle east that
whose regimes to that extent were
becoming weaker and the intellectual
management of them was decreasing
you also had
the rise of satellite tv
and
the decision
by al jazeera staff
to
film and broadcast
protest scenes in the street
so most revolutions
kick off
in
a crowd situation like this one where
everyone can you know all the time the
regime is saying
um
this voice is an outcast voice this is a
minority this is not popular opinion and
what the media does is
censor those voices and prevents people
from understanding that actually
that what the state is saying is in the
minority is in the majority and once
people realize
that their viewers in the majority then
they understand they have physically
have the numbers and there's there's no
better way to do that than in some kind
of public square which is why korea
square in
egypt was so important because everyone
could see that they had the numbers
and that's
you know this is i often perceive that
there are moments like that politically
yes the middle east was one that we
might be going through you know you saw
just before the berlin wall fell
everyone thought that it was impossible
why
i mean if that if a lot it's not that
people suddenly received a lot of new
information rather what the information
they received is that
everyone a large majority of people
had the same beliefs that they had
and people became sure of that
and then you have a sudden switch
a sudden state change and then you then
you have a revolution so
i often feel that we're
we're on the edge of that and that
alternative ways of people becoming
aware
of what their beliefs are what each
other's beliefs are is something that
introduces that
truly democratic
shift and i i've often lambasted
bloggers
as people who just want to demonstrate
peer value conformity and who don't
actually do any original news don't do
any original work
when we release original documentation
on many things
although the situation is very
interestingly improving
often we find that that all these
left-wing bloggers do not descend on a
fresh cable from panama revealing as it
did
today
that the united states has declared the
right to board one third of all ships in
the world without any justification they
do not descend on that rather they read
the front page of the new york times and
go
i disagree or i agree or i agree in my
categories
and
that is something that is sort of
that hypocrisy of saying that you care
about a situation um but not actually
doing the work is is something that has
angered me but it it does serve an
important function
the function that it serves
is
the function of the square it is to show
the number of voices that are lining up
on one side or another
before you respond i just wanted to ask
since you talked about what you released
today you also have just sued mastercard
and visa can you explain this weekend
why you did that
oh
you know
when daniel ellsberg released the
pentagon papers
actually i spoke to daniel westbrook
last night told me incredible story
about that but
did you know the new york times had
a thousand pages of the pentagon papers
one month before daniel ellsberg gave
the pentagon papers the new york times
fresh news
amazing stuff um
yeah i'll leave that aside
um so what was the question oh yes
muscat so
when daniel ellsberg released the
pentagon papers
did they suddenly change things
actually nixon was re-elected after
daniel ellsberg
released the pentagon papers the vietnam
war didn't stop
the information was very important in
all sorts of ways and it's and its
importance
over time was very important
the most important thing to come out of
the pentagon papers was the reaction to
the pentagon papers because the pentagon
papers described a situation in the past
what the past was like but the reaction
to the pentagon papers described what
was going on right now
and
it it showed a tremendous overreach by
the next linux administration various
attempts to cover things up um
and actually the new york times really
probably wouldn't have published the
pentagon papers unless they thought it
was going to be published anyway which
they which they did it was scheduled to
be published
in four months time in a book
very very interesting so
on december 6 last year visa mastercard
paypal the bank of america
western union
all ganged up
together
to engage in an economic blockade
against wikileaks and that economic
blockade has continued
since
that point so it's over six months now
we have been
suffering
from an extrajudicial
economic blockade that has occurred
without any process whatsoever
in fact the only two formal
investigations into this
one was on january 13 last year by
timothy c geithner the secretary of the
treasury
who found that there was no lawful
excuse to conduct an economic blockade
against wikileaks
the other
was by a visa subsidiary who was
handling our european payments tiller
who found that we were not in breach of
any of visas
by lines or regulations those are the
only two
formal inquiries and yet
the blockade continues it's an
extraordinary thing that we have seen
that visa mastercard western union and
so on
are
instruments of u.s foreign policy but
instruments of us of not us as in a
state operating under laws foreign
policy but rather instruments of
washington's
patronage
network
policy
so there was no due process at all
and so
over the past few months you know we
have a number of cases on so we've been
a bit distracted but over the last few
months we have built up a case against
visa
and mastercard
under
european
law
and
visa and mastercard together
own about 95
of the credit card
payment industry in europe and therefore
they have a sort of market dominance and
that means under european law they
cannot engage in certain actions that uh
to unfairly remove people from the
market speaking of other legal cases i
just wanted to ask you about what you
face next week the extradition case on
july 12th the nation magazine has done
two pieces
one is forthcoming and they quote your
new lawyer gareth pierce who is very
well known for
representing prisoners at guantanamo a
renowned human rights attorney
and tom hayden who writes the piece
interviewed many people in sweden in the
united states and sort of talks about a
feeling in sweden of an attack very much
represented by your past lawyers on the
swedish justice system and on the
integrity of the women in sweden
and he quotes gareth pierce saying that
our lawyers never attacked any
integrity of women
well he quotes gareth pierce saying the
history of this case
is as unfortunate as it is possible to
imagine
each of the human beings involved
deserves respect and consideration
and i just wanted to ask if you are
seeing this as a change of
approach with your legal team and
dealing with your possible extradition
to sweden
possibly i mean
the situation
what has happened to europe and what has
happened to sweden is is fascinating
i mean it's something that i have come
to learn because i've been embroiled in
it
but it is
intellectually
extraordinary
so we see for example
that
the european union introduced an arrest
warrant system
and that arrests foreign system to
extradite from one state of the eu to
another state of the eu
was put in place in response to 911 to
expedite terrorists to far to have fast
exhibition of terrorists
and
it introduced this
concept or rather recycled a european
union concept
of mutual recognition
this is sort of a very feel-good phrase
that
one state in the eu
mutually recognizes another state in the
eu and that sunk down into
mutual recognition between
the one court in the eu to another court
in the eu but actually what
it seems to be talking about if you
think about it
given the reality that three people a
day are extradited from this country to
the rest of europe
is a mutual recognition
of the elite
in each country in the eu
it is a
a method
of
of being at peace
so the elite in each country in the eu
has if you like made
literally a treaty
with each other
to recognize each other
and to not
complain about the behavior
now
you might say that well
okay we have justice systems in the eu
in various countries yes they they vary
in all sorts of ways some are better
some are some are some are worse
depending on your value system
but we have sunk so low that it's not
even like that anymore
the european arrest warrant talks about
the mutual recognition of judicial
authorities
so courts
but it has permitted each country to
define
what they call a judicial authority
and sweden
has chosen
to call policemen
and prosecutors judicial authorities the
whole basis of this term being used
in the original introduction european
restaurant was that you would keep the
executives separated from the judicial
system it was meant to be a natural and
neutral party
who would request exhibition and and
it's not
um so there are many
things like this that are going on in
that case
i haven't been charged
so is it right
to extradite someone to a state where
they do not speak the language
where they do not have family they do
not know the lawyers they do not know
the legal system
if you don't even have
enough evidence to charge them
you won't even come over
as we have offered many times to speak
to the people concerned
so
previous
complaints
about
these sort of problems
have led to
some inquiries in sweden
for instance the biggest swedish law
magazine that goes out to all the
lawyers had a survey on this
and one third of the lawyers responding
said that yes that these complaints
about the swedish judicial system they
truly are a problem
on the other hand it has also engendered
a situation where the
swedish prime minister and the swedish
justice minister have personally
attacked me
and said the swedish prime minister
said that i had been charged to the
swedish public when i hadn't been
so it is a delicate situation because
sweden
the sweden we have now is not the sweden
of
palm in the 1970s
sweden
recently
sent troops
recently passed the bill
to send marines into libya it was the
fifth country out to send fighter jets
into libya this this is a different
dynamic
that has happened now and
we have to be uh careful
at dealing with it so it's one thing to
sort of be con considerate of
differences
in the way various justice systems are
administered
but it is it's another to
tolerate
any difference
and i don't think any difference should
be tolerated in the eu
you know
what is it that prevents
the justice systems of eu states from
fundamentally
collapsing and decaying
we say there's mutual recognition it's
mutual recognition between the uk
and romania
and what if the romanian justice system
collapses more and more and more
who's going to account for that who's
going to scrutinize it
is it going to be some bureaucrats in
the ec that are going to scrutinize the
romanian justice system no the the only
sustainable approach to scrutinizing the
justice systems of the eu
is
the expedition process
so it is extradition lawyers and
defendants who have the highest
motivation to scrutinize the quality of
justice in
the state that they are being extradited
to and
that's a healthy system that permits
outside scrutiny and
and so can stop
european states from decaying
but the european arrest warrant system
removes that possibility
it's not
it's not
open to us
to
look at any of the facts in the case in
the expedition at all that is completely
removed all we're arguing about is
whether
the two-page request that was filled out
which literally has a box ticked rape
is
a valid document
you will land with slavery okay
first i'm so sad we don't have time to
go into it because i found this again
yet another this by this i mean this
strange mutual recognition and this
absolutely think about it what you've
heard this cut properly kafka is paradox
of being extradited without even being
charged
i mean are we aware where we are
but let's not take that path first i
cannot but
restrain from
making an obscene lovingly obscene
remark of how when you said you were
staying with that miss of egypt no i
hope there will be some american
fundamentalist
who will say ah now everything is clear
there you were seduced by that miss who
was really al qaeda agent and then you
were turned into a terrorist agent
through her to do your terrorist
activity now things are clear now okay
so let's go on with
okay yeah but one minute in this broader
christian sense where time is eternity
and so on very briefly first
that also those palestinian papers that
kind of you triggered the movement i
wonder if you agree i read i've read
them what made me so depressive is that
my liberal israeli friends were telling
me all the time listen we admit it we we
are doing bad thing of the west on the
west bank but you cannot negotiate if
they bomb you like
let's just and
if you of course
exempt gaza on the west bank there was
practically total peace the last five
six even more years the image you get
from these papers is that
there was an incredible compromising
spirit from the palestinian side
offering them practically entire
jerusalem and so on and it was
absolutely clear that it's israel which
is not interested in peace
second
first couple of points second point i
think
it's so important the exact words you
use
which make my point which confirm my
point namely how
undeniable they could no longer deny it
and so on that's important you know
again we are in this situation where i
know you know are you that you know you
know that i know but we can still play
this cynical game let's
act as if we don't know
the function of wikileaks even more
important i claim in concrete
ideological political situation then
learning us then learning to we click
something new is
to push us to this point where you
cannot pretend not
to know which is why let me give you
another example again i'm not a total
fan of obama although i still have
certain respect for him but
this is cynicism at its purest you
remember this outcry in zionist circles
where obama made the simple point that
not even exact frontiers that the basis
of peace should be the borders the 67
borders
my god
the critical reaction was as if obama
said something i don't know following
orders from al qaeda or water but this
was the official u.s policy accepted
only the obscenity of the situation was
that although this was officially the
u.s policy it was part of the unwritten
deal not to talk about it to ignore it
that's our situation here step further
egypt
i know you know what's for me and you
had hear a lot the truth about egypt
we western europeans had this normal
spontaneous racist attitude no we would
love to see a
secular democratic movement in arab
countries unfortunately all they can do
is some stupid anti-semitic
fundamentalist
nationalist whatever outburst now
officially we got exactly what we wanted
a purely secular uprising and so on and
you know how we behaved my last loving
obscene example did you see francois
tree for day and night where a guy wants
to sleep with a girl tries to convince
her for a long time then finally they
are alone because of an accident by a
lake and again he starts please let's do
it quickly we are alone here and the
girl says okay let's do it and start to
unbutton her trousers and the guy says
okay but how do you mean my god just
like that or whatever like he is shocked
we were a little bit like that
officially we wanted secular democracy
the abduction said okay i put down my
drugs and skill will have your stupid
secular democracy and you cannot get it
just like that it was such a clear
example of hypocrisy
now really to uh to finish maybe the
most important thing uh
what you already said i think amy i
think maybe this is one of the ways if
we are approaching the end to conclude
it
even if you ignore wikileaks
it changed the entire field
you it's again
even at the level of
of publishing spreading informations you
pushed things in a very formal way
to a point of undeniability nobody can
pretend that wikileaks didn't happen and
it would be very interesting to classify
all reactions to wikileaks you know as
different forms of in psychological
terms repression denial whatever some
people say formally yeah yeah but try to
neutral neutralize it like oh another
another chapter in freedom of the press
investigative journalism others say
directly terrorism i wonder
the approach i would have followed if i
were to be
on the other side would have been
something like it's basically a good
thing it's just misused by some
extremists you know and then you kind of
say precisely to save the safe core of
good core of wikileaks so what i'm
saying is that again to conclude don't
worry this is the moment of truth
wikileaks is an event not only because
of what it sees as in itself but because
nobody can ignore it it changed the
entire field the point is not to allow
to be re-normalized to remain faithful
to it
just a note um
slavoy and i will be out signing books
on the left in the lobby right
afterwards and would love to talk to you
um definitely pick up a flyer yes you do
and
end on i want to end with this question
julian tomorrow july 3rd you turn 40
years old what are your hopes for the
future
well there's there's the big future
there's the deep future
that one can long for
uh so
that that is a future where we are all
able to
freely
communicate
our hopes and dreams
factual information about the world with
each other and the historical record
is
an item that is completely sacrosanct
that would never be
changed never be modified never be
deleted and that we will steer a course
away
from orwell's victim of he who controls
the present uh controls the past so that
that is something that
is
my life long quest to do
and from all from that
um justice flows because
each
most of us
have an instinct for justice and most of
us are reasonably intelligent and if we
can communicate with each other organize
not be oppressed and know what's going
on then pretty much the rest falls out
so
that is my big hope in the short term
it is that my staff stop hassling me to
tell me to go
what i wish you to all the best is
another even more beautiful miss egypt
your birthday
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and to talk directly with authors during
our live programs
facebook.com
book tv
book tv continues now with a discussion
on the book the wikileaks files a
collection of the most important 2.3
million state department cables released
by wikileaks in 2010
author and journalist jeremy scahill is
joined in discussion by julian assange
via video link from the ecuadorian
embassy in london
to invite all of you here
this is the launch of the wikileaks
files
i'm jacob stevens i'm the director of
verso books
and we've been working on
this project with julian assange and
with wikileaks
for about four years now
um and so this is the culmination of a
lot of collaborative
editorial and political work that we're
very proud of
and we're thrilled to be able to publish
this in close cooperation with julian
assange and with wikileaks
and with his fantastic introduction
you should all get a copy if you haven't
got one on your way in
then get one on your way out
it's part of the ticket
and it has in it an amazing
roundtable discussion and analysis
of what we can really learn from this
huge
huge uh
leak of diplomatic cables and what we
can learn about the operation of u.s
empire
and u.s foreign policy from this
and i'm extremely proud to introduce
jeremy scahill
who is going to lead this conversation
with julian assange
jeremy scahill i'm sure you all know one
of the great journalists of our time the
author of blackwater and dirty wars and
of course the film
dirty wars
jeremy scale people
also i should add
one of the founders of intercept
um intercept of course carrying on the
great work of wikileaks and of edward
snowden
and you can carry on with that thank you
well it's uh it's really great to be
here i live in this neighborhood and i
never imagined i would actually be on
this stage i'm used to listening to
people who are good singers come up here
they asked me if i wanted a music stand
i thought there was a miscommunication
they thought i was going to sing it's
like the last thing any of you guys
would want to hear
um
you know i'm i'm uh i'm really honored
to be here to help
launch this incredibly important book
because we are gathered here at a time
when
there is a war in this country
not only against journalists but against
journalism
there is a war against people of
conscience within the united states
government
who dare to speak out without permission
who dare to uncover
extra judicial killings extra legal
activities by the government
unconstitutional activities that are
done in our names and with u.s
taxpayer dollars there has been a
criminalization
of independent journalism in this
country that has manifested not only in
the form of surveilling journalists
but in prosecuting whistleblowers and as
we know this administration the obama
administration which is headed by a
constitutional lawyer by training
has indicted more people under the
espionage act
than all of his predecessors
combined
the message that this administration has
sent
by going after journalists phone records
by presiding over trials of
chelsea manning who is now serving
decades in prison and continuing to be
harassed and abused while in government
military custody
presided over the ruining of the lives
of people like thomas drake one of the
original
nsa whistleblowers
by throwing people like john kiriakou in
prison who had the audacity to speak out
about torture
while at the same time allowing the
people that created the torture program
dick cheney jose rodriguez donald
rumsfeld to be on book tour
to be accepted as legitimate members of
society with something to say on the
elite talk shows on sunday
you can tell a lot about where
our morals reside in this country by
looking at what war criminals are on
book tour and what whistleblowers are in
prison
we can see a lot about who we are as a
society
now our special guest tonight
uh is not able to be here with us in
person
because of a campaign similar to those
that i've that i've described against
these whistleblowers
julian assange and i know that there is
a lot written about him in the press
there is a lot said about him in the
press his personal life is debated every
day in some publication across the world
julian assange spearheaded a project
that made it possible
for a brave whistleblower
on multiple occasions whistleblowers on
multiple occasions
to provide concrete
primary source material
on secretive government programs on
extrajudicial murders
of journalists and civilians
and provide the people of this country
and the world
with an incredible map
into a secret
bureaucracy
that in a democracy all of us should
have a chance to understand and debate
when i was reading julian's uh
introduction to this book
i was struck that it it feels like a
piece of writing from a different era
it feels like a philosophical writing
from the late 50s or early 60s
because it takes account
of history it's not written for the
twitter adi
it's not written for the short attention
span society
it delves into the history
and refers to the history of the ming
dynasty
of using papyrus as paper of having
messengers cross mountains in an effort
to map out the geography of empire and
and what he says in his essay and i
encourage all of you to read it is that
by
looking at just individual cables and
what they say about a particular country
or a particular operation that the us
was involved in
we are uh we are casting aside the
empire and just looking at the cables
the forest and the trees analogy
and and and it's it's uh noting all of
this
that unfortunately we have to welcome
julian assange by video link instead of
him sitting here on this stage but
please join me in welcoming wikileaks
founder and publisher julian assange
[Music]
and
thanks jeremy for those kind words which
is good to see you again
the last time i saw you julian we were
sharing a whiskey in the confinement of
the ecuadorian embassy there in uh in
london uh i remember about a year ago
year and a half ago maybe or is it two
yeah it could be i uh i i wanted to uh
to start off there's a lot to talk about
here i i want uh to not forget that we
are talking at a moment when chelsea
manning of course is still in the
crosshairs of the government edward
snowden is of course in exile and other
whistleblowers that have not
yet been taken by the government across
the spectrum are quite possibly out and
in our midst and facing persecution in
the future but i did want to ask you
about the latest on your
current situation there's been
speculation over the past uh months that
you were potentially going to leave the
embassy
that statute of limitations have run out
in some of the cases against you
in sweden but i wanted to give you a
chance in your own words to address
people here and i'll have you know we
have a packed crowd here
in brooklyn new york
just let us know what's going on with
you what's the latest on your case what
are your thoughts about what's going to
happen in the coming months with you
okay it's it's going to be
fantastically boring and a bit technical
i am i'm of course sick to death of the
whole issue as you can imagine uh but
okay
uh i've been detained now
uh for
five years uh without charge uh in
prison and the house arrest
and then in this embassy that's without
any publicly revealed charge there's a
possibility
my washington lawyers say almost a
certainty that there's a sealed
indictment in the united states but
otherwise there's no charges we have
about a dozen different legal cases
around the world about half a dozen
criminal cases
so those are united states
sweden
criminal cases that we have taken
offensive criminal cases
in iceland in denmark in sweden in
germany additional criminal cases
against
me in australia
and
saudi arabia so we have a lot going on
that doesn't include the civil cases
that we have going in relation to the
unlawful banking blockade
that is being
constructed against us by visa
mastercard paypal bank of america
western union diners club discover jcb
and swiss post finance
we've defeated most of that banking
blockade okay coming up to the present
moment
the status now
in the united states is
there is a pending uh prosecution
uh for
espionage conspiracy to commit espionage
uh computer fraud and abuse
which contain the computer point of view
that contains a mini espionage act
conversion which is
stealing government property
and general conspiracy
that's quite that's a charged spectrum
we don't know how many charges
of each type we just know the types
that information came out because
the us government has been
sending warrants to a variety of service
providers in the united states including
google it's managed to get a number of
gag orders on google but some of those
have been overturned and so as a result
we have the warrants
for about
six of our people six of our journalists
that
the united states has served that on now
very interestingly there was a case in
u.s federal court
in dc earlier this year
in march and a judgment in that case uh
related to us and
we together with epic the electronic
privacy information center in washington
dc we're trying to understand whether
the us government had been illegally
surveilling
our supporters
in the united states
and
freedom of information requests were
filed in relation to that the doj and
fbi has been battling this out for about
two years
and the judgment found
that
the wikileaks case the case against me
is effectively a state secret in the
united states that is the us government
argues to even reveal a single line a
single word out of the hundred thousand
something pages that the doj and fbi has
in their pending prosecution would be to
harm
that pending prosecution and to harm us
national security so as a result that
series of freedom of information act
requests is restricted but further
around another 500 freedom information
act requests filed by us by our lawyers
by other journalists in the united
states and other civil rights groups are
also held back so there's a
it's like a hoover dam
uh
blocking off a torrent of documents all
under the excuse that there is a pending
uh prosecution uh of me
and
so it leads to interesting
we might we might have shot ourselves in
the foot a bit politically insofar as
if the case is dropped in the u.s then
suddenly this dam breaks open and uh
something like a hundred thousand
documents into the us persecution of
wikileaks come out uh so
politically they have to keep the case
going
and you know what what would um
just game out this scenario for a second
what what is your logic for not
just exiting the embassy and saying i'm
going to challenge all of this uh both
from the united states end of things and
the swedish end of things and i realized
those those two things have have
different legal repercussions for you in
answering this but um you know you you
certainly have never been shy about
challenging the empire challenging the
us government you had prominent u.s
politicians saying you should be
assassinated
in a drone strike you were portrayed as
a threat to u.s national security by
very powerful current officials
what what is stopping you from
stepping outside of the embassy and
saying i am going to face all of this
head-on and if you want to put me on
trial in the united states you're going
to have the trial of the century because
i'm going to have the best lawyers and
you're wrong and and i'm right and i
have justice on my side what's to stop
you from doing that julian
well i've thought about it
uh presently the uk
sweden refuses to guarantee not to
excite me to the united states the uk
also refuses to say whether they have
already received u.s extinction order or
not and we know that sweden was already
in informal talks about extraditing to
united states which was published in
london independent
well
we have thought about it
it is perhaps something to do at the
right political time if we can be
convinced
that there would be a fair process in
the united states but just like edward
snowden there cannot be a fair process
in the united states let me explain why
the us government has been running
admits to have run a grand jury against
us now for five years
in alexandria virginia
alexandria virginia is the hotbed
of the national security state
it is in the catchment area for the jury
pool
of
cia
pentagon
[Music]
the department of homeland security and
so on
it is the largest single concentration
of u.s government workers
and there's a that's not by coincidence
in fact uh the u.s government tries to
make sure that all cases
in involving national security claims
are held in alexandria virginia which
has what they call there the rocket
docket
and pushes cases very fast
and you've got a jury pool
where you have significant problems in
finding enough jury members on your side
there's also a special rule that says
you can't get rid of a jury member
because of what their spouse does
the the one of the things that that
amazes me about your
reality is that
whenever people start to write off
wikileaks as irrelevant you somehow seem
to get your hands on more documents
for instance the bounty you put recently
on on the on the tpp and the fact that
you guys were able to affect that debate
while the founder of the organization is
stuck in a handful of small rooms inside
of an embassy in london with it without
divulging
any you know methods or sources
how do you see
the ongoing relevancy or relevance of
wikileaks in the current era what what
what is it that you hope to achieve
even though you are stuck talking to us
on a video screen and and limited in
your movements what what is it that you
hope to achieve and how is it that
you're able to still
get documents
there's a frown on my face because
jeremy you sound like you're being
digitized and placed underwater
on mars if that is at all possible
dick cheney is in the room that's why
uh so i'm can you hear me clearly
yeah we hear you perfect
okay so why they try and fix your audio
i didn't understand the gist of that
question
um
but i just the short the short a little
bit why they fix it
can you hear me julian
it's super it's super super bad uh okay
okay so i just want to say i can make a
dedication
while waiting for that to be fixed
so
i'd like to dedicate
this book here it is
and it's us launch
to michael ratner
the present emeritus
of the center for constitutional rights
michael's a very dear friend of mine and
chief
of the wikileaks legal team
in the united states
and to some degree uh this book could
not be written without him in the sense
that uh he's provided me with legal
cover
which has given me enough time uh to be
able and security so it's a difficult
situation here enough security uh to be
able to write the book
he's a bear with a very sore head uh at
the moment so
uh michael we wish you were here
and i'm sure that's
is also felt by a number of other people
that i know are in the audience
and julian just just so you know i just
want to share with people here uh if you
if you don't know michael ratner is one
of the
uh the greatest freedom fighters in the
modern history of of this country uh
litigated the first challenges to the
guantanamo prison
not just post 9 11 but actually when
thousands and thousands of haitians
were taken to guantanamo in the 1990s
and were being systematically
stigmatized as uh
dangerous to america because of the
potential for
hiv aids and and and michael has been a
uh just an incredible
fighter for
freedom around the world
and he is
at present in a battle for his life
um and
i just i saw him the other day and his
spirits are very high he definitely
wanted to be here tonight uh and i think
it would it will mean the world to him
to know that people thought of him here
and brought his uh name into this room
so
keep him in your in your thoughts and
your hearts because
michael ratner is important to so many
uh causes around the world uh julian are
you able to hear me now
loud and clear okay so what basically
what i was asking before is how you have
managed to stay
relevant despite the fact that you are
stuck in a few rooms you still get
documents you had the bounty on the tpp
that produced results uh you managed to
shift that debate and impact that debate
uh and it seems like when people are
trying to say oh well wikileaks was just
the manning stuff or just iraq and
afghanistan you somehow always manage to
pop up with new documents and i'm just
wondering without i don't want you to
divulge any sources or methods but how
is it that you're able to do that given
that you are where you are right now
well i can divulge the sources and
methods quite easily
um
sheer bloody mindedness
on the one hand
uh and on the other hand having a pretty
good team
um
around me of people
in my organization so that's
i mean we can go for further afield and
of course we have legal support and we
have a bunch of donors in uh in the
community and sources uh still believe
in us
it is
is interesting to try and pull it off it
is quite it is quite hard work i should
say
right around this embassy right now
there's
around
about seven
uniform police and about the same number
of covert
police in the
covert action surveillance team that it
operates around this building
uh interestingly it's done a deal
with harrods which is a very famous
department store here which is owned by
the qatar sovereign fund that owns most
of the surrounding buildings it's around
the embassy it's not a deal to emplace
their surveillance teams uh in those
buildings that harrods own uh 24 hours a
day we managed to get hold
of the
of those documents
the budget spend
just by the police surveillance alone
not including gchq not including mi6
runs to 20 million
dollars so far surveilling me
in the embassy it operates at about 15
uh thousand dollars a day it's it's the
one area where i've been able to gain
political traction here in the uk uh
that so much money is being spent
harassing someone who hasn't even been
charged
i remember how how ridiculous it was
when uh when i came in to see you uh
there's there's police on the steps
there and they they just barely give
your visitors enough space to get by
them it's almost like they want someone
to bump their shoulder but then there's
this cartoonish surveillance van that is
right outside of one of the
of the windows is that an actual real
thing or is that just sort of like a
prop to to like kind of mess with you
well it's a fan with a question actually
the surveillance there's different parts
of the surveillance there's some that's
not visible to people who are going past
it
maybe actually about two-thirds is not
visible to the public then there's a
very public component
where large conspicuous surveillance
bands are parked in front of the embassy
and there's a uniform police presence as
well that's uh something that is done
for public relations purpose
when there's negative press on how much
it's costing for example uh that
retreats
uh and they park in the in the side
alleys and then once that wears off
they're back again but it it's
the very visible component is designed
to be visible
right i mean it seems it seems like it's
meant to send a message um
there have been some uh reports in the
media recently uh about your position
vis-a-vis the ecuadorian government uh
and i'm i'm wondering if you still
are confident in your relationship with
president correa
and the foreign minister of ecuador uh i
don't know the veracity of some of the
reports but there were purportedly uh
the purported documents not very very
not high veracity okay so that's why i
mean i don't know if people saw this but
i wanted to ask you about it because it
got a lot of traffic and i think you you
should have the opportunity to address
this the short of it was that there were
a number of news reports that basically
portrayed a scene where where the
internal staff of the embassy was in
conflict with you and that you were
there because of the grace of president
correa and that a lot of others don't
want you to be in that embassy can you
address some of these reports and that
are based purportedly on leaked
government documents of ecuador
sure it's it's not simply a matter of
political will
obviously
a government needs political will to
enforce its laws it is a matter of law
uh ecuador is a party to the 1951
convention of refugees and the caracas
convention amongst other conventions and
it has activated those conventions in
this process
when i won my asylum case with ecuador
and as such it has a
international legally binding obligation
uh to make good uh on the asylum and
that's a matter of okay it's a matter of
law but it's also a matter of
uh
national
concern
you know it's a
ecuador would be seen to be remiss in
terms of its asylum obligations if it
broke that
halfway through now does does that mean
um that there are factions uh in ecuador
outside the government and some inside
the government they have a different
position yes it does
and so we do have to keep an eye on what
the uh domestic politics are not so much
in terms of would it mean that
they would violate their convention
obligations
but more in terms of
for example
how much support there is
in the embassy uh giving me for example
access to this high-speed line which
we're doing this talk uh for at the
moment
right and that there are there i want to
get for a moment in a moment to what
happened to president evo morales
airplane
when the u.s government was hunting
edward snowden but one brief follow-up
on this
would you accept the post of ecuador's
ambassador to the united nations if
offered by president correa
it's an interesting question if i said i
would accept it now maybe i wouldn't
maybe it wouldn't be offered
that's uh okay all right fair enough a
very a very interesting
um situation where in science we can
comment about the weather for example
and the weather doesn't change
but in
politics and human society
you can comment on some feature of it
and then it changes uh because of your
comments
okay fair enough mr potential ambassador
um
wikileaks recently put out a statement
trying to clarify uh some of the events
that occurred when edward snowden was in
transition
moving from hong kong ultimately ending
up in moscow and of course
we know from your own account also from
laura poitras's film citizen 4 that you
very much were
involved with strategizing around that
and helping to facilitate
edward snowden actually being able to
get on a plane with some form of
documentation i have two questions about
it but the first i want to ask you so we
don't muddy the waters here is
we all i think remember when the reports
emerged that evo morales the president
of bolivia who has been a very fierce
critic of the united states throughout
his time in office and before his
airplane while it was traveling through
european airspace was forced to
land on direct orders from the united
states can you explain
uh given that you were directly involved
at the time with that reality on the
ground with edward snowden what your
understanding is of what happened with
abel morales's plane and the united
states government the the reasoning was
that they thought that edward snowden
may be on the plane that was what was
reported
sure um
look we saw edward snowden was in a
difficult position in hong kong
and
how were we able to see that how was i
able to see it well because i've been
detained without charge for five years
and i've also seen chelsea manning and
jeremy hammond
go through their cases in the united
states and
watched and observed them closely i've
come to know
far too much about the espionage act and
also
how the 1951 refugee convention works
and so on
so
i
read
the
hong kong
extradition
act and the hong kong bail act
and contacted
some very good sources that we had
developed in hong kong
and also in china in relation to the
will of the
chinese politburo china has
a foreign control of foreign affairs
function of hong kong domestically it
doesn't have a formal control of hong
kong but in terms of its foreign affairs
function
it does have
a if you like a veto power
hong kong's relationship to china is
very much like say a bermuda's
relationship to the united kingdom is
so
the
chinese
politburo did not have the will
to
intervene on the edward snowden case
and step in
to protect him
the hong kong government
our sources informed us were going to
conduct things very strictly by the book
they weren't going to give evidence any
breaks
but neither were they going to act
corruptly in relation to the united
states what's strictly by the book means
for hong kong
in terms of expedition requests from the
united states
is that the person who is going through
the expedition process
is
imprisoned during the whole process so
that's
point number one point number two in
relation to asylum applications within
hong kong uh hong kong
uh has a very poor record in relation to
the percentage of people who apply for
asylum that it grants uh asylum about uh
one percent
uh furthermore uh
in the
past few years that we studied it had
never done it uh for someone from the
west
therefore
we thought that edward snowden should
leave and go somewhere that he was more
likely
to receive asylum
and we engage in a variety of
negotiations with our diplomatic
contacts that we developed from my
situation and also in relation to us if
you like specializing on diplomacy for a
while
and i managed to secure him asylum
offers
and formal offers
from venezuela
from ecuador from
nicaragua
and
publicly
bolivia was making some good noises as
well
now then there was
we routed him
in a safe path
to latin america safe path obviously
doesn't go hawaii through hawaii so
you've got to go over the top and going
over the top
means going through russia
we also secured uh in russia that russia
would not exercise him to united states
before we had even put him on that plane
to make sure that he had um a secure
route the whole way
and we put him on a russian carrier
aeroflot in case there was any kind of
interference with the pilot
now
once he was in
russia
waiting for his transit flight to cuba
the us government canceled his passport
that's a one of the great
uh
own goals diplomatic owned goals
of the state department uh
this century was to cancel snowden's
passport why he was in russia
i guess some more conspiratorially
minded might suggest that
it was intentional
in relation to the pr damage that it
might inflict on edward snowden to be in
russia
but i think it was most likely that they
had started a bureaucratic process of
cancelling his passport because they
wanted to entrap him in hong kong
and they just
got their timing
wrong and ended up counseling why he was
in moscow okay so he was in moscow and
then we looked for well how can we get
him out of moscow without a diplomatic
sorry without a passport because the
airplanes won't take him
commercial airliners won't take him
and we noticed that there was an oil
conference
in moscow and president maduro
was going to be there amongst other
presidents and one of those other
presidents was even president evo
morales
now
we then reached out our feelers to
maduro who had already
given informal and maybe even by that
stage public
offer of asylum
to snowden
but
we decided that because there was so
much surveillance that in this
communication
our code word for maduro
uh would be morales
because we were so surveilled
and and we had lawyers involved and
non-technical people who couldn't really
uh communicate themselves
and then evo
made a joke where he was in russia at
this oil conference he wrote president
eva morales uh joked that at the end of
the interview that well he was off to
meet snowden now it was just a joke
anyway these things seem to have
combined the interceptions of us and
this joke by morales
and the u.s intelligence services put
two and two together and made 22
and
decided that they then had to expend
vast amounts of political capital
ringing up the countries of western
europe and trying to close their
airspace
uh to a presidential jet flight from evo
morales
which they did
and spain
france and portugal
closed the airspace incredibly uh to a
presidential jet flight because u.s
intelligence had asked them to and done
so without any legal or administrative
process and then the moralist flight
took off
and
tried to go into
its overflight path to refuel in the
canary islands to go off
to bolivia
i couldn't do so because the airspace
had been closed and was forced to land
uh in vienna
uh and then
there was a 12
hour process where president morales was
stuck in the airport waiting lounge of
vienna because he couldn't get the
clearance anywhere else now a
presidential jet
is
protected under the vienna convention
that's the convention that in fact
protects me in this embassy it surrounds
uh
territory and
presidential jets are listed as
diplomatic territory so you had a
violation enormous violation of the
vienna convention
in vienna
now this really sealed edward snowden's
successful asylum application uh when
eventually became clear it was too
dangerous to take any other option uh in
russia because what could be the russian
response
to this downing of president evo morales
flat
the only response that they could give
to seem like a credible country
is that if he asked for snowden asked
for asylum
then they would accept
the
asylum request and that's
what ended up happening so this
incredible diplomatic own goal
led to this
bullying of western europe which
provided the ultimate proof that edward
snowden was being politically persecuted
which is what ended up giving him
asylum
i love the vienna convention being
violated in vienna that's it
you should use that one more julian
um
you know i i'm a glutton for punishment
so i read a lot of uh right-wing uh
former intel people on twitter
uh
and uh and i i wanted i wanted to
because i i think it's important for to
have you address this head-on i want to
paint for you a picture of sort of what
these people say about you and your
relationship to edward snowden and and
just have you address it once and for
all so that there is a response because
they they seem to think that they have
stumbled upon some dark secret
by
stringing together innocuous parts of
sentences you and snowden have both said
to create a very fantastical conspiracy
theory and it goes something like this
you are basically an asset of russia's
fsb
and the the russian
intelligence services and and that
through your connections to the russian
fsb and other intelligence services you
were able to facilitate a situation for
edward snowden
where he would be given safe passage by
putin and the fsb and the kgb
where he would then become an fsb asset
as you already are
once he was safely in an fsb safe house
somewhere in moscow and that snowden has
just been
giving the russians all of america's
deepest secrets that he accessed while
he was at the cia the nsa etc
what is your response to all of this
beyond probably a funny joke that you're
going to make i would actually like to
hear a serious response to that uh
i'm not sure it deserves a serious
response but uh
uh
you're talking about a a conspiracy
theory that's pushed by the nsa dick pic
guy right
this is schindler's dick yes
this is a
some a guy john schindler
uh he he will he'll be orgasmic that his
name has been mentioned i can't believe
you've given him the satisfaction yeah
he'll be absolutely orgasmic but um
uh who was a who brags
um about having worked for the nsa for
10 years and is now a professor or was
until very recently a professor
at a naval warfare college in the us
and he runs something called 20
committee which is actually just his bog
and he posits
these conspiracy theories what is what
is interesting about them
um i should explain the joke i won't
explain a joke directly because it's
it's a bit tordry but the the reason
that he's called the dick pic guy you
can
just search for twenty community uh uh
and gorka or john schindler and gorka
i don't recommend doing this if you want
to keep your dinner down yeah yeah you
you need to have a an unseen button on
your eyes
um
okay so anyway he's been pushing that
that's not that's not actually very
interesting at all um
uh what is interesting
is
because there's plenty of trolls on
twitter
what is interesting is
the people who pick it up
yes
and one of those just recently
was
one of the governors
of the broadcasting board of governors
the bbg
and the bbg
is the us government's official
uh
propaganda
funding organ
so it funds voice of america it runs
radio free asia and so on uh to the tune
of about a billion dollars per year
anyway this governor has been
spreading that
around the place and it made me
think well i know what the
broadcasting board of governors does
more or less but maybe we should look in
our cables to see
if there's anything more on it and i
came across a fantastic cable
from the congo from the us ambassador
there
written
in 2008 2009
calling for
a psyops intervention
uh in the congo
that's
one of the most interesting things that
comes out of this constellation analysis
of the cables is the role of u.s
embassies now you think the role of u.s
embassies is more or less to
go to diplomatic hostile parties maybe
occasionally to provide cover diplomatic
cover
for some cia agents
but negotiate trade deals and so on you
think that's
basically what they're about that's not
at all true the the state department and
u.s embassies play a unique role out of
all the bureaucracies in the united
states
[Music]
maybe
only the
treasury
is can be
equated in a similar way the treasury of
course provides money
for all the other instant government
institutions in the united states the
state department
provides physical housing and lobbying
for all the major elements of u.s
national power
in fact more than 27 different agencies
are housed
in u.s
embassies
and the largest u.s corporations
also get access to u.s embassy meeting
rooms and also special advisors to act
as
political advisors
and trade negotiators for them
so for example
u.s embassies
most nearly all of the larger ones have
national security agency monitoring
equipment
[Music]
many of them
have
to hold that thought a second military
it's saying the connection is unstable
sorry julian you were just describing
the last thing we heard was how you were
describing the nsa uh surveillance gear
that is placed oftentimes on the top of
embassy so
u.s embassies
are like a rotary club
some might say an evil rotary club
and
in that clubhouse
is not simply the state department the
clubhouse is run by the state department
but it is the other major elements of
u.s national power
including the marines and army and air
force and cia and
department of homeland security and so
on and the largest u.s corporations
although they really have a permanent uh
station there they are given access to
meeting rooms and political advisors and
assistants making deals
and the largest ones in fact the u.s
embassy sort of goes out of its way
proactively to spruce them especially
arms contracts
so that's
something very interesting that you get
from a constellation analysis
of the cables that we have published
more than 2.7 million cables now more
than 2 billion words
in fact we've
been publishing
even this year 500 000
diplomatic cables
okay so go back to congo the u.s
ambassador to the congo
put in a request for
a psyops intervention
which he had constructed the plan of
in the congo to beef up support for the
government
and so that included
cia should come in
and
the
broadcasting board of governance should
come in as part of this
psychological operations intervention uh
to boost up
the fortunes of the government of the
congo
against the opposition
but how does that relate to the issue of
the question i asked about fsb i don't
want to leave the door open on this
because it's not just it's not just john
schindler i mean he he is a reasonable
person
fsb that's
i'm not sure what
more one can say about this you can you
can you can look at how they've put
together their conspiracy theory their
conspiracy theory is that
because i said
that i advised edward snowden to take
the russian offer of asylum because it
was in my opinion
uh
he was
much safer in russia physically and
over a several year period
i don't believe that he
i thought that the risks were too high
in latin america that he would
uh
be kidnapped or possibly even killed in
the process of attempting to kidnap him
as a variety of reasons for that the
weakness of latin american intelligence
services the the nature of their land
borders
and that they have democratic
governments
that shift wildly in character
between one election cycle uh and the
next
but he was absolutely focused
on the
rhetorical
counter-attack to nsa mass surveillance
and didn't want
uh
accus there to be any accusation that he
was a russian spy
which he thought would be used to
rhetorically
undermine his critique
so despite the risks he was intent
on going to latin america and so i said
okay fine we will try and arrange that
if that's what you what you want my
advice is that that is a significant
risk but we'll try and do it anyway
and and i i should say just for the
record i mean i i i think that those
allegations are ludicrous i mean i i
personally have spoken with snowden
about this and and his his views and
what he's done in russia
are completely antithetical to the
conclusions drawn by those people but
i'm so sick of seeing that line that i
wanted to raise it here
which i guess i should also
mention
you know the national security agency
they should give us a massive bonus
um we made sure when edward snowden
um
entered onto that plane
that he was not carrying any laptops
we made sure of that because we knew he
was passing through russia
and we did we didn't want
him to get stuck in russia on his way
somewhere else we'd want to create if
you like any attractive bait uh that
might
uh compromise
uh that situation
right don't let facts get in the way of
those conspiracy theories though you
keep making that mistake um the i we're
going to get to audience uh
questions in in a moment but uh i wanted
to ask you about your introductory essay
of this uh book cause i i i found it
fascinating and i found it to be of a
different style of presentation
and i thought it was a it's actually a
remarkable piece of writing and and
maybe you can walk people through
uh this sort of geography of empire that
you describe as being told through not
one or two documents or a selection of
them but but as a body of documents and
sort of why you think this book
is is so important to understanding the
impact of what uh chelsea manning did or
that we understand
that she did from her own
words in revealing these cables and
other cables that you have published at
wikileaks
well i had a great frustration
with the media reportage of the early
cables that we published the
alleged chelsea manning cables
and we had a deal with over 110
different media organizations had
contractual relationships over 110 so
we're able to
look at the different
biases in different different regions
and even across different organizations
and sometimes even the different editors
and lots of cables were sensitive
either through selection or directly
the new york times scandalously censored
one of our 62 page cables
about
nuclear weapons in a run
down to
one paragraph
sorry down to 20 well 26 words
from 62 pages
which
were the only 26 words which went to
line
went along with the line of the thesis
of the story that they were trying to
push which was that iran could whack
europe
soon enough with a nuclear weapon the
rest of the cable spoke in a different
almost completely different direction to
that
okay so i was irritated with the
reportage for that reason and because of
the
shallowness of it um that
you know there was a rush between
journalists and not to criticize them
too much but that you know they're the
news journalists so they do things
quickly
they search for some famous names um
and they find some scandalous comment or
some hypocrisy
and they write a story and
the sort of a habit was developed
amongst cable journalists
of doing that
okay so there needed to be something
deeper and i fully expected that that
deeper approach
uh looking at the
relationships between countries and how
the state department worked
as a
an organism and how the us worked in its
modern form was it a modern empire not
like the roman empire or like the
british empire but was it a modern
empire and if so what kind of modern
empire was it i expected that
academics would do that because
we have produced
the single most important
repository of international relations
primary source repository
covering uh 40 years uh 2 billion word
corpus of information
easily searchable well indexed and so on
it's the natural thing to go for the
first thing you could go for in fact
many investigative journalists uh even
just many political journalists it's one
of the first things that they look for
when they see a name that they haven't
come across before
in international politics what do the
cables say about them
but it didn't happen uh english speaking
academia in the united states
seemed extremely shy
uh suspiciously shy
about how it was engaging
with this
incredible archive this 30 000
volume
archive of how
the most
significant international organ that the
united states has
actually operates in practice to
administer uh the parts of the world
where it has an influence which is most
[Music]
okay
that was contrasted with other journals
in other parts of the world
concentrating on international relations
in this asian languages in spanish
languages
in slavic languages
and in german and french
where there is decent coverage and in
the courts so the el mastery cia
kidnapping case for example
six
of those cables were cited in the
judgement now mastery
is a completely innocent
even the cia admits that completely
innocent german citizen was snatched off
the streets and
detained
um and
tortured and then dumped on
this uh street
in albania
anyway eventually his case came for the
european court of human rights those
cables were used as evidence
chagos island's case
uses evidence people have been
freed from pakistani prisons based on
the cables
relitigation of
some of the
cia interventions in spain as a result
of
the cables there's about 30 000
citations of the cables in
various papers
including
once you get out of the field of
academic relations
journals inside the united states by us
authors
for example in epidemiology epidemiology
of war
in computer uh
in computational linguistics which is
how you look at
how you look at language and there's
there's so many words in this two
billion word corpus it's a great thing
for people interested in language
to study lots and lots of these being
done
even in the united states even in u.s
journals even with u.s authors so it
clearly wasn't simply the legal risk
and
u.s journalism organizations uh
use cables about you know about once a
day there is something published in the
u.s press that is derived from
that massive cable set
okay
what is the largest
organization in the united states that
deals with the international relations
at an academic level it is the
international studies association now
the international studies association is
viewed by the state department by the
white house is actually relatively
left-leaning
but it controls
five big
academic relations journals the number
one of which is international studies
quarterly
and there's one citation in the past
five years
to
information derived from the cables in
that journal
and the editor was asked about this
just uh in december last year by an
academic who was studying what the hell
is going on
with u.s academic journals not citing
wikileaks cables and the editor
responded that the editors are in an
untenable position
uh because
there's a rule which there are to be no
citations
uh and that's because of legal
supposedly because of legal fears but
that policy will not change until the
isa
this overarching organization
in the united states changes its policy
so
and i thought okay well that's the
answer
english speaking academia is not going
to
study these properly because it is
scared
scared for legal risks and as it turns
out
much more scared the participants
of not gaining security classifications
or not gaining contracts with the state
department or the us government if their
name is on something like that
so we had to do it ourselves and
that's what we've done
now i hope that people
will eclipse it we have 17 authors a lot
of very skilled authors in this book a
specialist in their field
but in particular chapter
chapter 4 is a discussion of how we did
it
uh and how to search the cables and how
to understand this incredibly rich
uh repository of state history um
relatively recent state history
how to do that and write these sort of
books and articles yourself
and it's interesting to note and i'll
just say to people there's a microphone
here unfortunately there's only one
microphone so if if people are
interested in asking
julian a question um
you can line up here and we do ask that
it be a question because it's very late
julian's time and and we're on somewhat
of a limited time frame here but the
microphone is here if people want to
line up and and prepare to ask questions
it's interesting to note julian that um
the the new york times which
published a lot of material based on
the bravery of a whistleblower
and sold a lot of papers and gained a
lot of notoriety as a result of being
one of your original partner publishing
partners
on multiple projects in fact
had to be shamed into covering chelsea
manning's
trial arguably one of the most important
trials in modern american
history
by alex o'brien and other independent
journalists who were doggedly there
every day reporting on it
we joined a lawsuit along with with you
at wikileaks and other news
organizations uh to challenge the
secrecy of those proceedings um and and
to try to gain the right to just have a
transcript of the proceedings and event
and what that ended in is the government
saying okay you can have someone
transcribe it but you have to pay for it
um and and it just it was there was a
deafening silence
on the back end of all of this when
someone actually was
uh did have their uh their livelihood
their freedom their liberty put into the
crosshairs of the most powerful state in
the world so maybe you can comment and i
know you've had
battles with
the guardian publicly with the new york
times about how they've treated you or
how they've treated wikileaks maybe you
could address that disconnect between
the way they cover
the consequences your case chelsea's
case and the way they use the documents
i've become philosophical about it
i was very pierced off at one stage
we had contracts for example and the
guardian
broke those contracts in fact every
single
of those
julian you're breaking up a little bit
let's
let's let's wait for the yeah
hold on julian we we lost you there for
a minute you the last thing you said
that we could understand was that you
had contracts with these entities the
guardian new york times
we had contracts and the guardian broke
every single clause of those contracts
the guardian editor has moved on now he
was responsible then the
awful editor of the new york times bill
keller
quite interesting to trace his history
in our cables actually he's he's awful
even 30 years back um
he's moved on and margaret sullivan a
very good public editor
at the new york times
also draw attention to the problems with
the time discoverage of the chelsea
manning case
yeah what what you should understand is
that large institutions like that
um
have only interests they don't have
allies
just like states
and they're very careful at dealing with
each other and dealing with states
they're armed to the teeth
with
giant libel cannons
so
when they get into a fight now they have
this ability to fire these liable
cannons and be very damaging uh to the
reputation of a state uh organization or
individual and so they circle around
each other and act in quite a diplomatic
way
with each other when they're dealing
with large institutions now
uh the new york times in relation to our
collaboration uh
when it's pac
ants
once the heat started in response to the
cable publications
now you could say
maybe it's too close to the very
interest that it should be policing i
will accept that as well in your
times in various
respects
has become too close to the
organizations the
various aspects of his government that
is meant to be scrutinizing
um
but
i think it was mostly fear
they saw this very intense reaction
coming
and they decided
that they didn't want to
have it hit them and therefore someone
needed to be the full guy
and so all that incoming firepower they
didn't hold the journalistic line
they simply directed that incoming fire
on to us and in fact on to me personally
and
actually
wrote against us
and
try to make life very difficult uh for
me and for our publications uh by
attacking us
and in that way distancing themselves
and so saving their own skins
that was quite clear they were horrified
about
being called a partner explicitly in the
publication they explicitly
requested that they not be called that
why is that
well because one man's partnership is
the dojs department of justice
conspiracy the flow of collaboration the
flow of information back and forth uh
looks very similar to a flow of
conspiracy back and forth and new york
times is petrified of that
but instead of having i don't know
it
enough
institutional strength to resist that it
felt that it had to create a full guy
for it and so it pushed all that
incoming firepower directly onto us
and to keep that distance
it decided uh to not cover
the
manning trial
you broke up a little there you're
saying they decided not to cover the
chelsea manning trial certainly we lost
you there julian for the last part of it
maybe
yeah they decided they decided to only
not cover the chelsea manning trial uh
until they were beaten up about it
but uh
the chelsea manning trial you know
forget loyalties forget loyalties to an
alleged source the chelsea manning trial
was the single most important
journalism-related trial
free speech related trial
in the last 20 years without a doubt
also
it was
the largest ever
u.s military trial the largest ever
took the longest time
was largest in size and that is
at least since
the civil war so that is a statement not
by me but by the prosecutor
in that trial afterwards
about
june this year
and it's a it's a damning metaphor for
the whole thing that you had the most
powerful media institutions in the
country
uh whether intentionally or
unintentionally colluding with the
government to shroud the entire thing
in
utter secrecy and only because of and
again i keep reiterating this a handful
of independent journalists
who were not working for
money or for huge publications just
refuse to let silence win at the end and
it shows the power of independent
uh voices of independent journalism and
independent journalists who often do
work harder than their corporate
counterparts and aren't swayed by the
powerful that's absolutely correct uh
alexa o'brien in particular was very
dogged uh throughout that whole process
right and she deserves a lot of credit
okay julian we have some people here
that are gonna uh ask you questions and
i know your time is limited so we'll try
to move through it quickly and maybe we
can ask people asking questions to be
succinct and also
uh if you can cut to the chase of the
most important parts of your answer then
we can get through as many people as
possible so
all right go ahead
hi julian my name is caroline thanks so
much for speaking with us today um as
all of this points out even though the
journalism was created as a way to check
government the us government is
incredibly powerful and so in an ideal
world
what would you say should be the role of
the us government within the
international order what should be the
role of the state department and what
should be the role of u.s embassies
well
a world with human beings in it will
never be an ideal world um
but let's
look at whether things can be adjusted
i'm i'm under no illusion that if
russia
had the same expanse more than 1400
military bases in more than 120
countries
uh
that would be a nicer empire uh all the
chinese chinese given that what's
happened the culture probably
less militarized
but maybe
more conservative in other respects
the problem isn't the united states the
problem is simply that
its empire has grown too big and that
means that there aren't there isn't
effective bargaining power
uh by other states in a whole
in many different areas of the world
there's there's very very few uh that
can play off uh support from by china
and a little bit uh supported by russia
very few states are able to do that the
result is
um that there's no accountability
it's my fundamental belief that
institutions organizations
even
families and marriages are kept honest
by people
by the people and organizations involved
having bargaining power they can go
somewhere else when they're [ __ ]
around now the structure of the u.s
empire is such that
that can't happen in most places and
it's had a very corrosive effect within
the united states
because it has led to
an extremely large military and
intelligence sector to a state within a
state
which
i'm sure jeremy could tell you more
about more than 5.1 million
uh
active security clearances now and
probably about another
20 to 30 million people
on their periphery
that has a distorting effect within the
united states and you can see that in a
very
simple uh way a simple easily imaginable
way when you look at ferguson
when you look at the
fruits of occupation and the methods of
occupation uh in afghanistan and iraq
being brought back home literally in the
form of
humvees and body armor
intelligence databases and fusion
centers and so on
so my answer is
smaller empires you have to have a
balance uh just i would say actually we
within a country uh the only thing that
keeps it honest is you know you've got a
balance between the commercial sector
the government sector
the church civil society and the media
it means that people have places to go
that's what keeps a country honest it is
not electoral democracy his ability to
transfer
allegiances and
favors when you're [ __ ] around
the the very last part before [ __ ]
around um uh we we lost you on there the
first clause in that sentence
we know something was [ __ ] around
it's a
what what
what keeps societies decent regardless
of their form whether they're monarchies
whether they're dictatorships whether
it's authoritarian capitalism
uh or or some form of electoral democrac
democracy is the ability
to transfer
support and allegiance from one power
group to another
uh when you get [ __ ] around
uh you've got options
now we understand the exclamation point
that's what keeps a society
okay next question uh hi there uh i am a
history teacher in new york and this
question comes from my 10th grade
students um and it's very similar to the
one you just answered but
a little more
less less idealistic and more realistic
they want to know what your ideal form
of government is and they say this
because we looked at low voter turnout
in democracies and the way voters vote
and they would like to know what you
have to say about that
well it could be a good thing
why is there low voter turnout because
voting doesn't make any difference right
more or less
it doesn't make much difference compared
to what you might otherwise do with the
time that you spent voting
[Laughter]
i mean i i was involved in an election
in australia um
not my own but
supporting someone else's and
um you know i manned a polling booth and
i did these things because that does
make a difference but actually the time
that you spend voting doesn't make a
difference very very rarely there's just
you're breaking up a little bit there
julian you were just you're just trying
to dissuade all young people from voting
[Laughter]
with very few very few exceptions i
wouldn't bother i would spend the time
you don't become disengaged but i would
spend that time doing something else you
can do you can most people can do
something that is more productive in
relation to society
than spending the time voting
there's going to be an interesting
debate in somebody's history class
tomorrow go ahead
uh hi julian um you mentioned uh
advising edward snowden against going to
latin america from russia um more
specific or generally when countries
offer asylum what are your criteria for
choosing which country gets the refugee
in other words which countries are your
best friends
well it just depends on the person and
what their conflict is
i
founded a foundation together with
governor mcfadden a
journalism professor here they call the
courage foundation it runs edward
snowden's defense fund but it runs a
number of people's
defense funds
and we were involved in
getting someone else out of a asylum in
an embassy in baku uh
his wife actually works for the us
military he's a he's a pro pro-us guy in
relation to azerbaijan and the tussle
there in relation between influenced by
israel the united states
and russia
so that
he ended up go
being transported on the swiss
foreign minister's
jet
it was so it we kind of it ended up
happening something like uh what
we had hoped would happen with nicholas
or from venezuela and edward snowden
you said something sorry
technical problems julian we we missed
it you were just you i think you were
just saying something about that case
versus the snowden case in your hopes
sorry okay there
um there are other people trapped in
embassies around the world um there's
um some ethiopians um senior political
people who have been trapped for more
than uh 20 years in the italian embassy
in ethiopia
emin husseinov
who's
an azerbaijani media activist
more or less
on the pro-us side his wife is a
serviceman
he was trapped until very recently
in the swiss embassy in azerbaijan we
arranged his lawyers and eventually he
came out on a flight during the opening
ceremony of the
european games
he came out he came out on a flight
on the swiss
uh foreign minister's jet
into switzerland and the swiss
government have
stood up for him so it it it just
depends on the political situation as to
who is willing
to
stand up uh for someone's asylum uh in a
legal and political sense um how much
that country is invested uh in the 1951
convention refugees or other asylum
instruments
um
and what the physical threats are uh to
the person and can they be physically
protected in that country
so that basically the answer is
once you've applied all those
constraints there's usually very few
countries left um
you try and it's not it's not a
situation usually where you can pick
from five different countries that's
very very rare
thanks for the question go ahead next hi
julian uh my question is you've
acknowledged um a lot of the victories
that have come from
uh a lot of the documents that you've
gotten you know you're exposing you know
different corruption and different kinds
of activity but have you ever been
contacted or
have acknowledged some of the negative
repercussions that have come from the
exposure in terms of um you know people
who have died whether they be military
assets or intelligence assets and you
know how you acknowledge that in the
grand scheme of of you know considering
what you're doing a
uh positive versus you know whereas some
people see this as a very big you know
life-threatening negative
i'm i'm glad you brought up that
question uh because it's complete
[ __ ]
um
it has been admitted under oath
under oath by the us government
in the chelsea manning trial
that they could not find a single person
who would come
to physical harm
as a result of any
of our alleged
chelsea manning
related uh publications
and it hasn't been alleged as far as i'm
aware
uh
in relation to any of our other
publications either uh now that it's
just a it's a very old rhetorical
technique by governments to try and
divert attention away from a scandalous
news story now if it's a scandalous news
story that involves as it did in this
case
proof
of the us government's involvement in
the
death
we're losing you again and
maiming
of more than 2000 people
in
our side we produced evidence
showing on a
person-by-person basis
the us government's involvement in the
deaths or maiming
in iraq and afghanistan
of 200 000 people
200 000
death
or maiming
records
now
what that publication shows
is the pentagon and ultimately the u.s
political class that backed the invasion
of iraq and afghanistan
covered
in blood
covered in blood
and in some instances
involved in war crimes
and involved in torture
the response to that is simply to make a
diversion along similar lines
but what about the risk could someone
get hurt so we're just documented 200
000 people getting hurt or killed
so
it's it's to try and people are very
sensitive to hypocrisy so you try and
if there's a critique in one area then
the the spin is back in the same
you know in the same direction but it
it it's something that's been used
[Music]
rhetorically with great effect by
governments for
you know for
at least 50 years that i'm aware of
but i don't know of a single case
there may be one but i don't know of a
single case across not just our
publications but everyone's publications
of
information leading to direct reprisals
there's plenty of events where the bbc
for example
uh publishes a scandalous report and
there's a riot and someone dies now
that's happened that's happened many
times
but not in relation to intelligence
information uh or diplomatic records
you know it's interesting julian um
at the intercept you know we have
procedures in place where we give the
government
a chance to respond to stories we're
going to publish
particularly in the case when we're
going to be publishing uh classified
documents and i mean i've
sort of started to advocate a position
that we shouldn't even ask them
because they never actually answer a
question and they always push for
more time and they always give you the
identical
tin can statement so we're having an
internal debate about that at our own
media outlet right now but in in a
recent conversation that we had with
with a representative of a spy
organization
this person was was essentially saying
if you publish this you're going to have
blood in your hands now it was a
ridiculous uh you know notion because it
was it was a very benign piece of
information but it's their default to
say you're going to have blood in your
hands and i had i was so fed up with
hearing this over and over and over that
i finally said
your hands are already drenched in blood
and our editor kicked kicked me under
the table and i was um
but but it's it's it is remarkable it's
often printed without any substantiation
that wikileaks caused uh people to die
and and i think anyone who asked that
question should be required to present
an actual case because the us government
certainly hasn't done so but i'm glad
that that the questioner asked it
because it it often uh comes up and with
that we'll take the next question
hello jillian uh thank you and jeremy
both for your time your voices and your
relentless courage what can an average
tech savvy person do
beyond buy the book give you that
valuable retweet i know you guys love
what can someone do to help encourage
adversarial journalism like you do
and help encourage the next
whistleblower to come forward like tour
bridge relay exit node vpn cover traffic
what can we actually really do
to encourage and support
well it's it's very boring but
um the number one uh is give money
that's um
you know
take whatever your comparative
advantage is
the nsa is scrambling your financial
appeal
[ __ ] those guys
um
it's give it's give
give mon
if you have a comparative advantage that
makes money
say you're a
plastic surgeon
it's a very extreme case
then x advantage and transfer those
resources to others who
where their comparative advantage is
doing that job because they do it the
most efficient way
okay that's a technical and rather
boring answer um otherwise
yeah
defending the right of people to do this
is also quite important so speaking
about a very frank and robust way not
spreading paranoia
um
just
it's uh this is simply an expectation in
a reasonable society that this sort of
work is done um
keeping your eyes and ears open in
relation to sourcing opportunities
for organizations like us and jeremy's
if you you know you hear something
say something but say it to us
if you find something get something give
it to us
and encourage others along the same
along the same direction i'm assuming
you don't want people to report
suspicious bags on the new york subway
to wikileaks
on that front though
i remember when
you know when these companies were
starting to
shut off
wikileaks access to donations
and and then targeting activists who
were involved with
campaigns to oppose that
including paypal which of course pierre
omidyar who
is the funder of the intercept
is one of the founders of ebay and has
never publicly commented on that and i
think he should comment on the paypal
14 and i think he should comment on uh
on this
on this kind of discussion that we're
having now and i'm going to directly ask
him about it uh the next time i i see
him because i think people do deserve to
have an answer to that question
from pierre and other people who were
executives at the time but i recall that
a lot of tech people
ran to the defense of wikileaks in
helping to mirror the site helping to
try to figure out ways to circumvent
this sort of financial censorship of
wikileaks and i i think that there's a
lot of opportunity for freelance tech
savvy people to use their own innovation
when they see whistleblowers or
whistleblowing sites under attack and
and many times we've seen people on
their own initiative step up and do
something far more creative than we
would have thought about even though we
have journalistic resources to do it so
i think
obviously you should donate money to
causes that you believe in if you have
that money but i do think there's a
unique role that tech savvy people can
play in an era where some of our best
freedom fighters are sitting at their
computer all day long and and i would
just encourage people that as you say
keep your eyes open to ways to bolster
amplify support
the actions of organizations that are
taking risks or dealing with sources
that are taking risks so next question
hi julian my name is cody dolson i'm a
student at the new school i was just
wondering with the
beginning of the u.s election for 2016
and with the public opinion on
whistleblowers like edward snowden how
you see in the future the war against
whistleblowers if you see it advancing
or digressing that sort of thing
in the context of the election
very interesting question we're watching
it closely the
[Music]
bookmakers across 11 different
bookmakers
you can't
for for most of them now you can't even
bet on hillary clinton anymore
not because she's guaranteed to lose
but because
the marginal costs
are more than the payoff what that means
is
the bookmakers think hillary is pretty
close to a dead cert to win
and that has firms a lot over the last
uh 12 months but you know anything can
happen in politics maybe hillary will
have a stroke who knows
but hillary is very likely to win she's
a much more hawkish figure
than
barack obama but under barack obama
we have seen more people prosecuted on
the espionage act than all previous
presidents combined in fact more than
twice as many i think it's up to three
times as many now jeremy
so it's
i uh
i i i
might the reason we're having the
technical problems is that we're hosting
this on hillary's kingdom
there is a
yeah there has been some news reportage
that we're going to that i'm going to be
hillary's worst nightmare and there's
all this
hillary emails that have been released
and all that's quite interesting
actually i'm somewhat sympathetic
to hillary
although we've had our disputes in the
past over
the email scandal
because
it's a
ridiculous over classification
and
it's not surprising
to me
that she has been swept up in absurd
over open classification
scandals and
hillary can't say so herself but of
course the correct defense that she
should be giving
is well most of this classification
stuff is [ __ ]
there might be a moment where the
president
was about to land somewhere
and the details of what hotel he was
staying in
should be
classified for a limited period
to prevent
assassinations that's fine
but we're talking about emails that are
now several years old
so it's very interesting to think what
could still be classified genuinely
classified in those emails there's
nothing there's nothing that could be
genuinely classified in those emails i
tell you what i believe
is classified top secret in those emails
disgraceful efforts
by the united states
to subvert libya
to subvert
syria
to overthrow those governments which has
led uh to the rise of the islamic state
involvement with
saudi and qatar
and turkey in doing that which would be
diplomatically very embarrassing
if it was released
there can it's very unlikely there's
anything in hillary's emails that could
be genuinely classified now by genuinely
classified i mean
according to what's in the law about
classifications uh information which
would threaten the security the genuine
security of a significant fraction of
the population of the united states
i mean i i know that if if there is a
whistleblower out there
that uh
has access to those current cables
uh i'm sure julian wikileaks would be
very happy to publish them and he
certainly would be at the intercept and
i i agree with you i think that
there
you know there are scandals that play
out in public and there are public
secrets and there's investigative
journalism that can poke holes in little
pieces of it
but we don't even we're not even
scratching the you know the iceberg the
tip of the iceberg in what is happening
behind the scenes and that's why this
book is so important uh not just because
of what it reveals about how the
government works but also it shows the
potential for what could happen if we
actually had
transparency that was encouraged rather
than criminalized
that we would have a more
round debate in our societies
about what the moral stance of the
country should be about what national
security actually means
uh about what is the definition of a
terrorist how do you get on a kill list
how do you get off the kill list short
of being killed in a drone strike
we have
multiple administrations democrat
republican constitutional lawyers and
barely literate imbeciles who all have
embraced this idea
that the executive branch is effectively
a dictatorship within the united states
when it comes to dictating who lives and
dies around the world on any given day
we we only have about five minutes left
and i'm sensitive to the fact that we
have four people in line so what i want
to do is ask their cooperation and just
quickly asking your question of julian
one in a row and then we'll give julian
a chance to wrap up here
uh for a few moments so right that's
acceptable everyone just whip through it
in line with what jeremy was saying what
do you see the role of wikileaks in a
functioning democracy and in relation to
that do you see
a manner in which the general populace
can engage with wikileaks without the
inter interlocutor of a journalist
okay next question thanks in advance for
answering um basically i just wanted to
ask basically with wikileaks and with
your writing on edward snort and all
these whistleblowers coming forward and
the culture of intimidation and
suppression against everybody now how
that works in american history and what
it reflects on society because you had
muckraking you had people calling for
standards you had uh the woodward and
bernstein whistleblower on with
watergate and that took nixon out and
that was a demand for transparency and
now what you've seen is no outcry
nothing what you've actually seen is the
media almost cannibalize itself in
attacking journalists who do whistleblow
who do try to instill transparency so
what does that yeah
we got you
that was very fast okay thank you uh
jeremy and julian for everything you've
done and i want to know julian in ev in
all the cables you've read and
published in every what did you find the
most surprising
all right and our last question before
julian answers and last question is just
my name is ian and also thank both of
you and and julian it seems like you
made your name
um challenging power in one way or
another and so i want to echo some of
the questions about your ideal sense of
power relations i i got the impression
you were a big supporter of the
revolution iceland that sort of kicked
out the creditors or you
stopped the creditors from bankrupting
iceland but iceland is also a
scandinavian social welfare state where
unions are very strong and there's a
very strong egalitarian ethos and and
social democracy um is that something
you would support as a sort of bulwark
against power in general in societies
all right that's there's a lot there
julian but i trust you can you can you
can whip through it succinctly
okay try trying the last one first
of course you can't teleport uh
icelandic uh society
iceland has a population 320
uh you can't
transport that to a a country with a
population a hundred
times the size
of the united states or is it a thousand
times the size well you can't transport
that to the united states it's a
it's a has a scaling problem
um
but you can certainly grab some ideas um
in relation to wikileaks
and it's
but if we're talking about taking
actions against bankers sure actually a
lot of our work has been on the
financial industry
some of our earliest biggest cases
biggest attacks on us were from banks
in relation to wikileaks and its role
with journalism more broadly
well people
and we encourage it can interact with us
directly
in fact the majority here's something
very interesting the
majority
not the majority the light the largest
segment of our readers
um
comes from india
the
largest type of readers we have
is not people looking at news
it's not academics although there are
some it's not journalists although there
are some everyday
it is people searching for
who their sister is proposed to marry
they want to check out the groom and see
if he's corrupt or not
it's
people who are wanting to see
who they're going to be engaged in
business
or
it's the many foreign service
departments diplomatic departments and
government departments outside the
united states
that want to
check out
what
people inside the united states have
thought about one
one actor or another one ambassador or
another so
we take a view that
um
the stories that we release are bait the
stories we release are advertising for
something that is much deeper and more
important uh which is a historical
archive a grand library of how states
actually work
um
okay the remaining question was it was
about
in all of the cables that you've read oh
yes what surprised you
the most important one
okay well generally i always answer this
question
the most surprising thing is not a cable
that's precisely what this book is about
the most surprising thing is the grand
sweep of it all
you know the the big structures that's a
that's the surprising thing
uh
how it all knits together
but if you want little vignettes
well
i'll give you two ones in relation to my
present circumstances right now uh i'm
in the united kingdom
there's a conservative government in
power re-elected just this year
and
the principal figures in that
conservative government
um uh william hague uh who's the foreign
minister during the conflict uh i have
here
um david cameron who's the prime
minister and george osborne
who is the treasurer
so here is a cable back from the
american embassy in london back to dc
william hague the prime minister has
come in to the embassy and here's the
report
hague said he david cameron and george
osborne were children of thatcher and
staunch
atlanticists
haight said
whoever enters 10 downing street that's
the british equivalent of the white
house
as prime minister
soon learns of the essential nature of
the relationship with america
he added
we want a pro-american regime
we need it the world needs it
so the current government that i'm
dealing with which is the deployed this
hundred full-time equivalent
surveillance task force around this
embassy are the most disgusting the most
vulgar the most embarrassing
us sucks
imaginable
now there is a secondary question
as to whether
hague was being genuine or not or
whether he was trying to manipulate the
us ambassador
but either either way is quite bad
either it's genuine uh or it's a
machiavellian kind of
panhandling
that the
principal leaders of the british
government have done
the
other
cable
which i think is the the richest
uh
of any one
single cable
concerns
that it just has so much in it it is so
rich
it concerns censorship the kurds
turkey violation of the separation of
powers
and the
false status of scandinavian states
as liberal democracies and how the head
of nato got his job it's all in one
cable oh and barack obama in honor as
well
okay so
there's the kurds they
exist as an ethnic group of about 20 30
million people
in the border regions of turkey
iraq and syria big news at the moment
because of what is happening in syria
and iraq
with the islamic state
they have a tv station or rather they
had a tv station called roj tvs the
largest kurdish language broadcaster
that tv station was destroyed as part of
a
plot
who was in on that plot barack obama the
turks
and the head of nato the head of nato
uh until just recently uh
rasmussen he was the former prime
minister of denmark and he wanted this
plum job as being the head of nato uh
he's a
awful uh
reactionary transit
okay now now denmark has just hacked
your connection
denmark wanted to become head of nato
that's rasmussen you will have seen him
in the past year trying to
foster increasing tensions between the
united states and russia
okay rasmussen for prime minister
denmark he wanted to become head of nato
the u.s and obama also wanted him to be
head of nato the turks
perfectly happy with him being head of
nato but
the way nate works is that each country
has veto power
the turks wanted to destroy
the kurdish language tv station roj the
largest kurdish language broadcaster
what's denmark got to do with it well
denmark
is where
rojtv was headquartered it beams up to
eurostat beams down into the curtis
regions so turkey had been going after
these things in a variety of ways they
tried to allege it was connected to the
pkk they tried to allege that it
displayed too much violence and
therefore fostered terrorism it took
those cases domestically within denmark
and they all failed it was found to be a
perfectly normal tv channel with no
connections to the pkk
but
in the cable
the
prosecutor the equivalent of the
danish
attorney attorney general
and a senior member of the danish
intelligence service pet the equivalent
of the cia of denmark go into the u.s
embassy to have a chat about how they're
going to [ __ ] up
rojtv
because the deal with rasmussen and
obama and nato needs it and the u.s
embassy and the danes are going well
the problem is we haven't been able to
find any of these connections to the pkk
so
let's go after it on tax grounds
let's go after it looking at the content
let's see if we can come up with
creative solutions
and that is precisely what happened
they went after it on content grounds
they said that this kurdish language
broadcaster i was
talking about things too much from the
kurdish perspective that it wasn't
balanced enough in its reporting
about what was happening
in the kurdish-speaking regions of
turkey
and so the danish courts whacked it
as a result of this conspiracy that was
brought that was developed
the case is now before the european
court of human rights the star exhibits
in that case the
kurds have taken the danes to court uh
is
uh are these two cables
one in particular anyway it says that
you know that barack obama has sealed
this deal he's all happy with that
the tv station was wiped out censorship
not merely of one tv station but an
entire
people's an entire language group so
that's how the modern world works
including what you think uh is the
modern pristine world of social
democracies in scandinavia it's not
there it's just a more sophisticated
illusion
and all of that in in just one cable
gives you a sense of the wealth of
information that is housed on wikileaks
site
i want to thank julian assange it's the
middle of the night there for joining us
i think everyone here really was happy
to see you
[Music]
and as julian fades away like the wizard
of oz on the screen uh let's remember as
we leave that chelsea manning is behind
bars edward snowden is in exile julian
is in this embassy and other
whistleblowers have had their lives
ruined have been targeted and are under
tremendous pressure right now
all of you should have have one of these
books make sure you tell your friends
about it talk about it on social media
buy another copy and give it to someone
and most of all be out there in public
whenever the crosshairs are aimed at any
whistleblowers or any journalists thank
you guys thank you verso books thank you
bell house thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
sunday night at eight eastern on
c-span's q a
following the arrest of wikileaks
founder julian assange british home
secretary sajid javed delivered a
statement to members of the house of
commons on the current situation
mr assange who was arrested shortly
before the home secretary's remarks was
living at the ecuadorian embassy in
london for seven years under temporary
asylum
which was later revoked
mr javid outlined the next steps and
later took questions from members
this is 25 minutes
thank you
statement
the secretary of state for the home
department
secretary sajid javid
with permission mr speaker i would like
to make a statement on the arrest of
julian assange
this morning after nearly seven years
inside the ecuadorian embassy mr assange
was arrested for failing to surrender in
relation to his extradition proceedings
he was later also served with a warrant
for provisional arrest pending receipt
of a request for extradition to stand
trial in the united states on charges
relating to computer offenses
his arrest follows a decision by the
ecuadorian government to bring to an end
his presence inside the embassy in
london
i am pleased that president mourinho has
taken this decision and i extend the
uk's thanks to him for resolving this
situation
ecuador's actions recognize that the uk
criminal justice system is one in which
rights are protected and in which
contrary to what mr assange and his
supporters may claim he and his
legitimate interests will be protected
this also reflects the improvements the
uk relationship with ecuador under the
government of president moreno
these are a credit to the leadership of
my right honourable friend the minister
of state for americans and to the
ongoing hard work of foreign office
officials both here in london and quito
mr assange was informed of the decision
to bring his presence in the embassy to
an end by the ecuadorian ambassador this
morning shortly before 10 am
the metropolitan police entered the
embassy for the purpose of arresting and
removing him
all of the police's activities were
carried out pursuant to a formal written
invitation signed by the ecuadorian
ambassador and in accordance with the
vienna convention on diplomatic
relations
i would like to take this opportunity to
also thank the metropolitan police for
the professionalism that they have shown
in dealing with the immediate situation
and during the last seven years
both the uk government and the
ecuadorian government have become
increasingly concerned about the state
of mr assange's health
the first action of the police following
the arrest was to have him medically
assessed and deemed fit to detain
the ecuadorians have made their best
efforts to ensure that doctors chosen by
him have had access inside the embassy
and while he remains in the custody of
the uk we are now in a position to
ensure access to all necessary medical
facilities
proceedings will now begin according to
the court's timetable
under uk law following the provisional
arrest the four extradition papers must
be received by the judge within 65 days
a full extradition request would have to
be certified by the home office before
being submitted to the court after which
extradition proceedings would begin
at this point the decision as to whether
any statutory bars to extradition apply
would be for the uk courts to determine
i will go no further in discussing the
details of the accusations against mr
assange either in the uk's criminal
justice system or in the u.s
but i am pleased that the situation in
the ecuadorian embassy
has finally been brought to an end
mr assange will now have the opportunity
to contest the charge against him in
open court and to have any expedition
request considered by the judiciary it
is right that we implement the judicial
process fairly and consistently with due
respect for equality before the law i
commend this statement to the house
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
the home secretary for his account
of
events
on this island house we're glad that
julian assange will be able to access
medical care treatments and facilities
because there have been worrying reports
about his ill health of course at this
point this is all a matter for the
courts but on this side of the house we
want
to make the point
that the reason we are debating julian
assange this afternoon
even though the only charge he may face
in this country
is in relation to
his
bail hearings
the reason we are debating this this
afternoon is entirely to do with the
whistleblowing activities of julian
assange and wikileaks
it is this whistleblowing activity into
illegal wars mass murder murder of
civilians and corrupts on a grand scale
that has put julian assange in the
crosshairs of the u.s administration
it is for this reason that they have
once more issued an extradition warrant
against mr assange the home secretary
will note that mr assange complained to
the um that he was being unlawfully
detained as he could not leave the
extraordinary embassy without being
arrested and in february 2016 the un
panel ruled in his favor stating that he
had been arbitrarily detained and should
be allowed to walk free and compensated
for his deprivation of liberty liberty
mr assange held that as a significant
victory called the decision binding but
the foreign officers responded by saying
this ruling changes nothing i noticed it
was the foreign office that responded
not the home of this all the ministry of
justice foreign office has no
responsibility for imprisoned next
edition in this country but it is of
course interested in relations with
allies and others
we have precedence in this country in
relation to requests for exhibition to
the u.s when the u.s authorities raise
issues of hacking and national security
i would remind the house of the case of
gary mckinnon in october 2012
when the the current prime minister was
home secretary an extradition request
very similar to this one was
refused
and we should recall what wikileaks
actually disclosed who can forget the
pentagon video footage of a missile
attack in 2007 in iraq which killed 18
civilians and two reuters journalists it
is the monumental amount of leaks such
as this
that lifted the veil on u.s led military
operation in a variety of theaters
none of which has produced a faithful
outcome from the people of those
countries julian assange is not being
pursued to protect u.s national security
he is being pursued because he has
exposed wrongdoing by u.s
administrations and their military
forces and we only have to look at the
treatment of chelsea manning to see what
awaits him if he's extracted to the u.s
miss manning has already been on
incarcerated between 2010 to
2017. she was originally sentenced to 35
years her indefinite detention now is
because she refuses to participate in
partial disclosure which would allow
whistleblowers to be pursued and not the
perpetrators and her human rights and
protections as a transgender woman has
been completely ignored
her human rights as a transgender woman
have been completely ignored and i would
hope members on the
the other side of the house would take
that seriously and what it has to do
with juliana sanji's case is this could
be the type of treatment that he could
expect if he's extradited to the us in
this country we have protections for
whistleblowers including the public
interested close disclosure in 1998 and
others
even if some of us feel these
protections should be more robust
underpinning this legislation is the
correct premise not that anyone can leak
anything they like but there should be
protection afforded to those who take
personal
risk to disclose wrongdoing where that
disclosure serves the public interest
julian assange is at risk of extradition
to the u.s precisely because on this
side of the house we believe he has
disclosed material that is in the utmost
public interest this is now
in the hands
of the british law courts
we have the utmost confidence in the
british legal system but we would say on
this side of the house we would be very
concerned that on the basis of what we
know
julian assange was extradited to the us
mr speaker can i
first of all thank the right honourable
lady for her response
uh
but mr speaker
you know i think the the whole country
if they listen to a response they will
be pretty astounded by the tone that she
has taken
and she talks first of all she started
talking about the reason
for mr assange's uh arrest
and try to come up with all sorts of
justifications herself which have
nothing to do with the reason the reason
mr assange has been arrested is because
he failed to surrender to a uk court
that's why he's been arrested and there
was a provisional arrest warrant which
is subject to extradition proceedings
but that is the usual procedures
procedures under uk
law and there's no one in this country
that is above the law and the right
honourable lady who we should remember
wants to be the home secretary is
suggesting that we should not apply the
rule of law to an individual that's
right she she's she's disagreeing
sitting from her position but she is
implying she's saying actually quite
clearly that mr assange should be not
subject to uk law and that is something
that should worry every any british
citizen should she ever become home
secretary i
i will she she can she can intervene
late if she if the speaker allows her
that's uh that's possible but i i do
wish to finish my comments in response
to hers she also talked about the un as
though the un had some opinion on this
and i'm sure it's not intentional but uh
she would be at risk of uh not giving
quite correct information mr speaker
because the un has no view on the
assange case i think what she was
actually referring to was the view of a
group of uh independent persons that uh
have decided to look at this case they
do not speak for the un in any way
whatsoever
it's a small group of uh individuals
where who came up with a deeply flawed
opinion so suggesting that somehow mr
assange was indefinitely detained in the
uk by the british authorities when in
fact the only person responsible
for mr assange's detention is himself it
was entirely self-inflicted and it's
astonishing the right honourable lady
should even bring up that report and
suggest somehow that it was a u.n view
or a un report and then the right
honourable lady talked about uh the the
u.s request for extradition uh i won't
be drawn into the request recognition
it's rightly a matter for the courts
should the courts deem it correct and
necessary at some point to send it to me
as a request recognition i will consider
it appropriately under uh our laws but
mr speaker
i note that the shadow home secretary
both today and in the past and indeed
the leader of the opposition have
defended assange and wikileaks from
efforts to tackle their illegal activity
they they they could have clarified that
today for the british publicly the right
on lady could have done that on behalf
of the opposition and she didn't so why
is it mr speaker that whenever someone
has a track record of undermining the uk
and our allies and the values we stand
for you can almost guarantee that the
leadership of the party opposite will
support those who intend to do us harm
you can always guarantee that from the
party opposite
dr julian lewis how much has the police
operation cost guarding the embassy and
is there any prospect of recovering any
of this money perhaps from mr assange's
celebrity backers
mr speaker it's an interesting
suggestion of cost recovery uh from my
honorable friend but i i can tell him uh
up to 2015 the figures i have for up to
2015 uh the police operation has cost uh
an estimated 13.2 million pounds
frederick grady
thank you mr speaker i also thank the
home secretary for advancing a statement
i'm sure swift actions and determination
to appear before the house had not been
lost on his audience on the tory back
benches um it's right that nobody is
above the law and in many ways a today's
action has been at least one kind of
deadlock has been broken and that's
perhaps important at least from the
health and well-being point of view but
at the same time human rights under the
law are inviolable
and the treatment that mr assange
receives in the period to come must take
place with appropriate due process and
with respect to the protection of his
rights that the home secretary stresses
so can he confirm that nobody should be
extradited from the united kingdom if
they face an unfair trial or a cruel and
unusual punishment in the destination
country and can he also assure us that
any judicial process here in the united
kingdom will be carried out with as much
transparency as possible and with all
appropriate opportunity for review and
appeal as necessary
mr speaker i'm actually very happy to to
agree with the honourable gentleman what
he said
that this country has a long and proud
tradition of uh human rights and when it
comes to extradition requests wherever
they may come from uh it is absolutely
right that the courts and the government
consider an individual's human rights
um
and so this uh story moves to its
conclusion having cost the british
taxpayer
millions of pounds uh having ruined
relations during that period between uh
ecuador and the united kingdom and i
very much hope that those relations can
now be
uh sustained and nurtured
but let me just say two things if i may
mr speaker we should not allow mr
assange to get away with the idea one
that he was arbitrarily detained which
is ridiculous when he could have walked
out of that door any one time and
secondly the fact that he had no charges
to answer originally in sweden because
the swedish prosecutor would have needed
to interview him personally something
that he never allowed her to do
those two
facts need to be put
right in the middle of this ridiculous
story
mr speaker my right honourable friend
has made a number of uh important points
and uh he also refers to our
relationship with ecuador uh which is uh
very good and i think uh today's uh
outcome shows that and as i said and i
will say again thanks to the the hard
working efforts of the minister of state
for the americas and the foreign office
uh those relationships are very strong
uh today and and when it comes to mr
assange's detention uh my right
honourable friend is absolutely right to
remind the house the detention this is a
self-inflicted detention this was a
decision by mr assange to lock himself
up for seven years
unc lucas thank you mr speaker i'm
pleased that the right animal gentleman
mentioned sweden because the home
secretary didn't mention sweden and the
fact that there was the proceedings in
sweden which led as i understand it to
the to the warrant being issued
originally
is it in fact the case that the swedish
proceedings will be continuing and if
there is any
competitive aspect between the swedish
prosecution and the united states
prosecution how will that be resolved
mr speaker i can tell the honourable
gentleman that the original
exhibition request was a swedish
extradition request but then at a later
date the swedish authorities chose to
withdraw their request whether there is
a an existing or new swedish request i
can either confirm uh or deny and should
there be for any individual more than
one extradition request that would be
dealt in the usual way by the courts
correct
bob cd
mr speaker i understand the extradition
the potential expedition to the us is in
relation to the half a million leaked
documents in the chelsea manning case
would you agree that as a more serious
and disturbing case potentially against
julian assange for his and wikileaks
role
in the kremlin's 2016 attempts to
interfere and manipulate the us
presidential elections when wikileaks
was used by russian military
intelligence the giu as the primary
vehicle to disseminate the stolen
documents hacked by the giu from the
democratic party and while some see him
as an information war hero others see
him as a useful stooge of an
authoritarian state
mr speaker i'm sure my honorable friend
would uh understand it be inappropriate
for me to
refer to any
accusations that may or may not be made
against mr assange
but i understand that my honorable
friend has talked about this on a number
occasion including as i understand it
today in the world that one he's very
articulate and i'm sure that many people
would have heard him mr edward davey can
i thank the home secretary for his
statement and clearly today's arrest is
correct
uh but looking ahead will the home
circle confirm that any extradition
requests in the united states will be
considered by the home office and
including in that consideration there
will be a public interest test
consideration and a press freedom
consideration and indeed that any court
hearing extradition
case uh would it would also be able to
consider a public interest test and a
press freedom defense secretary
mr speaker i thank the one old general
for his uh support for today's action
and
in relation to what happens next uh with
respect to the acquisition uh request
that will be
in the first instance it's a matter for
the courts uh there will be once a full
extradition request is received uh my
department will receive that and we will
determine whether it is uh certifiable
or not but after that it will go to the
courts and the courts will have to make
the initial decisions according to our
law steer
thank you mr speaker
julian assange says apparently that his
personal space has been violated which
is a bit rich considering the number of
people who've been put in extreme danger
among our allies
name secretary
perhaps might be appropriate mr speaker
to
draw uh attention to the statement today
from president mourinho of ecuador where
and i quote he said that to today i
announced that the discourteous and
aggressive behavior of mr julian assange
uh has uh led him uh to his actions so
it it does tell you something in itself
donna johnson mr speaker i'm really
concerned that uh a man suspected of
rape which is what in this case actually
happened was able to
do what he did for several years to
escape justice and i've seen remedia
reports that lawyers for the victims in
sweden
are taking steps to try and start the
proceedings off again i wondered if the
home secretary might be able to
investigate that and let the house know
because i'm sure there are many members
of parliament who are very anxious about
this matter
mr speaker i do i do understand very
much uh
the uh the concerns of the honorable
lady and again it would be inappropriate
for me to talk about any accusations
that have been made by whether it's from
sweden or elsewhere against uh
mr assange
she may want to reflect her the
honourable lady on the words that were
actually used by her front branch and
actually in the past in in december 2010
7th december 2010 the right honourable
lady that is now the shadow home
secretary uh was openly tweeting her
support for mr assange and the
honourable lady on the on the opposition
back ventures might want to actually
reflect on the leadership she's
receiving from her own front bench
mr speaker the right honourable
gentleman uh certain is right to praise
press freedom and i know their home
secretary is an advocate for press
freedom but whatever the shadow home
secretary says is it not the case that
responsible journalists do not play fast
and loose with the national interest and
put our people in danger when it should
not be happening
yeah
mr
speaker my my honorable friend a
distinguished former journalist himself
is absolutely right in what he said
press freedom in this country is
sacrosanct but what we find is that by
and large uh people that work in the
press in this country are responsible
clive effort thank you mr speaker i i
find it extraordinary that somebody's
just rich and powerful or powerful
anyway can just avoid
an allegation of the rapist of being a
rapist in the way that julian assange
has done for so many years costing so
much taxpayers money can the uh
secretary of state can the home
secretary tell us who is paying the bill
for the uh 13.2 million pounds that
julian assange has uh has cost us is it
is it the people of london in cuts to
their police service or does it come
from a central budget
mr speaker again i do understand very
much the uh the sentiment of the
honorable gentleman i think he speaks
for for many people across that house
the answer to who's paid that bill and i
referred earlier to the 13.2 million up
to uh 2015 uh that has come from various
sources but each one of those are the
british taxpayers and that's why they
would welcome justice that's being done
today
stephen kerr
speaker it's right and proper that my
right honourable friend the home
secretary secretaries paid tribute to
the minister of state for europe and the
americas for the workings but it's also
appropriate to pay tribute to the
strength the resilience and the patience
of the british diplomatic service
yes mr speaker i very much agree with my
old friend and in particular if i may is
uh pick out the british ambassador in
ecuador who has been absolutely
brilliant in how she has pursued this
how she has worked with uh her
counterparts in ecuador and ecuadorian
ministers and others and indeed the the
ministers in the foreign office
ross thompson thank you very much mr
speaker can i join my right honourable
friend in sending our gratitude to
president mourinho for his decision and
does he agree with me that it is totally
right that mr assange will now face
justice and that he will do so in the
proper way with the proper protections
of the british legal system
absolutely i can give that assurance to
my honorable friend uh today is a very
good day uh for justice the the british
legal system our defense of the rule of
law
and the fairness of our legal system is
world-renowned and that is exactly what
mr assange will receive
my word thank you mr speaker i joined
honourable members in thanking my
writing will friend for his statement
and the metropolitan police for their
effective action uh this morning the
ecuadorian president has indicated that
julian assange repeatedly violated the
conditions of his asylum at the embassy
does my writing befriend have any
further details of such violations
uh mr speaker the first of all can i
join my honourable friend and uh
in his thanks for the metropolitan
police who have uh for many years done
an outstanding job but today uh
certainly in in making sure mr assange
was arrested and presented in front of
the courts and um the
he asked me about the ecuadorian uh
government i might point his attention
uh to the statement that's been made
today
in a video message by president mourinho
and uh he has talked there about how mr
assange in the opinion of the president
uh has been discourteous and aggressive
and uh there and makes a number of
accusations against mr assange which is
one of the reasons that the president
decided as a sovereign decision of the
ecuadorian state to remove what they
call diplomatic asylum
[Applause]
tonight on the c-span networks some of
today's hearings on president trump's
2020 budget proposal
at 8 p.m eastern on c-span acting
defense secretary patrick shanahan enjoy
sunday night at 8 eastern on c-span's q
a
washington journal continues
and we are back we'll finish up today's
washington journal with your reaction to
the arrest of julian assange the new
york times front page this morning with
the headline a device a divisive prophet
of the public's right to know mr assange
they write has always elicited fervent
reactions he has been hailed as a hero
of free information or despised as a
treacherous criminal worthy of death by
drone often depending on what wikileaks
had recently been up to
we want to know do you agree disagree
with the new york times the way they
frame mr assange this morning also his
arrest and possible extradition which
the paper's note could take years for it
to happen and then a court case awaits
him here in the united states the
washington post front page case aims to
skirt first amendment concerns under
secretary general jeff sessions the
former attorney general excuse me
prosecutors dusted off an investigation
and discussed how the anti-secrecy
organization's founder could be charged
without running a foul of press freedoms
this is how
this arrest came about under the federal
law governing computer crimes
prosecutors faced a deadline to file
charges within eight years of the 2010
disclosures that put him in their
crosshairs the single count indictment
unsealed in alexandria federal court
yesterday shows they did so just under
the deadline and it accuses assange of
conspiring to help
chelsea manning
to hack into the government's computers
in order to disclose uh the information
that was then put out to the public and
the washington po post notes that this
law that they are trying to prosecute
mr assange under is from 1984. it's the
computer fraud and abuse act america's
premier anti-hacking statute that law
prohibits accessing a computer without
authorization in the one the 35 year old
legislation has long been dogged by
critics who say the law is so vague that
it's been abused to go after relatively
innocuous behavior that happens every
day
richard in albuquerque new mexico
republican richard good morning what's
your reaction to the news
yes um i'm commenting on this weekly
listing look i think no matter where he
gets uh persecuted or not i think that
this is really great because it
expresses and and explores and opens up
what the democratic party is doing
and i don't think there was nothing
wrong with it because the democratic
heart is hiding a lot of stuff
that
citizens of the united states don't know
nothing about
okay okay richard jonathan turley who's
been a guest on this program
and is a professor at a professor a law
professor at george washington
university
writes this morning washington will
crucify assange he is our property
that's a quote those celebratory words
of senator joe manchin came on cnn soon
after the news of the arrest of
wikileaks founder julian assange it was
a sentiment shared by virtually everyone
in washington assange committed the
unpardonable sin of embarrassing the
establishment from members of congress
to intelligence officials to the news
media and he will now be punished for
our sins despite having significant
constitutional arguments to be made it
is likely that he will be stripped of
those defenses and even barred from
raising the overall context of his
actions in federal court what could be
the most important free speech and free
press case in our history could well be
reduced to the scope and substance of an
unauthorized computer access case
wikileaks disclosed a massive and
arguably unconstitutional surveillance
program impacting virtually every u.s
citizen it later published emails that
showed that the dnc and the campaign of
hillary clinton lied in various
statements to the public including the
rigging of the primary for her
nomination no one has argued that any of
these emails were false they were
embarrassing the criminal charge against
assange filed in a federal court was
crafted to circumvent the constitutional
problems in prosecuting him by alleging
that he played a role in chelsea
manning's hacking operation in 2010 the
government is seeking to portray him as
part of the theft rather than the
distribution of the information if
assange helped manning secure a password
to gain access to additional information
that would be a step that most news
organizations would not take and this is
what the washington post editorial board
is arguing today that this case does not
jeopardize the first amendment or or
journalists
because he stopped being a journalist
when he accessed that computer and
committed a crime what are your thoughts
brit in baldwin missouri independent
brick good morning to you
good morning yes i think the real crime
was committed by
chelsea bradley manning
with her security clearance and the
release of the thousands of classified
documents there's certainly some
hypocrisy here especially with the
pardon of manning
and the full on charge against julian
assange i don't think there's a lot of
difference between
what's going on there and
the pentagon papers okay but manning
just to clarify manning was not pardoned
his sentence was communed which means
the the obama administration said that
he had served his time and he was let
out of jail
could you imagine having a secret top
secret clearance
and uh doing all that and then
escape with the little bit of prison
time that he had
served i was in the government myself on
dod and we were you know we would lose
our
jobs um our pensions
uh serve prison time with all that sort
of thing i just can't imagine with
bradley manning chelsea manny getting
off as lightly as she did you know and
then the full-on charge against
julian assange so so brady if you
believe that
chelsea manning committed a crime by
accessing that computer and if the
government can prove that julian assange
helped him at the time him access the
computer
is he not then part of the crime
well that is to be proven i'm just re
you know giving you my feelings on what
i've heard over the news over the years
and my understanding is that uh
julian
really was just accepting the
information that
chelsea was sending to him
it was just amazing absolutely amazing
thousands and thousands of documents
i don't know okay okay bert sauce there
dennis in port st lucie florida democrat
hi good morning greta good morning
i i think mr assange would want to come
over here to tell his story and shed
some light his light on recent history
here in america and around the world and
what do you mean by that
well he's got a story to tell here's his
opportunity the biggest stage
maybe the biggest story uh
of recent history whether or not there
were
uh elements of our political parties
cooperating with agents from other
countries around the world he
he just may hold
the key to the truth here okay dennis in
florida lane
in north carolina republican lane help
me with your town what is it
yes um i was calling about the
julian assange yes that to comment um
there's thinking that hillary clinton
when she was secretary of state she
committed treason uh when her and bill
clinton went to russia and he did a
speech with the russians for like 500
000
and she sold 20 of our uranian
to vladimir putin
for
i understand she got 148 million dollars
and if she got 148 million i'd like to
know how much obama got she couldn't
have done this alone
and
i'd like to know where i could call
and get my share
of the
money i mean why why should her and
obama get to keep all the money it was
all the americans uranium so why can't
um if it was sold why does her and obama
get to keep all the money i'd like my
share and the other americans would like
their share of the money
also okay all right lane karen in
washington an independent hi karen
good morning i just wanted to comment
that i have been paying attention to
some of the information
that has been coming out recently about
a whistleblower
group that julian assange was part of
called secure drop
and i hadn't been aware of this until
just recently
but there were
several members of secure drop within
the last couple of years
who have died mysteriously
and it's a little unclear if the group
was infiltrated and the people who were
members of secure drop or
were killed um or whether they they
truly died of unusual causes
but um the important thing
that i take away from it is that it
tells me that we need a better mechanism
for whistleblowers to be able to
communicate information
about
wrongdoings within our government if we
don't have that
then it's hard to understand exactly how
we keep our government
on the straight and narrow and i think
when
all is said and done in terms of
pursuing julian assange
with legal charges at the end of the day
i think it may very much be a situation
like joe arpaio where
what he did was um something that we
need all journalists to do but he will
be prosecuted for it and may be
deserving of a pardon at the end of the
day okay so karen you're touching on
something that margaret sullivan writes
in her column for the washington post
that
the the
method by which
julian assange access this information
is
uh
is
in this digital age
techniques that journalists use
and she writes in her column quoting
people saying in the context of a
criminal conspiracy using encryption
making efforts to protect a source's
identity and source cultivation
um university of georgia media law
professor jonathan peters tells sullivan
that
he's he employed journalistic practices
and there is where there could be gray
area when prosecuting him and a possible
threat to the first amendment lisa in
tampa florida democrat lisa good morning
what do you think
good morning how are you i am really
kind of on the fence
i believe in our first amendment the
freedom of speech
you know the press
um however i really think there's
something going on with this julian
assange i don't believe he's above board
and just a journalist
what he did was clearly
breaking the law
under the
guidelines of what they're showing us he
did
of course everyone is innocent until
proven guilty
but i think he's actually twisted the
first amendment to be able to break the
law
but i agree with your last caller about
there should definitely be better
mechanisms and ways for whistleblowers
to come out because we do have an
imperfect government they're we're human
we all make mistakes we all break the
law
some break the law and we need that way
of bringing out the bad to to get rid of
it and make it good but i really think
that a lot of people are going overboard
with julian assange
and i do believe he's a criminal okay
lisa and others take a look at the
headlines on the opinion pieces that
have surfaced since his arrest here's
one with the headline is julian assange
a journalist or is he just an accused
thief you also have this the wikileaker
is about to face melancholy music
other headlines julian assange tucker
carlson saying assange's real sin was
preventing hillary clinton from becoming
president
and julian assange got what he deserved
writes one writer don't fall
for his uh sympathy please
we're getting your reaction to the news
of his arrest let's go to seth in
tennessee a republican hi seth hey
hey good morning good morning uh you're
handling you're handling this situation
very well
well what do you think
um well what i'd like to know is uh when
wikileaks
publishes how much they paid aaron rich
and then they get his bank records
okay seth thoughts in tennessee terry
lafayette indiana and independent
good morning america yeah this
shows me how corrupt our government is
uh we need more people like asajj
and it's just terrible when it is like
for instance the prohibition of alcohol
there were no
alcohol gangs so they passed the alcohol
laws after they passed those laws the
murder and the crime rate went up 70
percent there were no drug gangs until
they passed the drug laws after they
passed them the murder crime rate
doubled up a hundred percent
they kept the prohibition of alcohol
over 13 years it proved everyone caused
nothing but murder crime and corruption
so they repealed that law the murder in
the crime rate goes back down 70 percent
broke up all your murderous alcohol
gangs all right territory in indiana
we're getting people's reaction this
morning to the news of julia assan's
arrest
in from the ecuadorian embassy in london
he now faces extradition
to the united states and david ignatius
writes this morning in his column does
the first amendment protect
julian assange an intriguing footnote to
the assange case is that as part of a
failed plea bargain negotiation with the
justice department in 2017 he offered to
help vet some highly classified ci cia
files that wikileaks was publishing in a
document dump known as vault 7. as i
wrote last september this risk
mitigation discussion collapsed after
wikileaks revealed some especially
sensitive cia hacking techniques assange
could argue that the 2017 offer showed
he was sensitive to national security
concerns similarly he could point to his
a cooperation with the new york times
and other news organizations that edited
and vetted wikileaks files before
publication
complicating this case is wikileaks role
in disseminating documents hacked by the
russian intelligence from democrats
during the 2016 presidential campaign
when assange appeared to be a tool of
russian meddling to support donald trump
assange wants to fight his case under
the banner of press freedom his problem
is that the justice department has drawn
its in
indictment carefully enough that the
issue is theft of secrets rather than
their publication that's why so many
press advocates seemed to be distance
distancing themselves from assange after
the news broke yesterday william in
jersey city democrat hi william
hey how you doing um so yeah i just
wanted to make a comment uh i don't
really have an opinion either way of the
whole chelsea manning situation but i
was listening to the program and i
noticed that it sounded like you were
kind of misgendering her so chelsea
manning like regardless of where you
stand she is a woman not a man so i just
want to make sure that you know you
gender her appropriately and i was
referring to um
bradley manning at the time
was uh working with julian assange it
right it reads like this in the
washington uh post with assange's arrest
u.s and british authorities ended a
seven year saga in which the
anti-secrecy crusader stayed just beyond
their reach while his group dumped
classified and politically volatile
materials into the internet u.s
prosecutors confirmed for the first time
that they had secretly charged assange
last year with conspiring with an army
intelligence analyst to illegally obtain
secret u.s military and diplomatic
documents which is which assange's group
published online he is accused of
helping chelsea manning the formerly the
former soldier then known as bradley
manning perhaps unsuccessfully try to
crack a government password
michael in game bros maryland republican
yes hi how's it going thanks for having
me good morning
yeah um i you know i actually support uh
what julian assange has done uh i think
it's a great thing i mean if we can look
back at uh the video that he showed us
uh with the helicopter pilots shooting
on those people i mean they were clearly
not armed and you know that
that that's really just a horrible thing
to do and to be involved with and i'm
i'm glad that he that someone said
something that told the rest of the
country what's going on and the whole
thing with bradley manning or or
whatever i mean i i you know i i think
that that whole
that whole thing is just it's kind of
mentally ill but uh you know i i don't
hate the guy you know i i respect what
he did
if something's wrong you have to stand
up and say what's right you know and
that's and that's what being american is
all about and others point to the nsa
surveillance program that americans were
made aware of this program because of
wikileaks
yeah exactly uh i i i totally support
that uh you know wikileaks is known for
its honesty uh the new york times the
washington post they both quote
wikileaks they've been doing it for
years
uh so
um hopefully hopefully c-fan has them
more about wikileaks too because i
actually like their news uh their news
broadcast myself okay
michael there in gamble's maryland jane
is in dana point california independent
hi jane
hi um i wanted to make clear um that
wikileaks is a publishing company and
there's a suspicious stiff
excuse me there's a law that protects
that um they didn't break any laws
there's no criminal
the criminal intent is to act like
julian assange
broke in himself or created a password
this is a made-up charge
the fact that wikileaks exposed the
election fraud is enormously important
and um why he got arrested okay richie
in virginia democrat richie what do you
think
uh yeah i'd like to just point out that
the crime that he's being indicted on
has a five-year statute of limitations
and the crime was committed over eight
years ago
um there was a
thing i think was the washington post
this morning addressed that saying that
under the federal law government under
the federal law governing computer
crimes prosecutors faced a deadline to
file charges within eight years of the
2010 disclosures that put them in their
crosshairs and according to the single
count indictment
they did so just under that deadline
richie
well yes but they're also trying to
append it as a terroristic act to extend
the statute of limitations on it
okay richie in virginia
jared in
lawrenceville georgia republican
garage
sorry go ahead
i think that
trump administration needs to leave him
alone
i don't know if they're trying to get
information out of them about who leaked
the wikileaks but that's the only thing
i want to know who really leaked them to
him
if they said it was somebody in this
country it wasn't a russian
i like to know that now like i say trump
should leave him alone
okay all right
paul las vegas republican paul
yes ma'am good morning
uh as far as julian assange goes
uh i don't believe that he should be
prosecuted if he should be prosecuted so
should all the pundits that are on tv
the democrats that receive
information from government officials
that they broadcasted on tv and turned
out to be
false information if the sun is to be
prosecuted they should be prosecuted
also for receiving information and
broadcasting it that's my opinion thank
you very much ma'am okay all right the
president yesterday was asked about this
news of the arrest
the question was to him do you still
love wikileaks the president responding
i know nothing about wikileaks it's not
my thing
tim in minnesota independent
yeah um
i i uh
i'm kind of amazed at how
uh people are kind of glossing over the
the issue of uh mass surveillance and
it's a common denominator with edward
snowden chelsea manning
and uh julian assange
and it's to me
it's just it's just another fine mess
the democratic the two big money parties
got us into
and it just it's keeping people fighting
you know and
yep that's what i wanted to say okay all
right tim thomas fredericksburg virginia
democrat
what would you like to say this morning
thomas
uh
fine how are you
fine
what do you think about the arrest of mr
assange
i think that
the doj and barr and the trump
administration will use
assange to get information on um the
democratic uh surveillance and uh
uh help that use that to help them
indict them
i think there's a lot going on behind
the scenes that we're not aware of okay
that will be revealed later okay and as
we've noted the the papers this morning
reporting it'll take years um to
extradite mr assange and uh the bbc is
reporting this morning that uh jeremy
corbyn the labor leader in that country
is saying he should not be extradited to
the united states washington post says
more charges are probably forthcoming
prosecutors have 60 days to present a
final case to authorities in britain the
grand jury investigating assange is
still active and chelsea manning is
being held in jail for refusing to
testify before it the virginia
prosecutors have also been in touch with
federal prosecutors in new york who are
probing the disclosures of cia cyber
tools according to people familiar with
those conversations the same u.s
attorney's office in manhattan had in
2011 started to develop a hacking
conspiracy case against assange based on
wikileaks possible efforts to embarrass
the icelandic government according to
several senior law enforcement officials
prosecutors had hoped to build a case
against assange by charging and then
flipping one of the islamic associates
and had even drafted a complaint to do
so new york was told to stand down
because virginia was pursuing an
espionage investigation
special counsel robert mueller also
accused russian intelligence officers of
working with wikileaks to disseminate
democratic emails in 2016
but prosecutors and alexandria have not
indicted that
that their case goes beyond the 20 have
not indicated that their case goes
beyond the 2010 leaks
uh steve in pennsylvania republican hi
steve good morning to you
yes
good morning thank you for taking my
call i just want to
i just want to mention that
the press the free press actually can
receive classified information
um and can release classified
information from any sources because
they have to they don't have to divulge
their uh
their sources and also i just want to
correct corporea that previous caller
said that bradley manning used to be a
man and he changed his uh sex to female
that's why
today they refer her
to chelsea manning
he changed his uh
his physical identity so i just wanted
to clear that up thank you for taking my
call okay steve michael highland new
york a republican michael
yes i just have an open comment um i'm
just calling about the person that got
upset and
defended chelsea manning before i mean
that's i think that's why you don't
need to have transgender in the military
they're too touchy thank you
all right we will leave it uh there this
morning uh and uh
thank you all for your phone calls uh
this morning on today's washington
journal we'll be back
tomorrow morning 7 a.m eastern time
enjoy your friday enjoy your weekend
[Music]
you